BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER THREE ON.
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES ALL
WELCOME EVERYONE TODAY. AND TO
US. BEGIN BY- FIRST OF ALL-
GOING OVER SERVE OUR BASIC-
RULES- SO BASICALLY WE WILL BE
HEARING THE ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA. COME OUT- AFTER EACH
DEPARTMENT FOR THIS HEARING WE
WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENTS SO
AFTER WE GO THROUGH THE ISSUES
FOR EACH DEPARTMENT WILL THEN
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT- IN TERMS
OF THE HEARING ITSELF- WE
USUALLY HAVE AND AN OPENING
FOR. ASIAN BY THE AGENCY
FOLLOWED BY COMMENTS FROM THE
LA AND PARTMINER FINANCE. THE
PROPOSAL FOR INVEST WE MAY ALSO
OF. THE SPONSORS OF THAT
PROPOSAL- GIVE A PRESENTATION I
ASKED OF THOSE PRESENTATIONS BE
NO LONGER THAN THREE MINUTES-
AND THEN- YEAH AND WE WILL
HAVE- ASK FOR COMMENTS AND OF
COURSE BE QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND THAT THIS
OPPORTUNITY FOR MORE PROLONGED.
DESCRIPTION IF THAT IN TERMS
OF- MAKING POSITIONAL COMMENTS
AND THEN FOR PUBLIC COMMENT-
WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENTS AT
THE BACK MICROPHONE WE ASK THAT
YOU- TRY LIVING YOUR PUBLIC
COMMENT TO A MINUTE- AND IF YOU
HAVE ANY MATERIALS- WRITTEN YOU
CAN PROVIDE THAT TO THE
SERGEANTS ARE DIRECTLY TO THE
COMMITTEE SO- YOU COULD. KLAY
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE JUST
SIR STICK TO THE HIGHLIGHTS AND
AB HAVE SOMETHING. A LETTER OR
SOMETHING ELSE YOU CAN ALSO
SUBMIT THAT AND WRITING- TO THE
COMMITTEE AS WELL- SO AGAIN
WANT TO WELCOME. EVERYONE HERE
FOR THIS VERY FIRST HEARING OF
THIS SESSION. OF THE- BUT JUST
IN FISCAL REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER THREE AND HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES TODAY WE WILL BE
FOCUSING ON OVERSIGHT THE
CALIFORNIA PART OF AGING AND
VARIOUS PROGRAMS UNDER
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES.
INCLUDING COMMUNITY CARE
LICENSING ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES- SS I SS P. N. I. HSS.
ALL ITEMS HER TODAY WILL BE
HELD OPEN WE'RE NOT TAKING ANY
FORMAL THOSE TODAY. AND AGAIN
AS I MENTIONED THAT WILL BE
TAKING PART PUBLIC COMMENT
AFTER EACH DEPARTMENT. AND WITH
THAT ACTUALLY- WOULD ASK-
SECRETE PLEASE THE ROLE TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. SENATOR PAN
HERE. REPORTER WITH. CENTER
DATA HERE. OKAY SO WHAT LET'S
GO AHEAD AND- BEGIN WITH FIRST
THE DEPARTMENT AGING AND SO WE
CAN ASK THE PARK AGING TO COME
UP AND THEN WE WILL AND ALSO
THE- RESPECT REPRESENTS THE ON
THE PART FINANCE AND BEFORE WE-
GET THE PRESENTATION JUST ASK
EVERYONE AROUND THE TABLE-
INTRODUCE THEMSELVES FOR THE
RECORD- AND THEN WE'LL BEGIN
WITH ISSUE NUMBER ONE. SO
WELCOME AND SO WE CAN BEGIN
WITH THE INTRODUCTIONS OF THE
FROM THE REPRESENTS AND
DEPARTMENT AGING. GOOD MORNING
CHEMICALLY WAY DIRECTOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF AGING
IN. HELLO THOMAS KAMIN W.
DIRECTOR ADMINISTRATION FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING THANK YOU.
HELLO JACKIE BRAZIL BELIAU YOU
FINANCE BRING HAUSER DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. HI ONE DIFFERENT
FINANCE OKAY THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT SO LET'S- GO HEAD BEGIN
WITH THE ISSUE NUMBER ONE WHICH
THE MASTER PLAN ON AGING
UPDATE- AND WE DO HAVE A
WRITTEN THIS IS A IN THE AGENDA
SO IF YOU WANTED TO STEP
PARTICULARLY TOUCH ON IT'S AN
UPDATE AND- ADDRESS THE
QUESTIONS I THINK WE SENT. TO
YOU IN ADVANCE THANK YOU
WELCOME THANK YOU I THANK YOU
SO MUCH TO CENTER PAN AND
CENTER HER TADO AND FOR BEING
SUCH A CHAMPIONS AND OUR
PARTNERS ON THE MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING FOR ROUND TABLES IN YOUR
DISTRICT- EARLIER IN THE FALL
AND THEN. MONDAY LOOKING FOR TO
IT. THE MASTER PLAN FOR AGING
ARE BEGINNING JUNE WITH THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER OF OUR GOVERNOR
AND WE HAVE BEEN. WORKING VERY
HARD WITH WHAT THE STAKEHOLDER
WORKGROUP. AND THE CABINET WORK
GROUP TO DEVELOP A FRAMEWORK
WHICH YOU SEE THE- WE JUST
PUBLISHED THIS WEEK OUR SPRING
PROGRESS REPORT WHICH I HOPE
YOU HAVE A LECTURE. BILLION
HARD COPIES ARE COMING. WHICH
LAYS OUT THE VISION THE
MISSION. THE VALUES IN THE
GOALS- WE TALKED VERY MUCH
ABOUT BEING DATA DRIVEN THE BIG
THE BIG THING ABOUT AGING IS
NOT JUST THAT MORE OF US ARE
DOING IT THAT THE AGING. REALLY
CHANGING. WE'RE DIVERSITY SUPER
SO FAR MORE OF US. PHONE
PROFESSOR BASING POVERTY AND
MORE OF A SIX. MANY DIFFERENT
STAGES OF AGING. WE ALL KNOW UP.
NOW WE HAVE A BRAND NEW EQUITY
WORKERS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE. CELEBRATING WHEN HIS RIVER
CITY AND BEING RIGHT. I PLAN. A
PRESSING. BUT THE APP THAT'S
NOT. FIRST COMMUNITY. WERE
ENGAGED. CAN YOU THROUGH. A
WEBSITE IN. LANGUAGE EDITION
CHINESE AND WEB IN OUR-
THEORIES EVERY WEEK. WHAT I IS
REALLY INTERESTING IS WERE
COMMITTING NOW ENGAGED TO
RECKON. SO IN OUR MARCH MEETING
WE RECEIVED OUR OFF FIRST SET
OF RECOMMENDATIONS ADDRESSING
LONG TERM SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
FROM THE STAKEHOLDERS. THEY ARE
FINALIZING THAT REPORT IT'LL BE
TRANSMITTED IN A MATTER OF A-
BEFORE THE END OF THE MONTH
PRETTY EXECUTIVE ORDER BUT IT
LAYS OUT A FRAMEWORK FOR THE
SYSTEM OF CARE AROUND SERVICES
AND SUPPORTS EMPHASIZING THE
IMPORTANCE OF A CONSUMER
INFORMATION AND NAVIGATION
ACCESSIBILITY. AFFORDABILITY
THE WORK FORCE AND STATE LOCAL
STRUCTURES SUPPORTING THE
SYSTEM OF CARE SO THAT THE
ROBUST REPORT COMING WITHOUT TO
THE LEGISLATURE I BELIEVE A
HUNDRED FOR RECOMMENDATIONS
LAST TIME I SAW- AND A LIST OF
ABOUT A COUPLE DOZEN THAT THEY
CONSIDER OPTIONAL. READY ALSO
THAT ROOM. THANKS TO HIM. THEN
WILL BE AGAIN IN MAY.
RECOMMENDED ON LIVABLE
COMMUNITIES AND PURPOSE. HEALTH
AND WELL BEING- AND ECONOMIC
SECURITY SAFETY IN DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS. N JUNE WILL GO
OUT TO THE WHOLE STATE IN A
CAPSTONE EVENT TO MAKE SURE WE
HEARD IT AND GOT IT RIGHT- AND
THEN OUR FINAL STAKEHOLDER
MEETING IN AUGUST WILL BE
PRESENTING THE ADMINISTRATION'S
INITIAL OUTLINE AND THOUGHTS
ABOUT THE MASTER PLAN ALL
LEADING UP TOWARD THE DEADLINE
THE EXECUTIVE ORDER. OF OCTOBER.
I THINK I'LL JUST TAKE A ONE
MORE MOMENT TO HIGHLIGHT. SOME
TOPICS AND THEMES THAT COME UP.
IN ALMOST EVERY CONVERSATION-
IN THE- AS YOU MIGHT IMAGINE-
ONE OF THE TOPICS HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS OF COURSE. ALL AT
IN A VARIETY OF ISSUES
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING INNOVATIVE HOUSING LIKE
HOME SHARING- AGAIN THE NEED
FIRST SYSTEM OF CARE AROUND
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS. ANOTHER
BIG ISSUE IS ISOLATION AND
INCLUSION AND PURPOSE MAKING
SURE THAT THIS WEEK REALLY
ISN'T EQUITY IN CIVIL RIGHTS
ISSUE AS WELL AS BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH ISSUE.
INTERESTING CONVERSATION. APPLE
CONVERSATION YESTERDAY BUT A IN
THE GLUTTON EXPLOITATION. A LOT
OF- WHAT'S CALLED NEGLECT OF
ELDERS WHO ARE HAVING
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CHALLENGES A
RESOURCE CHALLENGES INCREASING
FINANCIAL ABUSE REALLY-
CHALLENGES THERE. AND THEN OF
COURSE EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS.
TEAMS WE HEAR A LOT REALLY
QUICKLY- DIVERSITY AGAIN UP A
BOTH RACIAL ETHNIC AND
IMMIGRANT RURAL URBAN AND
LESBIAN GAY BISEXUAL
COMMUNITIES. COGNITIVE
IMPAIRMENTS FROM DEMENTIA TO
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. TECHNOLOGY
HOW TECHNOLOGIES BOTH
DESTRUCTING CHANGING AGING.
WORK FORCE ME CONNIE. AND
IMPORTANCE OF CROSS
GENERATIONAL CONNECTIONS WITH
CHILDREN AGING THIS IS NOT A
MASTER PLAN FOR OLD PEOPLE I
OFTEN SAY IT'S A MASTER PLAN
FOR ALL OF US AS WE AGE ACOSTA
LIKE SPAM. COLLABORATION
SUPPORT ALL OF OUR OTHER
INITIATIVE PRECLUDED
ALZHEIMER'S TASK FORCE BUT ALSO
HOUSING BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
HEALTH CARE AGING IS
EVERYWHERE- AND WE ARE WORKING
TOWARDS THE TRANSFORMATION OF
CDA WHICH ALL DRESSED IN A-
FUTURE. SO THAT WE ARE ABLE TO-
IMPLEMENTING CONTINUE TO BE A
LEADER PARTNER IN THE SPACE.
ANY COMMENTS FROM OHIO. WE'VE
BEEN MONITORING THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THE MASTER PLAN ATTENDING
THE SUBCOMMITTEE HEARINGS A LOT
GOING ON- SO WHEN THE REPORT IS
RELEASED IN MARCH TWENTY TWENTY
AT THE END OF THE MONTH- WILL
FOR SURE BE READING THAT
MONITORING FUTURE DEVELOPMENTS
AS WE REACH THAT OCTOBER
DEADLINE- BUT THEN ALSO WILL BE
LOOKING FOR TO GET A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW CURRENT
BUDGET RELATED PROPOSALS THAT
HAVE A SENIOR PERSON WITH
DISABILITY AND PACKED LIKE CAL
AMY WILL TRULY CONNECT WITH THE
BROADER MASTER PLAN. YOU
FINANCE. COMMENTS NOTHING
FURTHER TO ADD AT THIS TIME
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT OPTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. SO ACTUALLY. SELECT
EQUAL ACTUALLY THE SAID YOU
WERE GOING TO US CAN YOU
ELABORATE ON THE- THE IN TERMS
OF THE TRANSFORMATION CDA SURE
THAT THE PART OF AGING THANK
YOU FOR OUT WE HAVE LARGELY
BEEN- OVERSIGHT AGENCY OF SOME
CRITICAL AGING FUNDING- BUT
REALLY- BECAUSE AGING IS
CHANGING IT CALLS FOR NEW
STRATEGIC PLAN FOR THAT
APARTMENT SO WE'VE- IN IN
PROCESS TO FINALIZE THAT
LOOKING OUT FOR GOALS WHICH ONE
IS TO IMPLEMENT THE STATE'S
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING. ONE IS
TO DELIVER QUALITY SERVICES ONE
IS TO ENGAGE AROUND AGE WHICH
IS OUR- SHORTHAND FOR PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT AND EDUCATION
AWARENESS AND MOLASSES TO
MODERNIZE CDA WE RELEASE ON
DEVELOPING QUALITY- DELIVERING
QUALITY SERVICES WERE WORKING A
LOT ON STREAMLINING-
MODERNIZINGEVERYTHING FROM
CONTRACTING OVERSTATE TO OUR
ALLOCATION. I AM WORKING
WORKING ARE PARTNERS TO KICK
OFF A PROCESS WHERE.
TENTATIVELY PLAYING TRIPLE A TO
OUT OF TRIPLE A STRUCTURE WAS
CREATED THE SEVENTIES IN
CALIFORNIA WE CREATED IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY. AND WE ALL
AGREE IT'S TIME FOR A FRESH
LOOK TO MAKE SURE WE ARE READY
AS STATE AND LOCAL LEADERS AND
PARTNERS. TO LEAD- INTO THE
NEXT DECADES AS AGING CHANGES
SO MUCH AROUND US SO THAT'S
EXCITING WORKING IN IN
MODERNIZING CDA. WE'RE WORKING
REALLY HARD TO DIVERSIFY WILL
BE- ENGAGING IN THE GOVERNANCE
GOVERNOR. GOVERNMENT ALLIANCE
RACIAL EQUITY TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE AS A STAFF ARE REPRESENTING-
THE BEST OF CALIFORNIA AND ABLE
TO SERVE CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE
POPULATION AND WE ARE ALSO
LOOKING TO MOVE INTO A MORE
MODERN ACCESSIBLE AND
WELCOMING. BUILDING WITH WIFI
AND THINGS LIKE THAT- AND
MICHAEL WE CAN. UPDATE THOSE
DEVELOPMENTS IN THE NEXT PC
PETERS GOSH. SO CAN YOU JUST
PERHAPS ELABORATE SO YOU SAID
YOU WANNA TALK ABOUT- TRIPLE A
TO POINT OUT RIGHT SO. HOW TO
USE- SO WHERE SOME THE THOUGHTS
ABOUT. OUR LOCAL- TO BLAZE AND
THE RELATIONSHIP OF THE
DEPARTMENT WITH THEM GOING TO
THE FUTURE SO I MEAN AS YOU
SAID YOUR- TO RE IMAGINING THIS
SIR- AND IF HE'D TRAPS
ELABORATE A LITTLE MORE ON WHAT
SOME OF THE THOUGHTS ARE IDEAS
THAT ARE BEING. DISCUSSED
ENTERTAIN IN RELATION TO THE
ROLE OF THE TRIPLE A.'S- AND
THIS NEW THE PART YOU KNOW FAR
REACHING. CONVERSATIONS HAVE I
HAVE BEGUN WITH OUR MANY OF OUR
PARTNERS ON THIS BOTH IN THE IN
THE COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE
AND NATIONALLY- YOU KNOW AGAIN-
WITH AGING GROWING THE NUMBERS
AND THE CHANGING NATURE OF
AGING YOU REALLY WANT TO BE
SURE THE POST CDA IN THE LOCAL
TRIPLE. ARE PUT TO BE THAT
STRONG LEADER PART. SO OF THE
WE WANT TO. SERVICE AREA. AND
WHETHER THAT'S THE RIGHT NUMBER
GIVEN POP. CHANGES IS ONE OF
THAT ONE OF THE KEY QUESTIONS.
YOU ALSO WANT TO LOOK AT WHAT
WE'RE FINDING IS THAT FOR
TRIPLE A.'S TO BE THE MOST
EFFECTIVE AND SUCCESSFUL IS
THAT THERE ARE THREE
RELATIONSHIPS THAT ARE CRITICAL
ONE IS WITH THE COUNTY. HOW
COUNTY SERVICES TO AGING
DISABLED ONE IS WITH LOCAL
LIVABLE COMMUNITY MOVEMENTS-
SOMETIMES H. FRIENDLY
COMMUNITIES HOW ARE THEY
IMPACTING EIGHT. HOUSING
TRANSPORTATION KEY INDICATORS
OF AGE FRIENDLY. AND INCREASE
ONLY A THIRD RELATIONSHIPS
HEALTH PLANS HOW ARE HEALTH
AND- A MORE SOCIAL TERMINATE
HEALTH PROGRAMS A TRIPLE A
TRADITIONALLY WORK AND WORKING
SEAMLESSLY. TO DEVELOP THE BEST
DELIVER THE BEST HEALTH
OUTCOMES PARTICULARLY
SUPPORTING LIVING AT HOME AND
COMMUNITY. SO WITH THOSE KIND
OF HIGH LEVEL- CONSIDERATIONS
WE WILL BE ENGAGING THE TRIPLE
A.'S- AND THEY'RE INTERESTED
LEADERS AND THINKING THROUGH
WHAT IS THAT. CALIFORNIA FOR
THE SECOND IT'S- I WOULD MAKE
NOTE THAT- THE ON THIS
COMMITTEE ACTUALLY- I GUESS NOW
THAT A- PRIVATE YEAR YEARS
LITTLE MORE NEW YEAR AGO
ACTUALLY- HELD A HEARING. ON
THE DEMOGRAPHICS FOR AGING
POPULATION- MORE IN TERMS OF
LOOKING AT- MULTI ESTO LONG
TERM SUPPORT. SERVICES SERVICES
SUPPORTS AND- MAKING NOTE THAT
AS OF NOW FROM BUDGETARY
STANDPOINT THAT- ADMIT THAT
CAME AFTER PRESENTATION FROM
THE DEPARTMENT AND FINANCE THAT
SAID THAT THEY WEREN'T REALLY
LOOKING OUT TO THE FUTURE IN
TERMS OF THE DEMOGRAPHICS AND
ITS IMPACT ON THE BUDGET SO. WE
DIDN'T HAVE THAT HEARING
APPRECIATE THE INPUT OF THE LA-
DOING SOME HOUSES FOR THAT. AND
RECOGNIZING THAT- YOU KNOW WE
NEED TO BE BETTER PREPARED-
FOR- FOR AGING POPULATION- AND-
APPRECIATE THAT- SUBSEQUENT TO
THAT THE GOVERNOR THEN IN THIS
STATE OF STATE ADDRESS LAST
YEAR TALKED ABOUT AGING CELL
CERTAINLY HERE IN THE SENATE.
BEEN VERY INTERESTED IN THIS
ISSUE WE PREVIOUSLY HAD UNDER.
CENTER CAROL LOOP SELECT
COMMITTEE ON AGING AS WELL WHO.
SOME REALLY FOR IMPORT THAT
GROUNDBREAKING WERE. AS WELL.
LIKE FOLLOW UP SO FOR THE
FASTER WE- MILLION DOLLARS FOR
AN ACTUARIAL STUDY I AUTHORED
BILL RELATION TO THAT I KNOW
THE YOU SEE. THERE'S
RECOMMENDED. THE TAP. FOR TSS
CAN CATCH A ON. WE EXPECT. WHEN
X. TO SEE THIS. SOME RESULTS
FROM THE ACTUAL STAIRS IS THAT
GONNA COURT ANY IN THE MARCH
REPORT AT FOUR OUT WHEN DO SO I
KNOW YOU'RE LOOKING AT LIKE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF SERVICES
IT'S ADDRESS SO. HE GIVE ME A
SENSE OF TIMELINE ON WHEN WE
MIGHT GET- THIS. FEASIBILITY
ACTUAR ANALYSIS OF CELSIUS AS
FINANCING YES I CAN GIVE YOU A
HIGH LEVEL IT'S ACTUALLY BEING
HANDLED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES SO THE
HIGHEST LEVEL WERE EXPECTING
THE REPORT FROM THE CONTRACTOR
THIS SUMMER. BUT WE CAN FOLLOW
UP WITH MORE DETAILS
SPECIFICITY AROUND THAT. I
YOU'LL SEE THE STAKEHOLDER
REPORT DOES INCLUDE
RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT UNIVERSAL
PUBLIC BENEFIT- BUT THOSE THAT
THAT DATA ANALYSIS FROM THE
ACTUAR ALSO IS NOT YET
AVAILABLE OKAY BUT THAT'S ON
GOING RIGHT NOW INSPECTED
SOMETIME IN THE SUMMER PERHAPS
ALL RIGHT. WE WILL CONSULTANT
FIRM ON THAT OKAY AND
APPRECIATE THAT. AND THEN WHEN
ACTUALLY WHEN THE OTHER- THINGS
THAT I WANT TO ALSO TOUCH ON IS
AND THIS IS MORE IN THE
OVERVIEW SECTION- BUT- THE-
AGING AND DISABILITY RESOURCE
CONNECTION- BOTH. I UNDERSTAND
THAT. IS SO THIS USE OF HAVING
FUN THE BY SOME PROGRAM LONG
TIME AGO AND STOP THEM WERE
USING STATE MONEY. AND THEN
WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT AND THE
ANALYSIS THAT- THE INTER AGENCY
AGREEMENTS. BETWEEN CD A AND D.
C. S. ACTUALLY THIS HAS A DATE
OF JAN THIRTY TWENTY NINETEEN
IS THAT CORRECT. IT IS SO A
SIDE. IT IS THERE IS KERN
INTERAGENCY AGREEMENT BETWEEN
DTS AND SEE A ON THAT RIGHT NOW
OR DID THAT EXPIRE AND EIGHTY
OUR C. SO THIS IS EIGHTY OUR
CDS. SO I'M NOT DIRECTLY
INVOLVED BUT I'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH MY- PARTNER I REMOTELY THE
OUR PROGRAM DEPUTY AND WE'VE
BEEN WORKING COLLABORATIVELY
WITH DH YES TO- RENEW THAT AYE
AYE AGENCY AGREEMENT- TO
CONTINUE TO DO THE GOOD WORK
THAT WE HAD PREVIOUSLY DONE ON
EIGHTY RC IN ADDITION TO
AUGMENTING IT WITH THE DOLLARS
FOR THE GRANT FUNDING THAT WE
RECEIVE VIA THE LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET PACKAGE. OKAY SO BE GOOD
IF WE CAN GET AN UPDATE ON THE
STATUS I REALIZE AND APPRECIATE
HERE THAT AGENCIES ARE STILL
WORKING TOGETHER AGREEMENT OR
NOT AGREEMENT BUT JUST ONE YET
THAT STATUS ON THE ACTUAL
THEIR- DEGREE MOST ACTION
RENEWED OR NOT AND WE WILL
FOLLOW UP WITHOUT SPECIFIC
SPELL CASTRATION. AND THEN ONE
OTHER. OTHER JUST FOR FOLLOW UP
THE TAIL IS SET LAST YEAR WE
ALSO FUNDED- FIVE MILLION FOR.
THE LOCAL TO PLACE THE AREA
AGENCIES AGING ON INJURY
PREVENTION EDUCATION AND HOME
MODIFICATIONS AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN- IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT TO ON MY
COLLEAGUES AND ALSO MYSELF- TO
TRY TO PREVENT AND
CIVILIZATION. DO YOU HAVE DO
YOU HAVE A STATUS ON HOW WHAT
THE UPTAKE WAS ON THAT BY THE
TRIPLE A IS SO WITH SAYS HERE
THAT YOU HOW HE GILLIAM UP WITH
TO PARTICIPATE TRIPLE A.'S. IS
THERE SOME SO. TO ANY I DON'T
AND THAT EACH. A IS THAT HAVE
DIFFERENT. SO FORTH JUST ONE
LIKE WHERE W ARE ON. THOSE
FUNDS THIS ON TRACKING WEATHER
DOES HAVE BEEN EXPENDED YEAH
THAT ARE STILL IN PROCESS AND
ALSO. IS THAT THE RIGHT WAY TO
DO IT JUST DISTRIBUTED EQUALLY
ARE- AND SHOULD WE BE LOOKING
AT MORE OR MONEY OR NOT. FOR
SOMETHING LIKE THIS. SURE SO-
WE WORKED COLLABORATIVELY WITH-
OUR PARTNERS THE AGENCIES ON
AGING. AS WELL AS THEIR MEMBER
ASSOCIATION SEE FOR A- TO
DEVELOP THE ALLOCATION
METHODOLOGY- WITHOUT WE WERE
ABLE TO GET THOSE CONTRACTS OUT
YES WE DID- THOSE DISCUSSIONS-
ALLOCATE THOSE DOLLARS. EQUALLY
ACROSS THE DIFFERENT REPLACE WE
SERVE. ALTER PLACE FIRST- WE
HAD ONE PARTNER WHO DID NOT-
OPT IN TO RECEIVE THOSE FUNDS-
AFTER THOSE- DOLLARS ARE
ALLOCATED. THE CONTRACTS WENT
OUT BELIEVE EARLY JANUARY I'M
SO AS FAR AS EXPENDITURES.
THOSE EXPENDITURE SHOULD START
BE. ONLY IN OVER THE NEXT
MONTHS WHICH IS GETTING PAID
AND- ON WHAT EXPANDING. PROGRAM
PACK NEW. AND DOING MORE
ANALYSIS HOUSING DOT FEEDBACK
INFORMATION SO BASICALLY WE'RE
JUST AT THE POINT OF ORDER
ACTUALLY PERHAPS GETTING THE
MONEY OUT YES WE JUST RECENTLY
GOT THE MONEY ON BECAUSE OF THE
COMPANIES LIKE ABOUT
TRANSFORMING CD EIGHT OR TRIPLE
A THESE ARE THE KIND OF THINGS
YOU WANT TO LOOK AT IS MOVING
FROM CONTRACTS ALLOCATIONS.
MAKING SURE IT WORKS FOR ALL
THIRTY THREE OF OUR PARTNERS-
AND HAVING DATA SYSTEM TO TRACK
OUTCOMES ARE EXACTLY THE AREAS
WERE MOVING TO. OKAY SO AGAIN
THANK YOU KNOW WE WANT TO BE
SURE AS WE TAKE TAKE ACTIONS
LAST YEAR- THEY DON'T STE LATER
SO. THE FOLLOW UP RIGHT WHERE
WE WITH THAT. WHAT'S THE UPDATE
YOU KNOW. HOW THAT WHAT'S THE
PATIENT. HOW MUCH SPEND ON
OVERHEAD HOW MUCH IS ACTUALLY
GETTING OUT TO BE. HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE AT IF PEOPLE KNOW
ABOUT THIS ARE NOW. YEAH PEOPLE
OVER HELPS SELL AND I KNOW IT A
LITTLE TO GET THE GOING BUT US.
THANK A- IF WE LIKE TO SEE THE
INVESTMENTS REITERATED WHAT THE
RESULTS ARE SO. OKAY ALL RIGHT.
SO CERTAINLY I KNOW THAT
CERTAINLY VERY MUCH LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE MASTER PLAN AND
DEALS LOOKING FOR TO HAVING OUR
SESSION ON MONDAY BUT ALSO THE
OVERALL MASTER PLAN I ALSO
THOUGH AND IN APPRECIATE THE
HARD WORK THAT'S GOING INTO IT
AND DOESN'T OFFICIALLY THE
WHOLE THING DOESN'T COME OUT TO
OCTOBER BUT I ALSO HOPE THAT.
DOES THAT WORK IS HAPPENING WE
DON'T JUST SIT STILL. RIGHT
SOMETIMES IT HAS THE WHAT WE
HAVE SOMETHING COMING SO WE ARE
JUST SIT STILL HERE. SO BE SURE
THAT BILLS WE'RE- DOING THIS
BUDGET AND COURSE WILL FINALIZE
THIS AND- GEN END OF JUNE RIGHT
FOR NEXT FISCAL YEAR THAT WERE
CONTINUE TO KEEP THE MOMENTUM
FORWARD ON. THE THINGS THAT
WE'VE- CONTINUED THAT WE'VE
INVESTED AND A PROVEN TO BE
SUCCESSFUL PASSED. THOUGH YES
TADA. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
JUST WANNA MAKE A BRIEF COMMENT
TO REALLY WANT TO THANK THE
DEPARTMENT FOR. ALL THE WORK
THAT THEY HAVE DONE ON THE
EIGHTY ARE SEES- YOU KNOW IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR OUR SENIORS TO.
HAVE TRUSTED POINT OF CONTACT
THAT CAN FACILITATE ACCESS TO
SERVICES. AND I KNOW THERE'S
MENTION OF THE MONEY THAT WAS
ALLOCATED IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET- FOR THE FOR THE LOCAL
TRIPLE A.'S AND AT THE
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS TO
UTILIZE A NO WRONG DOOR MODEL.
I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO ALSO
BUILD ON THE NO WRONG DOOR
MODEL FROM AS BEFORE FIVE THREE
OF TWENTY NINETEEN- JUST TO
MAKE SURE THAT. OUR OUR AGING
POPULATION IT A HEARING CAL
FRANKIE CONTINUE HAVE THIS
RESOURCE. SO YOU KNOW LOOK FOR
TO WORKING WITH YOU. MOVING
FORWARD AND CONTINUE THE
PARTNERSHIP BUT THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE WORK THAT YOU HAVE
DONE ON THIS. EXCELLENT ALL
RIGHT- OKAY WELL. ALSO I JUST
WANNA MAKE ONE OF THE-
APPRECIATE THE THAT WERE
GETTING MORE PEOPLE IN THE
OMBUDSMAN'S OFFICE I KNOW THAT
SOMETHING THAT I'VE- EACH EACH
HEARING- EACH YEAR- TEN BE SURE
THAT WE HAVE SOMEONE THAT- THE-
THAT. OUR SENIORS WHO AREN'T
FACILITIES CAN CAN ABSOLUTELY
CAN TURN TO SELF PRECIADO THE
MOST KEEP WORKING ON THAT RIGHT
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE NUMBER TWO
ISSUE TO WHICH IS THE B. C. P.
ON THE HEADQUARTERS RELOCATION
FUNDING. A YES SO JUST TO
SUMMARIZE- THIS B. C. P. IS IT
TO FIND THE RELOCATION- OF- THE
PHARMACY AGING AS WELL AS THE
COMMISSION ON AGING TO TRY
PROPOSAL- IT'S TWO POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
WHICH IS ONE TIME AND SIX
HUNDRED NINETEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND. ON GOING
TO MEET THOSE NEEDS THE ONE
TIME WILL BE FOR EQUIPMENT AND
OTHER EXPENSES THAT ARE ONE
TIME IN NATURE FURNITURE- AND
THINGS LIKE THAT ASSOCIATED
WITH ACTUAL YOUR LOCATION. THE
ADDITIONAL ON BRING MONIES WILL
BE TO COVER THE INCREASE AND
RENT EXPENSES- CDA AS WELL AS
YOU SEE I HAVE BEEN LOCATED OUR
CURRENT FACILITY FOR OVER
FIFTEEN YEARS- IT'S CURRENTLY
IN A STATE OF DISREPAIR. THERE
ARE HEALTH AND SAFETY ISSUES
BIG TRUCK ISSUES- IN ADDITION
TO IT NO LONGER MEETS OUR
BUSINESS AND OPERATIONAL NEEDS
IT NO LONGER HAS TO BE
REQUIRED- WE'VE GONE SO FAR AS
TO START CONVERTING SHARED
SPACES AND MEETING SPACE. IS IT
TOO EMOTIONAL WORK SPACES FOR
STAFF AS WE HAVE RECEIVED
POSITIONS LAST YEAR- AND AS WE
CONTINUE TO CHANGING-
OPERATIONS SUCH AS GOING TO
CONTINUE BEING CONCERNING ISSUE
DEFINITELY WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
MEETING SPACE TO HOLD. ARE
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGE MEETING WELL
AS ANY OTHER ACTIVITIES WERE
BEING TIED TO MASTER PLAN OR
ANY OF OUR OTHER- COLLABORATIVE
AFTER. THE NEED TO SELL IT
POINT. PRESS ISSUES IT WILL
HOWEVER FOR US TO IT WILL. OUT
MEETING SPACE FOR A TO HOPE
THOSE TYPE OF. X. AND
DEPARTMENTAL- MEETINGS AND
ACTIVITIES THAT WE PARTAKE IN
CONTINUOUSLY- AND IT WILL ALSO
HAVE THE TECHNOLOGY AND THE
ACCESSIBILITY EIGHTY
ACCESSIBILITY. THERE WE REQUIRE
TO DO OUR BUSINESS AND TO DO IT
WELL AND NOT JUST TO MAINTAIN
THE STATUS QUO. THANK YOU VALUE.
REVIEW THE B. C. B. AND I'M NOT
CONCERNED FINANCE BECOMES.
NOTHING FURTHER AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU I THANK YOU COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS- SO I
JUST TO CLARIFY THE- ONGOING IS
FOR BECAUSE OF THE INCREASE IN
RENTS AND I UNDERSTAND FROM
WHAT YOUR DESCRIPTION IS
PROBABLY LARGER SPACE ETCETERA.
MAYBE IT'S MORE A QUESTION FOR
DDS BUT DO YOU KNOW HOW LONG
THE LEASES- WE ARE NEGOTIATING
THAT RIGHT NOW- BUT OUR INITIAL
PROPOSED TERM IS SEVEN YOUR
FIRM- FOURTEEN YOUR WHOLE. OKAY
I'M LEASES SO IT'LL BE THAT
SEVEN YOUR FIRM SEVEN YOUR SOFT
OKAY ALL RIGHT. BECAUSE I
REPRESENTS SACRAMENTO I'VE LOW
MORE FAMILIAR TO YOU AT SOME OF
THAT SO I'M GLAD TO HEAR THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT A LONG. LONG
TERM LEASE AND SOME OF THESE
VERY SHORT LEASES WHERE WE CAN
HAVE MORE TIES THE IMPROVEMENTS
SAID THAT ACTUALLY CAUSES OR
RENT TO BE A LOT HIGHER THAN IT
NEEDS TO BE. SOME HAPPY TO HEAR
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
LONGER TERM LEASE THAN A ULTRA
SHORT WANT. THAT OKAY. ALL
RIGHT WE SHOULD THAT OKAY NO
THE QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS LET'S
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE
WHICH IS ACTUALLY A PROPOSAL
FOR INVESTMENT SO I'M GONNA ASK
YOU JUSTICE AND WHEN THE STAY
PUT AND THEN IF PLEASE COME UP-
SO WE HAVE- THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION AREA EIGHT.
AGENCIES ON AGING- THE REQUEST
YES PLEASE COME UP TO THE-
TABLE HERE. I LIKE THAT THE
AGENCY STAY AT THE TABLE
BECAUSE THEY MIGHT. I HAVE I
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS FOR THEM
ABOUT IT SO. OKAY RIGHT WELCOME
IF YOU CAN INTRODUCE YOURSELF
AND THEN ASK IF YOU CAN. KEEP
YOUR PRESENTATION TO THREE
MINUTES LESS THAN THREE MINUTES
IS FINE TOO SO I'M QUITE CAMPY
AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE TRIPLE A OF SANTA CRUZ
AND SAN BENITO COUNTY. AND A
MEMBER OF THE MASTER PLAN I
STAKEHOLDER ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
SO FIRST OFF I WANT TO THANK
BOTH OF YOU FOR WHAT HAS
HAPPENED LEGISLATIVELY IN TERMS
OF JUSTICE. PRIEST INTEREST IN
AGING ISSUES IN MOVING THAT
TOPIC FORWARD. AND THE PROPOSAL
THAT I'M HERE TO TALK ABOUT IS
SPECIFIC TO EIGHTY R. C. SO
THANKS FOR CARING THAT ALSO. SO
HOW ON WE'VE TALKED ABOUT IT A
LITTLE BIT ALREADY AND EIGHTY
OR SEIZE ARE REALLY THE HUB OF
A NO WRONG DOOR SYSTEM. IN WALL
GETTING ACCESS TO SERVICES
ISN'T ALWAYS THE SEXIEST THING
OUT THERE IT'S NOT A SEXY IS
HOME DELIVERED MEALS FOR
EXAMPLE IT'S PROBABLY THE MOST
CRITICAL. BECAUSE IF YOU DON'T
KNOW WHERE TO FIND SERVICES
THEY DON'T EXIST SO THE EIGHTY
R. C. MODEL IS JUST TO MAKE
SURE THAT HAPPENS IN THE WAY WE
BUT ALL DREAM IT TO HAPPEN AND
SENATOR I KNOW I'M PREACHING TO
THE CHOIR WITH YOU ABOUT THIS.
BUT IT'S PROBABLY ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT THINGS WE DO IN
TERMS OF MAKING ALL THE
SERVICES AVAILABLE TO OLDER
ADULTS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AVAILABLE AND
MAKING THEM WORK BETTER AND
HAVING THEM BETTER COORDINATED
WITH EACH OTHER. SO THE BILL
LAST YEAR THAT THE SENATOR
KERRY HAS RESULTED IN THEIR
BEING NOW SIX FULLY OPERATIONAL
ADR SEASON THE STATE AND TEN
THAT ARE DESIGNATED AS A
MERGING WHICH MEANS A YEAR FROM
NOW. HOPEFULLY I'LL BE HERE
SAYING THEY ARE NOW SIXTEEN
EIGHTY ARE SEIZE FULLY
OPERATIONAL. THE CHALLENGE WE
HAVE IS WE THINK THIS IS JUST
EXTREMELY VALUABLE. AND IN
ORDER TO MOVE THAT NUMBER FROM
TEN OR SIX TO SIXTEEN AND THEN
HOPEFULLY TO FIFTY EIGHT WE
HAVE ONE IN EVERY COMPANY
THAT'S GOING TO TAKE A
CONTINUED INVESTMENT. SO THIS
BUDGET ALSO IS TO CONTINUE THE
INVESTMENTS TO CREATE MORE ADRS
THESE. PROCESS ANOTHER. SO THE
PROPOSAL YOU'LL SEE IT'S BROKEN
DOWN INTO THREE YEARS WITH THAT
REALIZATION NOT EVERYBODY WILL
DO THIS OVERNIGHT WE'RE ASKING
FOR NINETEEN MILLION AN
ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR. THE
COMING FISCAL YEAR THIRTY
MILLION IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO AND FIFTY ONE MILLION IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE WHICH
WE THINK WE'LL GET. THE PROGRAM
ESTABLISHED STATEWIDE I CAN
ANSWER QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW WE
CAME UP WITH THOSE DOLLARS THE
SHORT ANSWER TO IT IS THAT WE
WANT TO HAVE BASS LINE FUNDS
FOR EVERY EIGHTY R. C. SO THEY
CAN KEEP THEIR DOORS OPEN SO
THEY CAN ACTUALLY OPEN THE
DOORS. AND HAVE A MINIMUM
NUMBER STAFF TO ANSWER THE
PHONE CALLS TO RUN THE PROGRAM
AND MAYBE MORE IMPORTANTLY
NETWORK WITH THE COMMUNITY OF
OTHER SERVICE PROVIDERS BECAUSE
THE MODEL ISN'T JUST HAVING ONE
CENTER THAT EVERYBODY GOES TO.
BUT HAVING YOUR ENTIRE
COMMUNITY HOOKED IN WITH THAT
CENTER IN IF NOT BEING ABLE TO
ANSWER ALL THE QUESTIONS FOR
WHERE TO GET SERVICES NO ONE
ENTITY TO GO TO GET THEM FROM.
SO THERE'S DIFFERENT CAPACITIES
OF THAT BUT WE ALSO REALIZE
THAT LARGER POPULATION AREAS
NEED A LOT MORE STAFF THAN WHEN
IT JUST TAKES TO OPEN THE DOOR
SO WE HAVE A WAITED FORMULA
THAT- ESTIMATES THE NUMBER OF
USERS BASED ON DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE POPULATION FIGURES. TO
MAKE SURE THAT EVERY AB R. C.
CANNOT ONLY OPEN THEIR DOOR BUT
ONCE THEY'RE OPEN THEY CAN BE
SUCCESSFUL IN THAT OPERATION SO
WE LOOK AT YOU KNOW POTENTIAL.
SERVE ON OF ALL ADULTS AND
PEOPLE JUST BILL. ON THE
CLOSING I WOULD MAKE IS ON
MONDAY MASTER PLAN FOR AGING
LOOKED AT THE P. L. TSS
SUBCOMMITTEE REPORT LOOK AT.
THINGS COULD IMPLEMENT NOW
BECAUSE JUST YOU SAID WE WANT
TO WAIT FOR EVER FOR THAT PLAN
TO COME OUT AND TAKE ACT. AND
THIS WAS DONE OF ARTISTS AND OF
THOSE TWO THAT READY TO GO NOW
I. WANT A IN. AND ASK FOR THE
OTHER POLLS AND COMMON. OKAY
THANK YOU. I DO. THOSE BUT IT.
STATION PROPOSAL BUT AT ANY
FROM DEPARTMENT OF AGING ABOUT
THE FOR. A LA. IN FINANCE. ALL
RIGHT QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. SO I DID I DO HAVE A
QUESTION TO AND APPRECIATE YOUR
DESCRIPTION. IN TERMS OF THE
FUNDING FOR EIGHTY ARE SEIZE
JUST CLARIFY IS THAT TOTALLY
STATE FUNDED OR WE ABLE TO DRAW
DOWN MATCHING FUNDS ANY FEDERAL
SUPPORT BECAUSE I KNOW THE
STATUS OF FEDERAL DEMONSTRATION
GRANT BACK IN WAS A TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE BUT SINCE
THEN. SO CAN I JUST SO THIS IS
THIS GOING TO THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WOULD BE FUNDED SOLELY
THROUGH STATE FUNDS ARE WE
LOOKING AT BE ABLE TO DRAW DOWN
ANY FEDERAL OR OTHER SOURCES OF
MONEY. TO CURRENTLY EIGHTY R.
C. IS FUNDED- SOLELY BY GENERAL
FUND- BUT- DEPARTMENT IS
WORKING COLLABORATIVELY WITH DH
CS AS WELL AS OUR PARTNERS-
TRIPOLI'S ANTI FOR A TO EXPLORE
THE POSSIBILITY- MEDI CAL
ADMINISTRATIVE CLAIMING- TO SEE
IF WE CAN DO SOME DRAW DOWN TO
OFFSET SOME OF THOSE COSTS FOR
THE- PROGRAM OKAY- AND THEN
CHOOSE THAT AND AGAIN I GUESS-
IN TERMS OF A TECHNICAL
STANDPOINT- IS. THIS PROPOSAL A
GIVEN YOUR KNOWLEDGE OF EIGHTY
ARE SEIZE REFLECTIVE OF THE
COSTS THAT WOULD IT TAKE TO GET
TO THEY'RE PROPOSING FIFTY
EIGHT EIGHTY ARE SEES AS IT
THIS THIS SEEMS TO BE IN SCALE
WITH THAT FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE
ON THE PART OF AGING I AND IF
YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT IT HAPPENED
YET YEAH BUT OKAY. PROCESS OF
LOOKING AT THAT WITH
PARTNERSHIP WORK THAT WENT INTO
IT OKAY I'M DENTURE DE SSE
ASIAN HAS SOME PRETTY GOOD
IDEAS TOO BUT I DO WANNA
POSSESSES APARTMENT TO IN TERMS
OF THEIR PERSPECTIVE OKAY. FROM
A TECHNICAL POINT OF VIEW- ALL
RIGHT SENATOR IF IT JUST YET
THE FRONT OF IT IT WILL BE
LOOKING FOR IS ALSO LOCAL FUNDS
ON BEFORE PARTNER CANADIAN SEE
TYPICALLY INVOLVES A NUMBER
PROGRAM SO SOME OF THOSE
PROGRAMS HAVE. AT LEAST PARTIAL
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE WITH
THE EIGHTY ARE C. WOULD BUILD
ON OKAY. AND CERTAINLY PM WANT
TO TED HAVING HUBS IN THE
COMMUNITY WHERE PEOPLE SO WE
CAN HAVE ANOTHER PROBLEM OR
PEOPLE GET YET THE SERVICES
NOTICED FIGHTING SERVICES WHEN
PEOPLE CAN'T FIND THEM SELL
RIGHT HELP. OKAY THE OTHER
QUESTIONS THE OKAY ALL RIGHT SO
WE ARE PUTTING EVERYTHING
PULLED RIGHT NOW SO THE SO WE
GET MAY REVISE PRETTY MUCH- SO
THANK HIS ROOM. FOR YOUR
PRESENT. THANK YOU. OKAY SO
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND- CAN.
YOU CAN DO AT THE REST OF YOU
CAN STAY. FROM A WILL TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT AND THEN SEE THE
ANY OTHER. FINAL QUESTIONS FROM
THE- SO WILL. PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELF AND WE THE MIKE ON
OKAY. NAME IN THEN YES WELCOME.
AND ARE YOU SURE BECAUSE- THE
WHOLE LINE FALLS AT IS A MICRO
ON. THAT'S UP LIKE IN A PROBLEM
OKAY LET'S LET'S OF THEM IN THE
BECAUSE I TO BE SURE WE WERE BE
SURE WE HEAR EVERYONE. THAT'S
OKAY. WE ROUND RIGHT. SENATOR
PENN AS YOUR CONSTITUENTS YES A
MAN IS WATCHING THE MASTER PLAN
THROUGH THERE IN THIRTY FIVE
PEOPLE AND THE FACT THAT IT
STARTED OUT WITH TWO COMMITTEES
IN IS GONNA INVOLVED IN TWO
SEVEN. PLUS THROUGH THERE I
WILL SAY ONE OF THE FIRST
THINGS IS NEEDED THE IS A TOTAL
INTERNET CONNECTION FOR THE
STATE. YOU NEED TO GET FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS AT LEAST TO
START OFF WITH FUNDING- THROUGH
THERE AND YOU NEED TO GET IT
STARTED NOW BECAUSE YOU'RE
EXPECTING FIVE MILLION BUT KNOW
THAT THAT WILL DOUBLE AND
DOUBLE. PROBABLY THIS IS THE
COMMUNITY THAT'S GOTTEN OF THE
THIRTY YEARS OF LIFE EXPECTANCY
RIGHT NOW. I'M LIKE WHAT WILL
BE IN THE FUTURE. FOLLOWING IS
INCREDIBLY CRITICAL- SO THE
PREVENTION PROGRAMS OF THAT AS
WELL AS THE OTHER THING TO KEEP
IN ONE LOCATION AND I KNOW
THERE'S MORE BUT A ONE MINUTE
I'M TRYING TO SOLVE IDENTIFY
MYSELF IS JEFF STARTED YEAR.
AND ADVOCATE. KALRA OWL AND
VARIOUS OTHER. ORGANIZATIONS.
THANK YOU. WELL THANK YOU MY
NAME IS JUDY JACKSON I COME
FROM ALAMEDA COUNTY I'M GLAD
THAT THERE'S AN EMERGING A D.
R. C. WHATEVER THAT IS BUT I
KNOW THAT A YEAR AGO I WENT TO
THE AUTHORITIES TO HELP MY
FRIEND CAROL MY FRIEND CAROL IS
ON. MEDI CAL AND MEDICARE AND I
WAS TOLD SHE WHO WAS BORN IN
THAT COUNTY AND LIVED ALL OF
HER LIFE IN THAT COUNTY HAD TO
MOVE TO ANOTHER COUNTY BECAUSE
THERE ARE NO FACILITIES. THAT
SHE COULD PAY FOR. SHE HAS
ALZHEIMER'S AND IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN TERRIBLY DESTRUCTIVE TO
HER LIFE. TO BE ABLE TO HAVE TO
MOVE TO ANOTHER COUNTY. I THINK
WE NEED TO GET THINGS DOWN TO
THE DETAILS NOT JUST THE- BUT
RESOURCE LEVEL. THANK YOU.
WELCOME IT MADE ON BEHALF OF
CAL PACE THE PROGRAM FOR ALL
INCLUSIVE CARE FOR THE ELDERLY
PAGE ORGANIZATIONS ARE OUT
PARTICIPATING IN THE MASTER
PLAN ON AGING STAKEHOLDER
ADVISORY COMMITTEE AS WELL AS
SEVERAL OF THE WORK GROUPS AND
WE WANT TO COMPLEMENT THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THE WORK THAT
THEY'VE DONE SO FAR ON THE
MASTER PLAN AND WERE
PARTICULARLY IMPRESSED WITH
WHERE THE SUBCOMMITTEE ON LONG
TERM SUPPORTS AND SERVICES IS
MOVING AND WE ARE ANTICIPATING
A WHAT THEIR RECOMMENDATIONS
WILL COME OUT AND LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING WORK ON THAT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR. THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION RED
SUPPORT OF THE C. TRIPLE A
PROPOSAL FOR INVESTMENT. THANK
YOU. WELCOME IS A COMMON
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA
LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN
ASSOCIATION WE WANT TO THANK
THE- ADMINISTRATION FOR THIS
MASTER PLAN AN AGING COMMAND
CDA FOR THE HARD WORK THEY'RE
DOING AND THAT STAKEHOLDER
COMMITMENT IS AMAZING. WE'RE
VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT OF THE-
EXPANSION OF THE EIGHTY ARE
SEIZE I THINK CUTS SAYS IT
BEST. IF A PERSON DOESN'T KNOW
HOW TO GET THE SERVICE BEEN
ESSENTIALLY THE SERVICE DOESN'T
EXIST. AND I ALSO WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR THE INVESTMENT IN THE
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM IT IS MADE A
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE. AND
WE'RE GETTING THOSE ANNOUNCED
FACILITY VISITS AND THEY'RE
HAPPENING- SO I DO ENCOURAGE
THAT WE MOVE FORWARD WITH THAT
SEE A PROPOSAL TO GO- CHANGING
OUR CONTRACTING SYSTEM SO THAT
THE MONEY GETS INTO THE HANDS
OF. SERVICE PROVIDERS TURNING
TIME. YOU'RE YOU. COME MORNING
NANCY. NOT NANCY VOTE JEWISH
FAMILY SERVICE LAST I AM LEASES
IN EARLIER TO THE DEPARTMENT
AND THE PROCESS HAS BEEN
TERRIFIC WE LOOK FORWARD TO IT
WE SUPPORT THIS SEE FOR A
PROPOSAL BUT WE ALSO WANT TO
SAY WE WANT THESE INVESTMENTS
IN THIS BUDGET CYCLE THERE ARE
A NUMBER OF THINGS OF ITS HAVE
BEEN MENTIONED THAT WE CAN DO
NOW INCREASING FUNDING FOR
MEALS INCREASING ACCESS. TO
HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION
SERVICES INCREASING THE FUNDS
FOR SSI RECIPIENTS THERE ARE
NUMBER OF THESE PROPOSALS THAT
ARE READY TO GO AND DON'T
REALLY NEED TO WAIT UNTIL THE
PLAN IS FULLY DONE IN OCTOBER
AND WE HOPE YOU'LL CONSIDER
THOSE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WELL JUST GET CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES JUST
WANT TO COMMEND THE DIRECTOR
AND HER TEAM FOR THE GREAT WORK
ON THE MASTER PLAN FOR AGING
THEY'VE HAVE SOME VERY
AMBITIOUS DEADLINES AND TIME
LINES AT THE RIKEN TO MEET
COUNTIES HAVE A NUMBER OF
CRITICAL ROLES IN SERVING AGING
POPULATION WE'VE APPRECIATED
THE NUMEROUS OPPORTUNITIES TO
ENGAGE IN PER INPUT AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE WORKING
TOGETHER THANK. YOU WELCOME
SOURCE UNDER CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING AND I WANT
TO ECHO WHAT EVERYONE ELSE SAID
THE DEPARTMENT IS DONE AN
AMAZING JOB WITH THE MASTER
PLAN ON AGING WITH A SHORT
DEADLINE COMMISSIONERS HAVE
BEEN VERY INVOLVED THROUGHOUT
THE WHOLE PROCESS SO I'VE BEEN
IT WAS TO THE MEETINGS AND I'VE
SEEN EVERYTHING GREAT JOB THANK
YOU I WANT TO SUPPORT THEIR OF
BUDGET PROPOSAL TO RELOCATE
BECAUSE I'M WITH THEM WERE CUT
LOCATE SPY ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT
CD. REPORTER INVEST IN THE-
CITY'S. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WELCOME A RESEARCHER MEMBERS
AND SHANE ASKING BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S IF IT MAKES AS
WELL AS MY CAROL FROM THE
WESTERN CENTER I TO STEP OUT
WHEN I THINK THE DIRECTOR AND
HER TEAM FOR THE INCREDIBLE
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGE ON THE
MASTER PLAN THAN TO SHOW ONE
ECHO YOUR COMMENTS REINFORCED
THE FACT WE NEED THE KEY TO
MONTH THE MOMENTUM UP MANY OF
THE PROPOSALS THAT WE AND-
PLEASE TO SUBMIT TO. DIRECTOR
THERE THERE'S NO TO GET WHAT WE
NEEDED ON IN A LOT OF WAYS TO
SUPPORT OLDER ADULTS WHEN YOU
GET PEOPLE OUT OF POVERTY WHEN
YOU GET THAT CONNECTED TO GET
FRESH WE DON'T EAT UNTIL
OCTOBER AND HELLO NEXT YEAR TO
MAKE PROGRESS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. WELCOME MY NAME IS EDWARD
WILLIAMS AND I'M A VOLUNTEER
WITH THE COUNTRY COSTA. HOW
FOOD BANK AND- PLATO SAID
POVERTY IS PAN OF CRIME. AND I
MEDICATING FOR AN INCREASE IN
S. S. THAT. AFTER DOING NINE
THIRTY YEARS IN PRISON. AND I
NEEDED BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE OUR
WATER TO GRADUALLY THANK YOU
AND THE BUT THAT ITS COUPLE
BILL MENTIONED WE ARE COMING TO
THAT ITEM A LITTLE LATER ON OUR
AGENDA SO- JUST ONE LET PEOPLE
KNOW. WELCOME MY NAME IS BUT
THREE SETTLEMENT AUG WAS WE'VE
US I'M ON AN ADVOCATE FOR THE
FOOD BANK CONTRA COSTA AND
SOLANO I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE HERE FOR THE MASTER
PLAN WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IN
OCTOBER. BUT JUST AS A REMINDER
DON'T FORGET THAT THE SENIORS
NEED THE SERVICES THAT ARE.
THAT ARE ALL OFFER TO THEM AND
CAN'T WAIT TILL OCTOBER SO
PLEASE KEEP THAT IN MIND THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. WELCOME HI MY
NAME'S ROB A COUPLE HAVE LONG
TO A GROUP CALLED DOCTOR WAS A
DIFFICULT FEW RIGHTS GROUP HERE
IN SACRAMENTO AND THE POOR
PEOPLE'S CAMPAIGN WHICH IS MORE
ADEQUATE SERVICE. FUNDING FOR
ADEQUATE SERVICES STATEWIDE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. WELCOME HI
MY NAME IS GORDON MILLER- FROM
WALNUT CREEK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LUNCH RETIRED
AMERICANS I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR THE LONG TERM PLAN ARE
YOU SURE A LOT OF GREAT MINDS
NEED TO GET OGETHER AND START
WORKING THROUGH LONG TERM CARE
THAT'S GONNA BE A KILLER IF WE
DON'T WATCH OUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WELCOME REBECCA
GONZALEZ NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR HARD WORK AND
ATTENTION TO THIS ISSUE AND
ALSO WANT TO SUPPORT THE
BUDGET. REQUEST FOR EIGHTY ARE
SEIZE. THANK YOU. WELCOME THE
MORNING MESSAGE REMEMBER
SEVENTY RIGHT WITH THAT THE ARE
YOU CALIFORNIA JUST WANTED TO
THANK OF THE DIRECTOR AND HER
TEAM FOR WORKING ON THE MASTER
PLAN ON AGING AND ENGAGING
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS LOOK
FORWARD TO THAT REPORT COMING
OUT IN OCTOBER AND CONTINUING
WORKING WITH THEM YOU ALL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS. MANY MEMBERS
OKAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR PESENTATIONS AND- LOOKING
FORWARD TO- LOOK FOR TO SEE
SOME OF YOU ON MONDAY AND
LOOKING FOR TO THE REPORT COMES
OUT MARCH AND THEN SUBSEQUENTLY
IN OCTOBER AND- PERHAPS IF
ANYONE COMES OUT IN MARCH. YOU
KNOW. IT'S WE MAY BE. CYCLING
BACK CERTAINLY BEFORE BY MAY
REVISE- HAVE YOU GUYS HAVE ANY
FURTHER CONVERSATION WELL THIS
IS A- FOR THE PUBLIC
CONVERSATION WITH I HAVE.
QUICKER CONVERSATIONS EARLIER
TO LAY THIS OUT OKAY THANKS
VERY MUCH THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. WE ARE NOW MOVING ON
TO THE PART OF SOCIAL SERVICES
AND HOME SUPPORT SERVICES.
WELCOME. ALL RIGHT. EVERYONE
COME UP TO THE TABLE AND
INTRODUCE THEMSELVES FIRST.
RIGHT. CAVE ON A START WITH THE
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES WE
INTRODUCE YOURSELF FOR THE
RECORD. GOOD MORNING CHEN
MEMBER KEN JOHNSON CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES
WELCOME. GOOD MORNING DEBBIE
THOMPSON FROM THE SOCIAL
SERVICES ADULT PROGRAMS DEPUTY
DIRECTOR THANK YOU HELLO.
JACKIE BRASSIERE ELIA FINANCE
GE COMPORT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THANK YOU WELCOME
ALRIGHT SO ALWAYS START WITH
THE OVERVIEW OF- ITES SS AND
AGAIN WE DO HAVE A FAIRLY GOOD
RIGHT UP SO IF YOU WANNA HIT
THE HIGHLIGHTS ON WHAT'S
HAPPENED LAST YEAR AND WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR NEXT YEAR. SO
THANK YOU. HI GOOD MORNING YES
YOU HAVE A POWER POINT THAT WAS
HANDED OUT TO ALL- KIND OF GO
THROUGH THAT QUICKLY AND THEN
IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS HAPPY
TO RESPOND TO THOSE. SO I THINK
YOU'RE ALL IN HIS THROAT. I
THINK YOU'RE ALL FAMILIAR WITH
IDEA TO SET AND WHO WE SERVE WE
SERVE ELDERLY AND DISABLED
INDIVIDUALS. HOW WE'RE FUNDED-
WE RECEIVE. MEDICAID DOLLARS
FOR ABOUT 98% OF OUR POPULATION
AND FOR THE REMAINING TWO
THAT'S THE STATE COUNTY FUNDED
PROGRAM A LITTLE UNDER 2% FOR
THE RESIDUAL PROGRAM. THE
BUDGET FOR THIS NEXT YEAR IS
PROJECTED AT FOURTEEN POINT
NINE BILLION. WE DID HAVE NEW
AMMO LEASE- FUNDING STRUCTURE
THAT BEGAN IN NINETEEN TWENTY I
THINK YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THAT AS A
PART OF THE NEXT SECTION HERE
SO. I'LL GO FOR SKIP ON THE
FAIR LABOR STANDARDS ACT WHICH
WAS IMPLEMENTED A NUMBER OF
YEARS AGO NOW TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN WHICH INTRODUCED OVER
TIME TO OUR PROVIDERS WE WANTED
TO PROVIDE. A LITTLE BIT OF
UPDATE ON VIOLATIONS THAT
SOMETHING THAT YOU OFTEN
INTERESTED IN AND YOU'LL SEE
WE'VE SPLIT OUT BETWEEN PAPER
TIME SHEETS AN ELECTRONIC-
VERSIONS WE JUST WANTED TO
SHARE AS WE'RE MOVING TO THE
ELECTRONIC- FORMAT FOR
SUBMISSION OF TIME THAT THAT
HAS BEEN A REAL BENEFIT TO-
SUPPORT. OUR PROVIDE IN NOT
INCURRING VIOLATIONS SO IF YOU
LOOK TO DECEMBER NINETEEN ON
THE NEXT TWO PAGES OR THE
PAPER. REDUCING THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE USING PAPER AS THEY
TRANSITION SO WE HAD ABOUT A
HUNDRED TWENTY TWO THOUSAND AND
THEY THEY AND KURT ABOUT ONE
POINT THREE OF THEM. A 3% OF
THEM IN KERN A VIOLATION.
WHEREAS IF YOU LOOK AT THE NEXT
PAGE WITH ELECTRONIC TIME SHE'S
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND-
PROVIDERS WERE USING THE
ELECTRONIC METHOD. AND ABOUT
POINT THREE PERCENT- RECEIVED A
VIOLATION THAT'S BECAUSE BOTH
THE TELEPHONE SOLUTION AND THE
ELECTRONIC PUMP UP PORTAL
ONLINE. PROVIDE REAL TIME
PROBLEMS AS PEOPLE ARE
COMPLETING THEIR TIME SHEETS
AND NOT HAS BEEN A REAL BENEFIT.
ON THE NEXT SLIDE SHARES WITH
YOU KIND OF WHAT'S HAPPENING
WITH OUR POPULATION OBVIOUSLY
GROWING PROJECTED AUTHORIZED
CASES FOR THE NEXT YEAR IS
ABOUT SIX HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN
THOUSAND. FOUR PROVIDERS WE
HAVE ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY ONE THOUSAND. THE NEXT
TO SLIDE GIVES YOU A LITTLE BIT
OF BREAK DOWN WE'RE WE'RE
SHARING BY AGE THAT SEEMS TO
GIVE A BETTER PICTURE THAN JUST
AGED BLIND AND DISABLED WHICH
IS ALWAYS A LITTLE DIFFICULT
AND CHALLENGING TO. CLARIFY SO
YOU'LL SEE ABOUT FORTY FIVE
APPROXIMATELY 45% OF FOLKS ARE
UNDER SIXTY FIVE AND ABOUT 55%
OF FOLKS ARE OVER SIXTY FIVE.
ABOUT 15% ARE EIGHTY FIVE AND
OLDER AND ABOUT 8% ARE MINORS.
THEN WE PROVIDED A LITTLE BIT
OF INFORMATION ABOUT OUR
PROVIDERS AND- ABOUT FIFTY
ALMOST 54% LIVE WITH THEIR
RECIPIENTS. ABOUT 80% WORK FOR
ONE RECIPIENT AND- ALMOST 20%
WORK FOR MORE THAN ONE
RECIPIENT. THE NEXT PAGE
PROVIDES A LITTLE BIT
INFORMATION ABOUT OUR RELATIVE
PROVIDERS SO YOU'LL SEE ALL- A
LITTLE OVER 72% OF OUR
PROVIDERS ARE RELATIVES AND
THAT GIVES YOU THE BREAK OUT
OF. THAT THE RELATIONSHIPS.
DOES THE TALKS A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT SICK LEAVE THAT WAS
IMPLEMENTED NOW BACK IN- JULY
OF EIGHTEEN. IT'S BEEN GOING
FINE- THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE
THAT WE HAVE IN THIS AREA IS
REALLY EDUCATING PEOPLE THAT
IT'S A OF ITON ITS
AVAILABILITY AND USAGE SOME OF
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THAT AREA
TO ASSIST WITH THAT IS THAT WE
DO SEND OUT ANNUAL
NOTIFICATIONS AND WE ALSO AS
PEOPLE ARE TRANSITIONING INTO
THE ELECTRONIC FORMAT FOR
SUBMITTING TIME. THEY'RE ABLE
TO SUBMIT THEIR SICK TIME THERE
AND THEY CAN SEE THAT IN THE
PORTAL WE WILL BE ABLE TO. POST
INFORMATION IN THE PORTAL AND
EMAIL INFORMATION OUT TO
PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL
EDUCATION TO PEOPLE OF ABOUT
THAT AVAILABLE BENEFIT SO
HOPEFULLY THAT USAGE WILL COME
UP. THIS NEXT FISCAL YEAR THEY
WILL BE GETTING SIXTEEN HOURS
INSTEAD OF THAT SO UP FROM THE
AGE WHERE WE STARTED. THE
ELECTRONIC VISIT VERIFICATION-
SO WE'RE IN THE MIDST OF TRêN
TRANSITION WITHOUT WE BEGAN
WITH OUR PILOT IN JULY AND LA
COUNTY WHICH WENT. REALLY WELL
WAS VERY SUCCESSFUL LA COUNTY
IS 99% OF THEIR PROVIDERS AND
RECIPIENTS HAVE TRANSITION TO
THE ELECTRONIC. VISIT
VERIFICATION TOOL- WE ARE IN
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE REMAINDER
OF THE COUNTIES WHICH ARE BEING
DONE IN WAVES TO MONTH WAVES
THE FIRST ONE WAS IN JANUARY
FEBRUARY THE SECOND ONE IS
BEGINNING NOW MARCH APRIL-
ABOUT. JUST ABOUT 80% OF
RECIPIENTS SOME PROVIDERS ARE
CURRENTLY TRANSITION TO AN
ELECTRONIC- BOB PROCESS FOR
SUBMITTING THEIR TIME SO WE'RE
WE'RE MOVING ALONG WITH THAT
WELL- THE IT GIVES YOU THE
SCHEDULE THERE OF- THE
REMAINDER OF THE COUNTIES. AND
THE LAST THING WE WANT TO COVER
WAS THE NEW MANDATE TO MOVE TO
DIRECT DEPOSIT OR PAY CARD ON
THE THAT IS EFFECTIVE JULY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SO WE HAVE.
ALMOST A YEAR AND A HALF BEFORE
THAT GOES INTO A FACT THAT
SOMETHING THAT WE ARE WORKING
ON IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE
ROLLOUT FOR ELECTRONIC TIME
SHEETS TO EDUCATE PEOPLE THAT.
I HAVE FOUND THAT PEOPLE USING
ELECTRONIC ON BOTH ENDS ARE
GETTING PAID WITHIN THREE OR
FOUR DAYS TYPICALLY. SO THAT'S
A REAL BENEFIT FOR OUR
PROVIDERS- YOU'LL SEE AND THE
LAST PAGE CHART THAT IT SHOWS
ABOUT. 56% AND THE MOST RECENT
I SAW WAS A LITTLE OVER 61% OF
PROVIDERS HAVE ALREADY
TRANSITIONS TO. AN ELECTRONIC-
MODE OF PAYMENT AS WELL. MAKE
INCOME IS FROM LA ON THE REVIEW.
WE'VE REVIEWED THE- I JUST AS
BUDGET ESTIMATES AND OVERALL
REYES NO MAJOR CONCERNS THERE
ARE A FEW AREAS IN WHICH WE
FLAG TO THAT ESTIMATES MAY BE
DIFFERENT- IN MAY WHEN WE GET
MOST UP TO DATE DATA
SPECIFICALLY HOURS PER CASE IN
THE CAR HERE ARE WITH US MADE
IN NINETEEN TWENTY MAYBE
HIGHER. JUST GIVEN THAT AVERAGE
ANNUAL GROWTH ALWAYS BEEN BROWN
OR HAS RECENTLY BEEN 2% BUT IN
THE BUDGET IT'S RELATIVELY FLAT
WHEN YOU COMPARE TO EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN LEVELS BUT THEN ALSO
PAID SICK LEAVE UTILIZATION I'M
GETTING BETTER ESTIMATES ON
THAT TO THEN DETERMINE WHAT
UTILIZATION WOULD LOOK LIKE IN
THE OUT YEARS REFLECT THAT AS
WELL. A MORE LONG TERM THING
THAT WE WOULD MONITOR IS THE
NEW POLICY OF EXPANDING LIKE
HELL TO ON CAN SEE. THE AND
THAT WOULD BY JUST SAYS THE
THAT WILL BE LOOKING FOR INFO
YEARS GETTING BETTER
UNDERSTANDING THOSE ASSESSMENTS.
THANK YOU FINANCED. I CAN JUST
STEP CAN. WHERE YOU KNOW. THE
MAY REVISIONS. WE WILL BE A
WORKING WITH THIRD. SOCIAL SIR.
TARA YOU KNOW CASELOAD COSTS-
HOURS PER CASE- SO YOU WILL BUT
THERE WILL BE AN UPDATE AT ME
REVISION. BASED ON YOU KNOW
ADDITIONAL DATA. THANK YOU.
RIGHT QUESTIONS FOR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. OKAY SO I DID A FEW
QUESTIONS SO I THINK IS ONLY A
REFERENCE TO THE IN TERMS OF-
THE SO WE HAVE AN INCREASING
NUMBER OF CASES RIGHT AGING
POPULATION- MORE PEOPLE WHO
NEED THAT SUPPORT BUT ALSO THE
HOURS PER CASES ALSO BEEN
INCREASING. CAN YOU NOW WELL
IT'S- THE CAN YOU ELABORATE ON
PERHAPS THAT MEANS THAT DO YOU
HAVE SOME IDEA OF THIS TO WHY
THE HOURS PER CASE IS ALSO
INCREASING AS WELL. SO THAT
MEANS THAT NOT ONLY OF COURSE
IT MORE PEOPLE TAKE CARE OF THE
FAMILY NEED MORE SERVICES ARE
MORE. DID OUT OF THIS INCREASE
INTENSITY OR SOME OTHER THINGS
SO CAN HE SPEAK TO THAT I CAN
CERTAINLY START TO IN MY OWN
BUT MAYBE YOU CAN SPEAK TO WITH
THE S. AND DO YOU HAVE SOME
DATA ON THAT. I THINK SAID A
PORTION OF IT COMES FROM THAT-
NOT ONLY ARE PEOPLE AGING BUT
ALSO PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
ARE AGING AND AS PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AGE THEN IF THERE
IS THAT. MORE EXTENSIVE
SERVICES- NEEDS THAT THEY HAVE.
WE ALSO ARE. SEEING MORE
CHILDREN OF ARE SO LIKE
PROTECTIVE SUPER WITH ASH
BURGERS AUTISM THOSE KINDS OF
ON DISABILITIES AND- I THINK
THOSE ARE SOME OF WHAT PLEASE
INTO THAT IT IS AN AREA WE ARE
WEAK WE CONTINUE TO WORK IN
COLLABORATION WITH OUR COUNTY
IS TO ENSURE THAT- THE-
ASSESSMENT TOOLS ARE UTILIZED
IN A GOOD WAY. LAKE ACCURATE A
BOMB. AND SO THAT THINGS ARE
DONE AS CONSISTENTLY AS
POSSIBLE ACROSS THE BOARD AND
SO THAT WE'RE ABLE TO CLEARLY
UNDERSTAND. WHAT'S HAPPENING
WITH OURS WITH OUR SERVICE
LEVELS OKAY EMPTORIS BECAUSE
WE'RE MOVING TO LIKE TRYING
VISIT VERIFICATION AND I KNOW
WE'VE HAD SOME DISCUSSIONS IN
THE PAST ABOUT THIS BURDENS INS
ISSUES BUT I WAS ALSO WONDERING
IS YOU'RE TRANSITIONING PEOPLE
FROM PAPER TO THE TRIBE
VERIFICATION. IT SEEMS LIKE
BASED ON WHAT YOU PRESENT THAT
MADE IS. THE LIKE TRYING
VERIFICATION SEEM LIKE IT'S A
MORE ACTORS FIVE NOT QUITE THE
RIGHT WORD BUT PEOPLE ARE
BETTER ABLE TO DOCTOR AND
TONIGHT ON OF THAT SO CAUSES
ANY SMALL ADJUSTMENT IN. THE
HOURS IN THE CASE BECAUSE OF
YOUR BETTER ABLE TO THAT
SOMETHING'S MAKE OUT SO I DON'T
KNOW IN TERMS OF THE PAPER
PROCESS REALLY TRONIC PROCESS
WITH YOU SEEN ANY SALACIOUS IN.
RULES DOCUMENT. HABITS AND THE
AND THE LEVEL DOCUMENT. DEBTS
THAT'S A THAT'S IT SO BECAUSE
NEW THE ERROR A SEEMS LIKE A
DROPPED WHEN USED ELECTRONIC.
ARM I THINK THAT I DON'T KNOW
THAT THAT'S IMPACTED
NECESSARILY THAT HOURS OKAY I
THINK THAT IT HAS- SUPPORTED
PEOPLE IN BEING ABLE TO. TRACK
TRACK IN AND ARE THERE TIME AND
BE AWARE IF THEY'VE MADE AN
ERROR ON AND SO THAT'S BEEN A
POSITIVE THING. ALRIGHT AND LOW
QUESTION ACTUALLY FOR FINANCE
SO I MEAN PLEASE OF COURSE WE
PASS A BUDGET EACH YEAR FOR THE
NEXT YEAR BUT WE ALSO IN A
BUDGETS QUESTIONS TALK ABOUT
OUT YEARS RIGHT WHAT NOW WHAT
AND SO WE LOOK AT- THE OUT
YEARS- SO IN TERMS OF THE OUT
YEAR NUMBERS FOR- FOR AYE HSS
AND OTHER THINGS RELATED TO
SERVICES FOR SENIORS ARE WE-
RATING IN THE- INCREASING
DEMOCRATS. CHANGES REALIZING
THAT MAYBE SOME POLICY CHANGES
IN THE FUTURE BUT STILL YOU
KNOW WE'RE- SO I MEAN WHAT'S
THE PROJECTED GROSS OF AYE TO
ASSESS YEAR BY YEAR OVER INTO
THE OUT YEARS. SO WE DO NOT
SPECIFICALLY- YOU KNOW FACTOR
IN DEMOGRAPHIC CHANGES. BUT
WHAT I WILL SAY IS THAT- YOU
KNOW THIS PROGRAM KIND OF
TRACKS WITH WITH MEDI CAL
ESSENTIALLY SO- AS YOU KNOW.
BECAUSE BECAUSE GENERALLY THE
WAY INTO I JUST **** THROUGH
THE MEDI CAL PROGRAM. SO WHAT
WE GENERALLY DO IS WE LOOK AT
THE TRANS- THE DEPARTMENT LOOKS
AT THE TRENDS AND HOW HOW CASE.
HAS INCREASINGLY WHAT.
PROJECTED GO YOU KNOW WHAT
WE'RE BRIDGE BAY ON. CHANGES
BUT GENERALLY NO WE DO NOT- YOU
KNOW FACTOR IN DEMOGRAPHICS-
IT'S HARD TO PREDICT- YOU KNOW
WHO. IS GOING TO BE USING I HSS
IT- WE KNOW THAT WITH THE AGING
POPULATION THERE WILL YOU KNOW
THERE ARE GOING TO BE- PROBABLY
MORE- PEOPLE ARE ELIGIBLE. BUT
AS MISS THOMPSON WAS SAYING WE
ALSO HAVE- YOU KNOW THIS
POPULATION ARE HIGHER-
POPULATION OF. ON THE BILL AT
THE SITE COMING INTO THIS
PROGRAM SO YOUNGER- POPULATION
WITH HIRE ME. THE PROGRAM HAS
BEEN GROWING PRETTY STEADILY
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS- I
THINK- IT THAT TREND IS
EXPECTED TO CONTINUE AS WE MOVE
FORWARD OKAY SO I GUESS THIS IS
THE IS A MORE CONCRETE QUESTION
IS THAT AS WERE LOOKING AT OUT
YEARS WHAT IS THE PROJECTED
GROSS THAT YOU'RE USING THAT
FINANCES USING AND MAYBE LA-
CAN ALSO ANSWER WHETHER LA IS
LOOKING AT IS WE'RE JUST YOU
KNOW WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE
BUDGET IS ABOUT NEXT YEAR BUT
THEN YOU SAY WELL LOOK AT YOUR-
IMPACTS SO. WHAT THREE. USING
FOR PROJECTIONS FOR THE I GUESS
THAT WE GOT LIKE FIVE YEARS I
THINK. FIVE YEAR ELLIS THOUGH
YEARS TWO THREE OBVIOUSLY I CAN
CHANGE WITH NEW INFORMATION
THAT'S- EVEN DO MAY REVIE FOR
THE SAME YEAR BUT I MEAN WHAT.
WHAT GROWTH ARE WE PLANNING FOR
AND I'D JUST US- AS WE'RE GOING
AS WE- TALK ABOUT THESE OUT
YOUR PROJECTIONS. TO WE ARE WE
ARE PROJECTING SIGNIFICANT
GROWTH I APOLOGIZE YOU DON'T
HAVE THAT INFORMATION IN FRONT
OF ME BUT WE CAN DEFINITELY GET
BACK TO YOU- GENERALLY THIS
PROGRAM COST WISE- SINCE. YOU
KNOW THAT. I WOULD SAY PROBABLY
OVER THE LAST- TEN YEARS IS
PROBABLY ON- THAT TOTAL
EXPENDITURES HAVE BEEN GROWING
AROUND LIKE A 10211% CLIP
ANNUALLY- AGAIN WE WILL YOU
KNOW WE HAVE TO LOOK AT CERTAIN
POLICY CHANGES SO THE RECENT-
CHANGE IN THE COUNTY I. SYSTEM
A WE- ARMENIANS ABOUT LEVEL
THAT IS GOING TO THAT FACTORS
IN TO OUR GROWTH FACTOR. UP TO
OUR- THE INCREASED COST TO THE
STATE. IT'S YOU KNOW AGAIN A
LOT OF IT IS ALSO BASED OFF THE
GROWTH IN THE SLOPE THAT WE SEE
AND I THINK WERE SOMEWHERE IN
THE- 5% ANNUALLY- IS WHAT THE
CASELOAD HAS BEEN GROWING BY.
US ALL THOSE FACTORS GO INTO
IT- I CAN'T I DON'T HAVE THE
NUMBERS HERE I DON'T KNOW IF MY
COLLEAGUE LA- DOES BUT WE CAN
WE CAN DEFINITELY GET BACK TO
YOU ABOUT WHAT WERE. WHAT WE
THINK THE GROWTH RATE IS OVER
THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS IN TERMS
OF EXPENDITURES OKAY SO I
THINK- THAT IS ALWAYS HOPEFUL
BECAUSE SOMETIMES WE DO HAVE
THESE DISCUSSIONS ABOUT WELL WE
CAN'T YOU KNOW WE'RE- NO ONE
TIMERS IS ON GOING WHAT'S- HOW
MUCH DO WE HAVE ON GOING IT
CETERA AND- I'D- NOTE. GIVEN
THE PREVIOUS WORK OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE SAYING THAT WE
NEED TO INCORPORATE THE
DEMOGRAPHICS THE REALIZE
DEMOCRATS IS ONLY ONE FACTOR OF
MANY AND HOW MUCH WOULD
ACTUALLY SPEND- BUT I THINK IT
IS SOMETHING THAT. WE WANT TO
BE YEAH. WELL IT'S ACTORS WHICH-
PROJECTIONS WHERE WE'RE GOING
TO GO- IT DAILY AT THE ONE A
COMMENT ON THIS ISSUE AS WELL.
AS PART OF OUR ALSO FISCAL
FORECAST THAT WE DO NOVEMBER
AND THEN ALSO IN MAY- WE ALSO
LOOK AT TO PROGRAM GROWTH I
THINK SPECIFICALLY WHAT YOU'RE
MENTIONING IS IT'S NOT JUST
CASELOAD IT'S THE POLICY
IMPACTS AND ACCOUNTING FOR
THOSE AND WHEN WE DO LOOK AT
THOSE IN THE OUT YEARS WE TRIED
TO ACCOUNT TO THE EXTENT
POSSIBLE- THE SIZE OF THE POOL
OF INDIVIDUALS THAT WOULD BE
AFFECTED BY THOSE POLICIES TO
THAN COSTA IN THE FUTURE BUT
THAT QUESTION THAT YOU RAISE OF
EXPLICITLY FACTORING AGAIN
CHANGING DEMOGRAPHICS WITHIN
THAT SHORT OUT YOUR WINDOW. IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE BEEN
LOOKING AT AS WELL AND IMPROVE
THAT WE CULD ON OUR FISCAL
FOR- I DON'T KNOW SPECIFICALLY
WHAT WE ESTIMATE IN THE OUT
YEARS BUT I JUST KNOW IN THE
BOOK IN THE WINTERS BUDGET THE
THAT THEY'RE ESTIMATING AND THE
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE IS SIXTEEN PER SAID THE
EXTENT CARRY FOR DOUBT YOU ZERO
SAN MAGNET THAT WERE TO UP BUT
AGAIN THAT SICK PERCENT CAPTURE
RECENT POLICY DECISION THAT
HAVE IN SOME CASES TO SHIP. OR
CALL TO THE GENERAL FUND. ALL
RIGHT. APPRECIATE THAT AND- I
THINK THAT YOU KNOW WHAT MY
THINGS WE WANT TO BE SURE'S
SAYS WERE TALKING AND I MEAN
THIS. SERVICES FOR THE- FOR
PEOPLE DISABILITIES AND WHO ARE
AGING AND NEED- THE SERVICES
ARE NO WE WANNA BE SURE WERE
PREPARED FOR THAT I WOULD ALSO
WANT TO MAKE NOTES- BECAUSE AS
YOU GIVE US ARE TALKING ABOUT
YEAH WHAT WE'RE PROJECTING AND
THE INCREASES THAT THIS IS
BEING DRIVEN PARTLY BY AGAIN AN
AGING POPULATION- WE WANT TO
HELP TAKE CARE OF PEOPLE WHO
HAVE DISABILITIES SO THEY CAN
THE FULL LIVES I MEAN THAT'S
PART OF OUR COMMITMENT SO WE
HAVE AN INCREASE DOWN THE GOOD
NEWS IS WE HAVE- PEOPLE WHO WE
CAN TAKE CARE OF FULLER LIVING
WHO. WHO WRITES FOR FOUR EIGHT
ANOTHER THING AND THEN THE
OTHER THING I DO ALSO WANT TO
RECOGNIZE YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT THIS ISSUE ABOUT TO
ASSESS THAT I JUST A STILL A
ALTERNATIVES TO
INSTITUTIONALIZATION SO AS
WE'RE LOOKING GOING LOOK AT THE
NUMBER. ISN'T THIS AND THAT'S-
THE CHALLENGE. WE ALSO HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE ALTERNATE. TO NOT
DOING IS EITHER SPENDING EVEN
MORE THROUGH
INSTITUTIONALIZATION OR NOT
PROVIDING SERVICES AND- THE
CONSEQUENCES THOSE HAVE SO I
JUST WANNA BE SURE WE FRAME IN
THAT REGARD IT'S NOT THAT- WELL
WE A LOOK OUT FAST IS GOING
AND- WE JUST NOT SPEND MONEY ON
THAT- SO I HOPE THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THAT MANY OF THE
ALTERNATIVES AND FOR ACTUALLY
COSTS EVEN MORE. IS AND IS PART
OF THE FUNCTION OF THE FACT
THAT DEALER STATE IS GETTING
OLDER AND- WE HAVE PEOPLE HO
NEED SUPPORT TO HELP- SO I DID
WHAT I RECOGNIZE THAT AND- SO
WE CAN GET BETTER DIAZ GET BACK
TO THAT- JUST- AGAIN BECAUSE I
KNOW THE DISCUSSIONS WILL BACK
ABOUT. WHAT ARE. HOW YOU'RE
SPENDING IS GOING TO BE ABLE
TALK ABOUT THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
SO JUST. KNOWING FOR WE ARE ON
THIS PROGRAM IS GOING TO BE
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT. OKAY
RIGHT. OKAY SO I GUESS MAY
REVISE WILL GET SOME UPDATED
NUMBERS THAT ALL RIGHT ALL
RIGHT OKAY SO ISSUE NUMBER TWOS
THE UPDATE ON THE AYE TO ASSESS
MOE. IN ITS OF EFFORTS AND IF
YOU CAN PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELF FIRST FOR THE RECORD.
TESTING AT THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT- SO HE'S GOT
PRESENT ON THIS ISSUE. RIGHT.
OKAY SO IN NINETEEN TWENTY THE
I JUST US I'M A E. WAS
REPLACED- AHEAD AFTER DOING
SOME ANALYSIS AS A PART OF THE
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN- AND OF THE
COORDINATED CARE INITIATIVE AND
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT OF
THAT EMILY THERE WAS THIS ODD
PART OF THAT WAS TO DO LOOK AT
THAT FUNDING STRUCTURE AND SOME
ANALYSIS AS TO- HOW IT WILL BE
OUR BEST TO GO FORWARD AND AS A
PART OF THAT THE M. THREE BASED
IT WAS PRODUCED BY ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED AND FORTY THE INSTITUTE
STATEWIDE. AND BE ON ANY WALL
INFLATOR TO THAT- AND HE WAS
REDUCED FROM 7% 24% ALSO THE
APPROACH TO THE ADMINISTRATIVE
FUNDING WAS ALTERED- AND IT IS
AN ALLOCATION- THE NON FEDERAL
SHARE OF THAT ALLOCATION IS A
100% STATE GENERAL FUND- IF THE
COUNTIES CHOOSE TO EXPAND MORE
THAN THAT THE NOT BECOME I
COUNTY. CALL OF THOSE WERE THE
BIG THINGS THAT HAPPEN AS A
PART OF THE NINE TO MOE IT ALSO
DID CONTINUE THE- ELEMENTS
AROUND I HAD LOCAL NEGOTIATIONS
AS FAR AS THE WAGE SUPPLEMENT
WHERE COUNTIES COULD NEGOTIATE
A SUPPLEMENT TO A WAGE THAT
THE- SHARED IN ONE TIME AND
THEN HAN AN ON GOING BENEFITS
TO IT- SITTING ON TOP OF ANY
MINIMUM WAGE INCREASE IT ALSO
CONTINUED AT THE OPTION TO
NEGOTIATE AT. INCREASE ABOVE
WHAT THE STATE PARTICIPATION
CAP WAS AND THE STATE WOULD
SHARE IN UP 210% OVER A THREE
YEAR PERIOD OF THOSE INCREASES
SO THAT WAS ALSO CONTINUED AS A
PART OF THE NINETEEN TWENTY MOE
WE WORKED CLOSELY WITH C. SACK
AND SEE TO BE THE A AND CAPITA
AS A PART OF. THAT ON THE AND
EASY WOULD BE DISTRIBUTED
AMONGST THE COUNTIES AND- SO
THAT WORK WAS COMPLETED AND
THAT- THOSE ALLOCATIONS WERE
DETERMINED. THOSE ARE. KIND OF
THE HIGHLIGHTS OF WHERE WE'RE
AT WITH WITH THE EMILY. I THANK
YOU. NO COMMENT ON THAT FROM
SEIZE ACT YEAH I THINK FOR THE
GREATER VIEW THE MAJOR
PROVISIONS OF THE NEW EMILY
AGAIN JUSTIN GARRETT WITH C.
SACK- TO START OFF WITH
COUNTIES ONE EXPRESS OUR
CONTINUING GRATITUDE TO THE
LEGISLATION THE ADMINISTRATION
FOR THIS NEW EMILY THAT
PROVIDES A MORE SUSTAINABLE
FISCAL STRUCTURE FOR COUNTIES
TO MENINGITIS COST. COMES ARE
PROUD TO ADMINISTER THIS
PROGRAM ON BEHALF OF BEHALF OF
THE STATE ON TOP OF ONE OF OUR
RESIDENTS REMAIN SAFELY IN
THEIR HOME AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE COLLABORATIVE.
PARTNERSHIP WITH DEPARTMENT SO
SERVICES AND DEPARTMENT
FINANCES WE'VE ACCOMPLISHED A
LOT IN THE FIRST EIGHT MONTHS
OF THE NEW FAMILY IN TERMS OF
IMPLEMENTATION. ALSO SOME OF
THOSE- MAJOR SIGNIFICAN ACTIONS
WE'VE TAKEN- WE CONVENED
ACCOUNT GROUP TO DETERMINE THE
INDIVIDUAL AMOUNTS OF THE NEW
EMILY OVER CLOSELY WITH CSS ON
THE FISCAL AND PROGRAMMATIC
AGAINST THOSE OUT COUNTIES. WE
HOSTED- AND LEAD AT ALL DAY AT
TWO HUNDRED PERSON COUNTY STAFF
TRAINING TO ENSURE IT IS
ACCURATE ON JUST IN ON THE-
IT'S GOING BACK TO THE
PROVISION AND WE MAINTAIN.
CONSIDER OPEN COMMUNICATE AT
THE STATE LEVEL WITH PROVIDING
UNIONS TO ENSURE CONTINUED
PROGRESS ON. THE MARKET. ON THE
ISSUE OF I SAYS CALL BARGAINING.
AND LEGISLATURE MAY IT CLEAR
LAST YEAR VERY IN. IN SO THEM I
DO AGREEMENTS BE REACHED AND
MORE PROGRESS ON THIS AND I'M-
TO. THAT THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT
HAPPENED. WE HAVE FOURTEEN NEW
AGREEMENT SINCE JULY FIRST-
WHICH IS FAR ABOVE THE HISTORIC
PACE OF NEW AGREEMENTS. WITH
COUNTY SUPERVISORS VERY
DEDICATED THIS PROGRAM. ARE
WORKING VERY HARD TO LOCAL
LEVEL TO ENSURE- THESE WAGE
INCREASES GET ADOPTED- THESE-
FOURTEEN COUNTIES REPRESENT
COUNTY THAT HAD BEEN WITHOUT-
AGREEMENT. AND FOR AN AVERAGE
OF FORTY SEVEN MONTHS SO A
NUMBER OF YEARS. ON THE NOW
HAVE AN AGREEMENT THAT'S
POSSIBLE BECAUSE OF THE IT
SIGNIFICAN IN FUSION OF STATE
AND ALL FUND. FOR THIS PROGRAM
THAT MAKES IT MORE SUSTAINABLE
FOR COUNTIES URBAN. RURAL
SUBURBAN COUNTIES FRESNO SAN
BERNARDINO RIVERSIDE. MARIPOSA
SANTA BARBARA SO NUMBER OF-
COUNTIES HAVE REACHED
AGREEMENTS- IN TERMS OF THE
AMOUNT COUNTIES ARE INVESTING
IN THIS PROGRAM FOR WEIGHT
INCREASES FOR. INCREASES THAT
ARE GOING TO AFFECT THIS YEAR
IT'S MORE THAN. FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS ON AN COUNTY FUNDS.
THAT IS ON TOP OF THE MORE THAN
SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS A
COUNTIES INVESTED LAST YEAR.
AND WE SAW FOUR MONTHS LAST
FOUR NEW AGREEMENTS CAN BE
REACHED SO WE HELP FOR SOME
ADDITIONAL PROGRESS. LOOKING AT
STATEWIDE- TO LOOK AT THE
NUMBER OF AYE ACCESS PROVIDERS
AND HOW MANY. PROVIDERS WORK IN
A COUNTY THAT HAS A KERN
AGREEMENT IT'S NEARLY NINE TEN
PROVIDERS SO A FULL 80% SO
WE'RE REALLY SICK PLEASE. I
JUST. AS THE FINE THING I'LL
TOUCH ON ON THE BARGAIN IS. ONE
OF THE OTHER NEW PROVISIONS
LAST YEAR WITH THIS. POTENTIAL.
THE RELEASE STATES IT PASSED
LEADERS IT WOULD ONLY OCCUR. IF
FORCED. AND FOR ME SELECT.
WOULD HAVE TO HAVE NEXT
AGREEMENT. THERE HAVE TO GO
THROUGH MEDIATION FACT FINDING
WITH PROVIDING UNION. THE FACT
FINDER WOULD NEED TO ISSUE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT ARE MORE
FAVORABLE TO THE UNION. AND IT
STILL BE A NINETY DAY PERIOD TO
REACH- A NEW AGREEMENTS ON MAKE
THREE POINTS ABOUT THIS FIRST-
NO COUNTY TO HADN'T ALREADY-GONE TO FACT FINDING HAS YET
UTILIZE THIS PROCESS- AND SO.
YOU KNOW THERE ARE A COUPLE
COUNTIES IT MAY BE GETTING
CLOSE- BUT THEY'RE ONLY AT STEP
ONE OF FOUR OF THESE PROCESSES
YOU KNOW THEY ONLY HAVE.
EXPIRED AGREEMENT THE HAVING A
GUN TO FAX SIGN IN AND THE
OTHER THING SO IS STILL THREE
ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITIES TO
REACH AN AGREEMENT. TO IF I
COUNTY IN A PROUD UNION GO TO
THIS PROCESS RELATED TO THE 1%
REALIGN WITHHOLDING. IT DOES
NOT MEAN THE COUNTIES
BARGAINING IN BAD FAITH THAT
MEANS THEY'RE ACTIVELY
BARGAINING IN GOOD FAITH. AND
THEY JUST CAN'T EACH AN
AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE OFFER
FROM THE COUNTY AND THE OFFER
FROM THE UNION. AND THEN
FINALLY I WOULD JUST SAY WE ARE
FUNDAMENTALLY OPPOSED TO THE
STAKEHOLDER PROPOSAL THAT WOULD
INCREASE THIS- PENALTY AMOUNT
FROM 1% TO SEVEN PERCENT. WE
ALL CAME TOGETHER LAST YEAR SAT
ACROSS THE TABLE REACHED
AGREEMENT ON THIS NEW PROCESS
WITH MINISTRATION OF LET'S. IN
PROVIDE MEANS IN SERENA. NOW BE
YOU KNOW ESSENTIALLY
RENEGOTIATE IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE IMPLEMENTATION. SO WE WOULD
BE OPPOSED TO THAT THAT I KNOW
WILL BE HEARD AND IN A- FEW
PANEL SO NOW SO JUST WANNA WRAP
UP BY. THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
BEST. A GENERAL FUND. COUNTY
FOR. A FOR WORKING HARD
IMPLEMENTS AND ACHIEVE NEW
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS THANK YOU. THEY COME
IN. LA IN A- AS MY IN THE NEAR
PACKAGE. DUE TO THE CHANGES
THAT WE MADE IN NINETEEN TWENTY
OVER TIME THE GENERAL FUND WILL
TAKE ON- A LARGER SHARE OF
TOTAL COSTS BUT WE WOULD NOTE
THAT THAT IS BY DESIGN- THOSE
CHANGES WERE LARGELY DUE TO
FINDINGS THAT THE- COUNTY COST
PRIOR TO NINETEEN TWENTY DID
NOT ALIGNED WITH THE AVAILABLE
REVENUES COUNTIES HAD TO
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE REALIGNMENT
TO COVER THOSE COSTS SO BY
REPLACING COUNTY HOSPITAL OR
AMOUNTS TO THAN REFLECT THE
ACTUAL REVENUES THAT THEY HAD
THAT IN AND OF ITSELF RESULTED
IN THOSE COSTS BEING SHIPPED TO
THE GENERAL FUND- SO JUST
INSURING THAT- OVER TIME. THE
COST OF DOING THAT IS CAPTURED
AND FUTURE BUT IT'S- THANK YOU
FINANCE NOTHING FURTHER ASKED
FANS OKAY. ALL RIGHT QUESTIONS
OKAY I GUESS WITH YOURSELF-
APPRECIATE THE- THE
PRESENTATION SO AND SO IN TERMS
OF THE EAT SO YOU MENTIONED
THAT A LOT OF THE- COUNTIES
HAVE COME TO AGREEMENTS AT A
FASTER RATE HOW MANY COUNTIES
STILL DO NOT HAVE AGREEMENTS-
AT THIS POINT. SO WE'RE
CURRENTLY AT A THIRTY FOUR
COUNTIES AND HAVE A CURRENT
EMILY YOUR TENTATIVE
AGREEMENTS- WE HAVE FOURTEEN TO
FIFTEEN COUNTIES THAT ARE
CURRENTLY NEGOTIATING- OTHER
ARMENIAN SMALL AMOUNT OF COUNTY
IS- THERE'S A COUPLE THAT ARE
IMPASSES A COUPLE THAT ARE
WAITING TO HEAR FROM THE UNION
TO INITIATE BARGAINING- SO THAT
YOU KNOW REPRESENTS THE BUT
AGAIN IT'S IF YOU LOOK AT THE
TERMS OF NUMBER PROVIDERS WERE
CLOSE TO EIGHTY EIGHT OR OVER
EIGHTY EIGHT PERCENT. AND WE
HAVE A LOT A LOT THAT ARE
STILL- CURRENTLY NEGOTIATING
AND CERTAINLY HELPFUL THEY'LL
REACH AGREEMENT SAM OKAY SO HE
SAID THIS FOURTEEN YOU DON'T
HAVE ANY AGREEMENT RIGHT NOW
EXISTING AGREEMENT THERE AND
EITHER MID NEGOTIATION OR
SOMETHING WITH. THEIR THE
TWENTY FOUR IS A THIRTY FOUR
HAVE AGREEMENTS TWENTY FOUR
DON'T HAVE AGREEMENTS WERE DONE
OUT FOURTEEN OF THOSE TWENTY
FOUR CURRENTLY NEGOTIATING THE
OTHER TEN OR IN SOME OTHER
STATUS OF. WAITING TO START
BARGAINING OR THE UNIT HAS A
REACH OUT AND ISSUE BARGAINING
AND A COUPLE ART IMPASSE. OKAY
AND DO WE KNOW OF FOR THE ONES
WHO DON'T HOW LONG THEY'VE BEEN
WITHOUT AGREEMENTS AND A SAID
SOMEONE TO GO SHE IN CENTER I
MEAN WE HAVE SOME IDEA WHAT THE
MEDIA AND OUR-  MEAN IS OF.
THE TIME THAT THEY'VE BEEN
WITHOUT AGREEMENTS. YEAH I
WOULD DEFINITELY ESTIMATE IT'S
PROBABLY BEEN- SEVERAL YEARS
SOME THAT. YOU KNOW A NUMBER OF
JUST EXPIRED IN THE PAST YEAR
AT NO CINEMA STANISLAUS. MARINE
AS A LIVING WAGE JORDAN SO THAT
ACTIVELY DOING WAGE INCREASES
BUT THEY DON'T HAVE A CURRENT
AGREEMENTS. AND THEN THERE
CERTAINLY ARE SOME THAT WOULD
BE IN THE SITUATION OF THE- THE
NEW AGREEMENT SUGGESTS BEEN
REACH WHERE THEY HAD BEEN WITH
AN EXPIRED AGREEMENT FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS- YEAH. I DON'T
KNOW THE EXACT AVERAGE AMOUNT
THEM. OKAY SO I MEAN I THINK
THAT'S THE CONCERN I REALIZE
THAT WE- WE CREATE THIS PROCESS
AT CENTER OF BUT THAT WE STOP
COUNTIES THAT- STILL HAVE NOT.
THAT NEED STILL HAVEN'T HAD
AGREEMENT IN YEARS AND- DOCTOR
NOT CLOSE TO GETTING ONE
THAT'S- THAT'S PROBLEMATIC.
YEAH I KNOW CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN THERE
WE'RE- DEFINITELY INTERESTED IN
SEEING THAT CONTINUE GRAHAM
IT'S I KNOW AT THE STATE LEVEL.
YOU KNOW WE REACH OUT TO
INDIVIDUAL COUNTIES WHEN THE
UNIONS HAVE HAVE COME TO US
WITH SPECIFIC CONCERNS THEY
HAVE ABOUT THIS YOU CAN GET
INVOLVED IN BARGAINING. BUT WE
MAKE SURE IT'S ACCURATE
UNDERSTANDING OF THE TOOLS AND
THE PPORTUNITIES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE. AND YOU KNOW. IT'S
AND CERTAIN SITUATIONS
BARGAINING TAKES TIME SEEN
FOURTEEN NEW AGREEMENTS IN JULY
FORCES. ARE DIVERSE IS GREAT
PROGRESS. HAVING US STILL A
NUMBER OF COUNTIES CURRENTLY
NEGOTIATING- WORKING TOWARDS A
NEW AGREEMENT- WHEN WE HOPE TO
SEE MORE SOON. RIGHT WELL
APPRECIATE THE PROGRESS BUT I
ALSO CAN UNDERSTAND THE
FRUSTRATION THE WORKERS WHO MAY
HAVE BEEN WORKING FOR YEARS
WITHOUT AGREEMENTS AND STILL
NOT HAVING THEM. SO THAT'S I
MEAN THAT'S- THAT'S THE THING
WE WERE TRYING TO BE SURE WE-
AT. THAT'S NOT FAIR. CELL YEAH.
OKAY AND THEN. I THINK IN TERMS
OF JUST SORT OF LOOKING AT SO
IF WE TALKED ABOUT ISIS. TRY
PROJECT YOU KNOW- CASELOAD
DEMOGRAPHICS BUT ALSO WITH THE
WITH THIS- WITH THE MOE
CHANGES. CERTAINLY I WANT. RE
QUESTION ABOUT THAT BUT- AGAIN.
WE CAN GET A BETTER. IDEA ABOUT
HOW WE'RE PROJECTING OUT INTO
THE OUT YEARS- WITH ALL THE
MULTIPLE CHANGES AN EXACT AND
IT'S BY ALSO HELPFUL IF IT'S
POSSIBLE TO SAY. BYE OKAY WE
EXPECT WE HAVE THE CHANGE PLUS
WORD OF THIS MUCH BECAUSE OF
CASELOADS ARE AGING.
DEMOGRAPHICS THAN WE EXPECT
THIS IS GONE. THIS IS WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN BECAUSE OF THE
AMMO YELLED AT THE EITHER PLUS
OR MINUS DEPENDING. ON THE
STATE BUDGET. AS WERE LOOKING
OUT HERE SO WE CAN. SEE
OBVIOUSLY IS. YEARS GO ON WITH
AND- KNOW WHAT THE ACTUAL
NUMBERS ARE BUT START. DOING
SOME OF THIS MODELING
PROJECTIONS OUT THERE SO WE-
AND- HAVE A BETTER IDEA. THE
FOR GOING. OKAY ALL RIGHT OKAY
I THINK TO A SO RIGHT WELL
THANKS VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION AND I KNOW THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR- FROM SOME
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES INTO
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT- ISSUE
NUMBER THREE IS A MANDATORY I
JUST A SOCIAL WORKER TRAINING
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE. PLEASE
SO- I TOUCHED ON EARLIER ONE OF
THE- CORE THINGS THAT WE'RE
WORKING ON IS ENSURING THAT OUR
ASSESSMENTS ARE. DONE
ACCURATELY AND CONSISTENTLY AND
THAT'S ON ON GOING- WORK THAT
WE DO AND- IT THAT THE
FRAMEWORK AND THE STRUCTURE
THAT REGULATORY GUIDELINES THAT
ARE IN PLACE ARE- AT THAT ALL
OF OUR SOCIAL WORKERS ARE
TRAINED AND EDUCATED ON THOSE
AND THAT THEY'RE BEING USED
CONSISTENTLY ACROSS THE BOARD.
SO THIS PROPOSAL ACTUALLY DOES
TWO THINGS IT- IT DOES A ONE
DAY REFRESHER FOR ALL CURRENT
SOCIAL WORKERS SUPERVISORS AND
PROGRAM MANAGERS TO ENSURE THAT
THOSE TOOLS ARE UNDERSTOOD IT
APPROPRIATELY BEING UTILIZED
AND IT ALSO MANDATES THE SOCIAL
WORKER TRAINING FOR ANY NEW
SOCIAL WORKERS. SO WE'VE HAD
THE TRAINING ACADEMY IN PLACE
FOR QUITE A NUMBER OF YEARS NOW
BUT IT HAS BEEN AN OPTION- AT.
MOST COUNTIES DO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THAT OPTION BUT WE DO FEEL
THAT IT IS IMPORTANT THAT ALL
SOCIAL WORKERS HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO. ENSURE THAT
THEY GET THAT BASS AND
GROUNDING IN THE UNDERSTANDING
OF HOW THE ASSESSMENT IS DONE
AND CONDEMN CONDUCTED TO
ENSURE. PARTICULARLY THAT THERE
IS CONSISTENCY IN THE
ASSESSMENT PROCESS AND THE
AUTHORIZATION OF OURS FOR OUR
RECIPIENTS. OKAY THANK YOU
COMES EMILIO. REVIEW THE BC
PEEN HAVE NO CONCERNS BUT KNOW
THAT THE DEPARTMENT- IS WORKING
ON PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
TECHNICAL- RESPONSES SUCH AS
LIKE A BREAK OUT OF THE COST
AND- WHAT ACTIVITIES ARE
ATTRIBUTED TO THE COST IN THE
SUMMIT IN ALL. THE FINANCE
NOTHING TO ADD OKAY THANK YOU.
SHE WHY YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
THIS IS THAT TO SECURE A CITY
STE. I MEAN TO HAPPY TO HELP-
BUT IS THERE A REASON WE NEED
LAW FOR THIS IN THE AGENCY CAN.
DO THIS WITHOUT. LAW. WELL WE
NEED FOR IT FUNDING PART YOU
NEED FUNDING RIGHT AND THIS IS
A BUDGET YES OKAY GOOD BECAUSE
THIS IS MORE FRAMES AS A FILLER
BILL LANGUAGE FOR OKAY BUT
OBVIOUSLY YEAH WE NEED NEED FOR
FRIGHT FUNDING TO SELL AND THAT
IS IN THE FOR VIEW THE
LEGISLATURE THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
ALL RIGHT SO- WORD LET'S WILL
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER FOUR
WITH A SERIES OF PROPOSALS FOR
INVESTMENTS- FROM A U. D. W.
ASKED ME- LOCAL THIRTY THREE
THIRTY NINE THIRTY ON A STATE
THEY'RE COMING UP TO THE TBLE
I WILL JUST ALSO BEFORE MENTION
THAT WE'RE GOING TO GO AND ALSO
HERE WHAT LOOKS LIKE IT'S
ACTUALLY PART THE SAME PEACE
BUT THE A B. C. P. FOR
ELECTRONIC VISIT VERIFICATION
FOR I JUST US AS WELL AND THEN
WE'LL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AFTER
THAT FOR ALL THE- ISSUES THAT
WE'VE HEARD. FOR BECAUSE THAT'S
ALSO RELATE TO HSS SO JUST SO
FOR EVERYONE'S GAMER FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT THAT SOME WILL BE
TAKING THE PUBLIC COMMENT SO
ALRIGHT SO LET'S GO BACK TO
ISSUE NUMBER FOUR WHICH ARE WE
HAVE A SERIES OF PROPOSALS FOR
INVESTMENTS HERE OF. ONE TWO
THREE FOUR OKAY. DID YOUJUST
WANT TO DO THEM ALL
COLLECTIVELY WILL GIVE YOU MORE
TIME THAN AND SET. OKAY SO- AND
HARD WE COULD DO ONE BY ONE ARE
WE CAN JUST FOR A MOMENT ACTED
STAND. ALL RIGHT SO ARE ABLE TO
THE MOLLEN BUT ONE PRESENTATION
AND THEN WE'LL ASK FOR.
COMMENTS FROM AGENCY IN LA ON
FINANCE THEN OKAY. RIGHT THANK
YOU. SIR GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS JUSTIN MYERS. I MEAN I AGES
US FROM HER PROVIDER FROM BUTTE
COUNTY. I CARE FOR MY BROTHER
TEAL HE'S A THIRTY ONE YEAR OLD
QUADRIPLEGIC WHO SUFFERS FROM
CEREBRAL PALSY- MY MOTHER AND I
PROVIDE YEAR. ROUND AROUND THE
CLOCK BECAUSE FOR CARE FOR HIM-
WITHOUT. MY MOTHER AND I CARING
FOR HIM HE WOULD BE AN ANSWER
TO SENT THE LEVEL OF CARE HE IS
OUT. WHICH WOULD BE- GREATLY
DIMINISHED LEVEL OF CARE FOR
HIS CALL IN QUALITY OF LIFE
FIVE. FOR MORE WE CAN PROVIDE.
MANY INSTITUTIONS- THAT CARE
FOR- DISABLED FOLKS IN MY
BROTHER'S LEVEL OF KERR- IF
PROVIDE MUCH SHOT HIGHER
MEDICATION DOSAGE AS- IN.
SOMETIMES I NECESSARY
MEDICATIONS AND ABLE TO US
TODAY MAKE THE MARS DOMICILE-
WE'VE- SEEN MULTIPLE
INVESTIGATIONS BY. THE NEW YORK
TIMES THE WASHINGTON POST THAT
BACK THAT UP. THAT THAT OVER
MEDICATION. ESPECIALLY WITH
THREE WILL POLICY DEVELOPMENTAL
DISORDERS. HI I KNOW THAT
INSTRUCTION CARE IS NECESSARY
IN SOME SITUATIONS BUT MY
FAMILY WOULD NOT LIKE TO SEE
THAT- FOR MY BROTHER'S CASE-
BEING CARED FOR AT HOME ALLOWS
MY BROTHER TO LIVE IN COMFORT
AND DIGNITY HE HAS THE ABILITY
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE COMMUNITY
WE CAN TKE A MILE. TO A PUBLIC
EVENTS WE'VE I MEAN IF HE LOVES
TO GET OUT AND ABOUT. FIVE WE
BELIEVE THAT WE'RE PROVIDING
THE BEST LIFE POSSIBLE FOR MY
BROTHER. AND THAT'S WHY THESE
THINGS NOT EVERY FAMILY IS IN
THAT SAME SITUATION THAT WE ARE
THAT WE'RE ABLE TO PROVIDE THAT
CARE OURSELVES- BUT BECAUSE I
TRUST PAYS SOLO- FAMILY MEMBERS
ARE OFTEN THE ONLY PEOPLE THAT
ARE ABLE TO PROVIDE THAT CARE
IN BUTTE COUNTY WHERE I LIVE.
THERE WERE OVER FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND HOURS OF I. H. SASS.
BY THAT WERE AUTHORIZED BY THE
COUNTY BUT WERE NOT USED IN THE
PAST YEAR- NOT BECAUSE THEY
DIDN'T USE NEED THESE HOURS.
BUT BECAUSE THEY COULDN'T FIND.
PEOPLE TO WORK. I AT THAT. WAGE
I AM NOT EVERY. PERSON AS I
MENTIONED HAS SOMEONE
IMMEDIATELY THERE THAT CAN
PROVIDE THAT CARE FOR THEM. I
WHAT I'M ASKING IS THAT- WHAT
HAPPENED IF ANYONE ELSE'S YOU
HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS THAT MAY
NEED CARE AT SOME POINT WHAT
WOULD YOU WANT FOR YOUR FAMILY
MEMBERS- HOW MANY SENIORS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES. I
HAVE SUFFERED- ADVERSE HEALTH
CONSEQUENCES OR LIVED IN UNSAFE
AND UNSANITARY CONDITIONS
BECAUSE THERE WAS NO ONE TO
COVER THOSE HOURS- WE NEED TO
INCREASE PRESSURE ON COUNTIES
WERE DELINQUENT IN CLOSING THE
RIGHT SUCH CONTRACTS.
INCREASING PENALTIES FOR
INACTION. HI AND THEN THEY IS
AFTER YOU TAKE KERR- BUDGE
ACTIONS ARE REQUESTING TO
INCENTIVIZE COUNTIES TO ACT IN
THE BEST INTERESTS OF ITIS US
CLIENTS PROVIDERS BY INCREASING
WAGE THAT WE CAN KEEP PROVIDING
THIS MYSTERY WORK. SO WITH THAT
ALTERNATE I ACTUALLY HAVE A.
THANK YOU DOCTOR PAN- MY NAME
IS CHRISTINE ABBAS HAMILTON I'M
HERE REPRESENTING YOU W. THE
UNITED DOMESTIC WORKERS APPS
ME- WE REPRESENT A HUNDRED
SIXTEEN. THOUSAND I JUST AS
WORKERS IN TWENTY ONE COUNTIES.
AND I WISH THAT I COULD SAY
THAT. THE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
ISSUES THAT ARE BRAND NEW BUT
SADLY WHEN IT COMES TO THE-
SITUATION WITH WAGES WE'RE
WE'RE LIKE GROUNDHOG DAY AND
I'M JUST TIRED OF THIS
GROUNDHOG DAY AND I WISH IT
WOULD. IT WOULD START A NEW
DAY- SO. YES THERE HAS BEEN
PROGRESS SINCE JULY. ARE WE
WHERE WE NEED TO BE I WOULD SAY
THAT'S NO- WHAT WE HANDED OUT
ARE HANDING OUT RIGHT NOW IS
COPIES OF. ON THE STATUS OF OUR
CONTRACTS THROUGH ITS UPDATED
AS OF MARCH FIFTH. SO YOU CAN
SEE THAT COUNTIES IN YELLOW WE
HAVE ONE TWO THREE FOUR FIVE
THAT REMAIN OUTSTANDING- VIEW
COUNTY WHERE JUSTIN IS FROM
GOES SPECIFICALLY BACK TO TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN SO WE'RE
LOOKING AT GOING ON SIX YEARS
THERE- SOME OF THESE ARE JUST
REALLY. DIFFICULT SITUATIONS
THAT I DON'T SEE RESOLUTION
HAPPENING ANYTIME SOON THE
OTHER POINT THAT I WANT TO
RAISE IS EVEN IF WE HAVE
REACHED AGREEMENTS IN IN SOME
OF THESE OTHER PLACES. WE'RE
LOOKING AT AGREEMENTS THAT ARE
FOR FIFTY CENTS ABOVE THE
MINIMUM WAGE. AND THAT'S-
PURELY BECAUSE THAT IS THE
ABSOLUTE BEST THAT WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN. AND I WANT TO NOTE THAT
ONLY 10% OF THE WORKERS THAT WE
REPRESENT GET HEALTH BENEFITS
THROUGH THEIR CONTRACT MEANING
THAT THE VAST MAJORITY LIKELY
OR ON MEDI CAL. AND SO THESE
ARE THE WORKING POOR THESE ARE
THE POPULATIONS THAT WORK FULL
TIME AND ARE STILL ON PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS SO IN LIGHT
OF THAT. AND IN LIGHT OF THE
FACT THAT THERE IS A CRISIS IN
TERMS OF WORK FORCE RECRUITING
AND RETAINING IN AYE HSS THAT I
BELIEVE ANY CLIENT COULD SPEAK
TO. IT BUT A SPECIFICALLY
CLIENTS WHO DON'T HAVE FAMILY
PROVIDERS WE WANT TO SEE THE
PENALTY AMOUNT INCREASE FOR
COUNTIES THAT ARE. NOT
NEGOTIATING IN GOOD FAITH SO AS
WE TALKED. HOLDING THAT WAS IT-
PASSED LAST YEAR WOULD LIKE TO
SEE THAT BECOME A 7%
WITHHOLDING AND HAVE IT BE
ANNUAL MEANING THAT SO LONG AS
IT REMAINS OUTSTANDING EVERY
YEAR THEY WOULD FACE ANOTHER
WITHHOLDING WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE. TRANSPARENCY IN TERMS OF
TAXPAYER DOLLARS- FOR EXAMPLE
WE HAVE COUNTIES THAT HAVE BEEN
BARGAINING AS I MENTIONED IF
YOU COUNTY FOR GOING ON SIX
YEARS. THAT RETAIN A LAW FIRMS
THAT ARE NEGOTIATING ON THEIR
BEHALF- I CAN'T IMAGINE IN SIX
YEARS HOW MUCH OF THOSE
RETAINERS ADD UP TO. AND HOW
MUCH DOES THAT COME RELATIVE TO
WHAT WE'RE ACTUALLY LOOKING TO
GET FOR FOLKS. AND IT'S BEEN
DIFFICULT WE HAVE FILED
NUMEROUS PUBLIC INFORMATION
REQUESTS- WHAT WE GET IS PIECES
OF INFORMATION OR JUST BROAD-
LINE ITEM EXPENDITURES IT'S
HARD TO PARCEL EXACTLY HOW MUCH
IS BEING SPENT ON AYE HSS
NEGOTIATIONS SPECIFICALLY. WE
THINK THAT BECAUSE OF THE FACT
THAT THIS PHENOMENON. OF
RETAINING THESE OUTSIDE VENDORS
AND THAT WE HAVE. YOU KNOW
HONESTLY AN INCENTIVE FOR THEM
TO NEVER NEGOTIATE BECAUSE
THEY'LL JUST KEEP COLLECTING
THEIR RETAINERS AS LONG AS THIS
KEEPS GOING. WE NEED TO HAVE
TRANSPARENCY HOW MUCH IS BEING
SPENT. AND WHAT DOES THAT LOOK
LIKE IN RELATION TO WHAT THE
ACTUAL COST WOULD BE TO JUST
SETTLE THE CONTRACT. SO THERE'S
A PERVERSE INCENTIVE THERE-
WE'D LIKE TO SEE A AN ACTION
REVERSE THAT AS TAKEN LAST
YEAR WHICH IS THAT ONCE THE
MINIMUM WAGE IT'S FIFTEEN
DOLLARS. THE COST RATIOS SO THE
SHARE OF COSTS WILL FLIP. WE'RE
THE COUNTIES WILL NOW PICK UP
65% OF THE NON FEDERAL SHARE
AND THE STATE WOULD PICK UP
THIRTY FIVE. SO THAT'S THE
OPPOSITE OF WHAT EXISTS NOW.
THE ONLY THING I WOULD SAY ON
THAT IS IF WE THINK IT'S HARD
NOW. IT'LL BE A HUNDRED TIMES
HARDER WHEN THIS POLICY IS
ENACTED ANYTHING THAT WOULD
INCREASE COSTS ON THE COUNTY
AND WOULD ONLY MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT TO GET CONTRACTS. AND
THEN THAT'S ALSO HOLDING TRUE
ON THE XCELERATED CASE LOW
GROWTH ALLOCATIONS THAT'S JUST
A REALLY FANCY WORD FOR WE NEED
TO GET THE MONEY FASTER.
BECAUSE THAT'S ANOTHER MAJOR
PROBLEM THAT ALWAYS COMES UP IN
NEGOTIATION SO I'LL WRAP UP
WITH THAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANY COMMENTS FROM- THE PARCEL
SERVICES TO THESE PROPOSALS
OKAY. RIGHT HELLO THE ON
FINANCE ALL RIGHT. SO IN TERMS
OF THE- SO WE HAD TO THE
COUNTIES ARGUING WILL WE GET AN
AGREEMENT LAST YEAR RIGHT AND
THERE ARE PROVISIONS PUT IN TO
TRY TO MOVE PEOPLE TO
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING RIGHTS
BECAUSE RECOGNIZE THAT WAS A
PROBLEM LAST YEAR. BASED ON.
WHAT YOU'RE PRESENTING NOW CAN
YOU MAYBE SPEECH TO THE EITHER
AFFECTED THIS OR AND
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE PROVISIONS
WE DID SO THEIR ARGUMENT IS
THAT WELL LOOK ON THE MIDDLE OF
THIS RIGHT AND WE ACTUALLY HAVE
MORE CONTRACTS WE READ BEFORE
BUT YOU KNOW AS YOU POINTED OUT
THERE STILL LIVES SOMEWHERE IN
TAX RATE. SO HOW CAN YOU CAN
YOU. TALK ABOUT WELL. SO WHY
SHOULDN'T WE GIVE THIS A CHANCE
RIGHT. GIVE A LITTLE LONGER-
IT'S HOW DO YOU SEE THAT THE
CURRENT NECK AND WHAT WE GREW
TO LAST YEAR IS SOMETHING
THAT'S- HEADED TOWARD FAILURE
ARE AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE SAYING
OR IS THAT SOME. SOMETHING LIKE
DO YOU TO SPEAK TO WHO- WHY THE
TOOLS ARE INSUFFICIENT. TO TRY
TO GET CONTRACTS AND REMAINING
COUNTIES- THAT WE WERE THAT WE
TRIED PUTTING IN PLACE LAST
YEAR. I WOULD ARGUE THAT
THERE'S A LOT MORE IN ADDITION
TO THE WITHHOLDING THAT'S GOING
ON THAT'S RESULTING IN
CONTRACTS GETTING- FINALIZED I
MEAN WE'VE HAD PUBLIC ACTIONS I
MEAN THERE'S BEEN ARRESTS
THERE'S BEEN CIVIL
DISOBEDIENCE. A PRESS YOU KNOW
CONTACTING LEGISLATORS TO
INTERVENE AND THE I MEAN. I
DON'T KNOW THAT THAT IN AND OF
ITSELF YES I WOULD SEE IT ADDED
TO IT BUT IN LIGHT OF THE FACT
THAT WE'VE HAD NEGOTIATORS SAY
WELL WE'LL TAKE THE 1% OR YOU
COULD TAKE THAT IN THE FORM OF
A TEN CENT INCREASE WE'RE GOOD
EITHER WAY. THAT TELLS ME THAT
THAT DOESN'T MEAN ANYTHING TO
ANYBODY RIGHT. HOW MUCH DID IT
HELP IT IT IS HELPFUL I'M SURE
THAT IT IS I DON'T THINK. THAT
WHAT WE HAVE IT SHOULD BE
MODELED IN ANY WAY WHICH IS
THAT WE GET AGREEMENTS AFTER
SHEDDING BLOOD SWEAT AND TEARS
AND- YOU KNOW LITERALLY GOING
ALL OUT IT SHOULDN'T BE THAT
WAY SO WHAT I WANT TO SAY IS.
YEAH THAT WE MIGHT HAVE GOTTEN
THERE IT'S LIKE SAYING YOU KNOW
WE LASTED TO THE VERY LAST
SECOND AND EIGHTY WE MADE IT.
IT SHOULDN'T BE THAT WAY
SHOULDN'T BE DRAGGING KICKING
AND SCREAMING IT SHOULD BE
LET'S DO THIS BECAUSE IT'S THE
RIGHT THING TO DO. OKAY I
APPRECIATE THAT. AT THE END I
KNOW YOU TO BE SPENT MOST OF
TIME TALKING ABOUT THESE ARE
TOUCHED ON XCELERATED CASE
GROWTH ALLOCATION SO YOU'RE
SAYING THAT THAT'S- TO- TRY TO
GET FASTER PAYMENT CORRECT YES
BECAUSE THAT IS A NUMBER ONE
COMPLAINT THAT WE RECEIVED FROM
COUNTY NEGOTIATORS IS THAT EVEN
IF THEY WANT. TO INCREASE THE
WAGE THEY CAN'T WAIT FOR THE
CASH FROM NINETEEN NINETY ONE
REALIGNMENT TO REACH THEM TO
COMPENSATE THEM FOR THAT
BECAUSE THERE'S AN AVERAGE LACK
OF TIME OF EIGHTEEN MONTHS SO
THEY DON'T WANT TO FRONT THOSE
COSTS. EXCEED FINE IT'S THE OF
A COMMENT ON THAT I WOULD JUST
LIKE. TO TEARS- THAT YOU KNOW
THAT THE PROCESS FOR XCELERATED
CASELOAD GROWTH WAS IN PLACE
ONLY FOR TWO YEARS- SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
WHEN THERE'S- COORDINATED CARE
INITIATIVE WAS ENDED AND WE
WENT BACK TO THE OLD- SHARING
RATIOS AND WE NEGOTIATE THE NEW
AND WE- SO. I WILL WHAT I'M
SAYING I GUESS IS THAT. THE
ISSUE. THEY RECEIVE THE FILES
EIGHTEEN MONTHS LATER THAT HAS
ALWAYS BEEN THE CASE PRIOR TO
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN. IT WILL BE
USED CASE I'LL BE PAYING IN.
TWELVE OKAY SIR. BASICALLY
GOING TO WHAT WAS BEFORE HER
EIGHT. SO ESSENTIALLY THERE
HISTORICALLY IT HAS BEEN-
VINEGAR ARE COUNTIES HAVE BEEN
REQUIRED TO BARGAIN AND
HISTORICALLY ODD WHEN THEY DO
BARGAIN THEY KNOW THAT THAT
FUNDING IS COMING LATER- WE
DON'T SEE THAT AS YOU KNOW A
BIG REASON OR A BIG DRIVER OF
WHY THE- YOU KNOW WHAT'S- WHAT
THE BARRIERS ARE TERRA. TERRA
NEGOTIATING BARGAINING OKAY.
BUT I WOULD POINT OUT DOCTOR
PAN AND I WANT TO SAY FINANCE
HAS BEEN VERY HELPFUL IN
GETTING US. WITH SPECIFIC
COUNTIES THAT HAVE THESE TYPE
OF QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW FAST
THEY'LL GET THEIR MONEY I WANT
TO POINT OUT SO WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE FISCAL PENALTY BUT WE
ARE WE HAVE PROPOSED IN THE
PAST THINGS LIKE EXHILARATING
CASELOAD GROWTH- GETTING
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS YOU KNOW
OFFSETTING COST LIKE. THE
CARROTS HAVE BEEN THERE FOR
MANY MOONS AND IT TOOK A LONG
TIME TO GET TO THE STICKS SO
IT'S NOT AS THOUGH LIKE WE'RE
JUST GOING FOR THE WORST CASE
SCENARIO THIS IS BECAUSE THE
CARDS DIDN'T WORK FOR A- PERIOD
OF TIME. OKAY ALL RIGHT. HEY
ANY OTHER COMMENTS ALL RIGHT
WELL THANK YOU. THE
PRESENTATION AND- SO WE ARE
PUTTING ITEM THANK YOU
DEVELOPMENT CELL OKAY THANKS
VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT. NEXT
PRESENTATION IS- DOES THE TERMS
OF A PROPOSAL FOR INVESTMENT IS
NUMBER THREE IS THAT A ALLOW
THE WAIVER PERSONAL CARE
SERVICES PROVIDERS TO BILLY TO
SEE PAID SICK LEAVE AND I THINK
WE HAVE S. YEAH YOU CALIFORNIA.
AND IS TWENTY FIFTEEN A
SEPARATE YOU GUYS WORKING
TOGETHER OR NOT SO YOU JUST
COVERS AT THIS ONE AND WILL
HAVE TWENTY FIFTY COMMERCENTRE
OKAY GOOD ALL RIGHT. WELCOME
AND IF YOU WANT TO COME UP IN.
NOW I'M BECAUSE THEY HAD TO
TOGETHER GAVE MORE TIMES WE
SERVE MASHED TO TOGETHER SO
THAT'S USED TO DO IT THREE
MINUTES YEAH THANK YOU. SO WE
CAN IT SHOULD FIRST INTRODUCE
YOURSELVES FOR THEIR RECORD AND
BEFORE YOU BEGIN PRESENTATION
TO ANYONE WITH A CA YOU
CALIFORNIA. GIVE J. DAVIS
WITHOUT W. PCS. OKAY WANT TO GO
AND BEGIN ALREADY TIFFANY
WHITENED WITH THE CSU
CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF OUR
OVER THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
FIVE THOUSAND LONG TERM CARE
WORKERS HERE TO RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR OUR
PROPOSAL RELATED TO WAY FOR
PERSONAL CARE PROVIDERS- AND
THEIR ABILITY TO RECEIVE PAID
SICK LEAVE AND SO TODAY WE HAVE
ONE OF OUR MEMBERS WHO IS A WAY
FOR PERSONAL CARE- PROVIDER
CHAD DAVIS- HOOSIER HERE'S- HIS
SHARE HIS EXPERIENCE THANK YOU.
LOGIC GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS-
MY NAME IS TED DAVIS AND I AM A
PERSONAL CARE. I'M A PERSONAL
CARE SERVICE PROVIDER MY CLIENT
IS GLENN. GREEN PEERS HE
QUALIFIES FOR A PERSONAL CARE
SERVICE PROGRAM BECAUSE HE'S
PARAPLEGIC. IS THAT IS REQUIRES
HIM UP TO EIGHT TO TEN HOURS OF
PERSONAL CARE DALY GLANDS MOM
IS ACTUALLY SAYS PROVIDER AND I
AM AN ADDITIONAL. OUR HEROES
THE ADDITION OUR HE RECEIVES
THROUGH THE DOUBLE PCS PROGRAM.
I HAVE KNOWN LYNN FOR OVER TWO
YEARS AND I HAVE BEEN PROVIDING
CARE FOR HIM SINCE THEN EVERY
SINGLE DAY I PROVIDE CLEAN WITH
A CARE WITH THE CARE HE NEEDS
TO STAYS SAFELY IN HIS HOME
THIS INCLUDES ASSISTANCE WITH
ACTIVITIES OF DAILY LIVING AND
TAKING CARE AND TAKING HIM TO
APPOINTMENTS HOUSEKEEPING TASK
AS WELL AS STRETCHING ENTRANCE
FROM HIM. TRANSFERRING HIM. TO
THE- FROM BED AND CHEER TO THE
FEW WITHOUT THE CARE OF FROM.
WITHOUT THE CARE FROM ME AND
HIS MOM GLENN WOULD BE WOULD
NOT BE ABLE TO REMAIN AT HOME.
I WANT TO BE. THAT MY BEST FOR
GLENN BUT THAT IS VERY
DIFFICULT WORK THAT IS VERY
DIFFICULT WORK TO DO IF I
CANNOT CARE FOR MYSELF WHEN I
BECOME ILL GOING TO WORK WHEN I
AM SICK PUTS GLENN AT RISK AND
MY WORK SUFFERS. THAT IS WHY I
AM HERE TODAY. I AM ASKING THE
THAT THIS COMMITTEE. TO BRING.
YOU KNOW EQUALITY PARITY TWO OF
MY BROTHERS AND SISTERS IN THE
DOUBLES PCS PROGRAMS. AND
INCLUDE US IN THIS THE STATE
SICK LEAVE LAW THAT EVERYONE
EVERY OTHER WORKER IN THE STATE
IS ENTITLED TO INCLUDED AYE
CHICEST PROVIDERS THERE ARE
LESS THAN ONE THOUSAND W. PCS
WORKERS ONLY. IN THE STATE.
STATEWIDE WHO ARE EXCLUDED FROM
THE LAW. AND WITHOUT PAID SICK
LEAVE MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE CONTINUES CARE FOR
CLIENTS LIKE GLAND IF THE STATE
DOES NOT MAKE THIS SMALL BUT
CRUCIAL. INVESTMENT YOU KNOW
WE'LL BE IN A- THE NINE I JUST
WANT TO SAY YOU KNOW THAT'S ME
AND IT JUST WANT TO SAY THANK.
YEAH THANK YOU. HE IS AT THE
TIME YOU CAN MAKE A REYES QUICK
STATEMENT IF YOU WANT TO
CONCLUDE SO JUST THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT WHEN THE TIME IS RIGHT
OKAY THANK YOU- COMES FROM
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES THIS
OKAY ALEJO FINANCE. RIGHT
QUESTIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT WELL I'D APPRECIATE
YOUR PRESENTATION THANK YOU- I
THINK THIS IS SOMETHING WE HAVE
RECOGNIZED ALSO IN THE PAST-
THAT THIS IS- NOT JUST THAT WE
HAVE THE SMALL NUMBER EL THIS
GROUP THE- GROUP OF FIVE PEOPLE
WHO WERE. DOING SIMILAR
SERVICES BUT YET AREN'T ABLE TO
ACCESS THE PAID SICK LEAVE
WHICH I KNOW WE FOUGHT HARD TO
GET FOR OTHER FOLKS AS WELL AND-
ACTUALLY- WE THINK ABOUT WHAT
WE'RE GOING THROUGH RIGHT NOW
AND WE NEED PEOPLE T BE ABLE
TO STAY HOME. AND FOR THE
PUBLIC HEALTH- WE NEED TO BE
SURE PEOPLE OF SICK LEAVE
BASICALLY SO THEY CAN. ONLY
TAKE CARE OF THEMSELVES BUT BE
SURE THAT DAY THAT WEEK THEY
CAN FOLLOW THE INSTRUCTIONS
THAT OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
AUTHORITIES ASKING PEOPLE TO
FOLLOW UP WITH. A POTENTIALLY
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT. DO YOU ALL RIGHT- NEXT
UP WILL HAVE- ESSIE LOCAL
TWENTY FIFTEEN WELCOME. AND
THIS IS ABOUT FROM RESTORATION
THE 7% CUT TO I JUST AS OURS.
THANK YOU. COME SHE CAN
INTRODUCE YOURSELVES THE RECORD
IN THREE MINUTES AT DOING HERE
WE CAN MAKE ROOM HERE. RIGHT WE
HAVE LOTS OF CHAIRS AROUND THE
TABLE IS WITH PEOPLE AROUND.
OKAY SO FIRST STEP FOR THE
RECORD IF YOU JUST INTRODUCE
YOURSELF THAT DOESN'T COUNT
AGAINST YOUR TIME. ANYWAY WITH
AS THE ARE YOU CALIFORNIA.
SERVER TIME AND ALSO AN ESSAY
YOU TWENTY FIFTEEN. WELCOME
YEAH. NICOLETTE EVAN LOW TWENTY
FIFTEEN ALL RIGHT EXCELLENT
WELCOME. AID IS THE CHAIR
NUMBER SEVENTY WAITING HERE
AGAIN I'M ON BEHALF OF THAT SAY
YOU CALIFORNIAN ARE THREE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND. LONG TERM CARE
MEMBERS WE COME IT SEEMS LIKE
EVERY YEAR TO ASK FOR THE SAME
THING AND IT'S GETTING A
LITTLE. LITTLE TIRE INFO WE'RE
COMING TO YOU ONCE AGAIN TO ASK
FOR A PERMANENT RESTORATION- OF
THE 7% AND WE HAVE TODAY
CLAUDIA- TO SHARE HER STORY WE
ALSO HAVE SERRA WHO TRANSLATE
FOR HER THANK YOU. YEAH ONE OF
THE S. ON. ME NUMBER IS CLAUDIA
ON THE CALL THAT A BUNDLE. SO
U. NOT WITH A LOTTA ANGKASA.
YOU CAN TELL A WHOLE BUT OF
THOSE DENTISTS- CONFETTI CIDA.
HE CAVING. TO SEE THAT THE IN
IT. MONTROSE COMPLETE GUS UNITS.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS CLAUDIA REVEL I AM HOME
CARE PROVIDER FOR TREES AND
KEVIN AND THERESA HAS MULTIPLE
CONDITIONS AND KEVIN AS WELL
HAS CHRONIC CONDITIONS. EL
PROGRAMA THE LAP FOR YOUR THIS
SAID BE SUING AND ALL THAT YES
THIS IS A- THAT WITHOUT WILL BE
DILUTES. OUR RESIDENT THIS MáS
WOULD LIMIT AB PLEASE FOR
EXAMPLE. BETTER SAUNAS MY YOUR
IS CALLING THE WRESTLES MINIMAL.
IT BETTER SO NASCO THIS CUP SEE
THAT. IN IS AREAS WITHIN THE
VEHICLE. CONCERT WOULD BE THAT
THE INDEPENDENCIA COMO SAMPLE
SEEM TO INSIST CASA. THE IN
HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES ARE
JUST AS PROGRAM PROVIDES BOTTLE
CARE TO OUR MOST VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS LOW INCOME SENIORS
AND PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
THEY MAY LIVE SAFELY AND AS
INDEPENDENTLY AS POSSIBLE IN
THEIR OWN HOMES. EL PROGRAMA
THEY YET TO SAY THIS IS BACK ON
SPENT THE MAIN THING. ANDREAS
GO. FOR MORE LIGHTLY MEAN ASEAN
THEY WON'T SEE IT THE POLICY
UNTIL. THE LOS FONDOS BURKE
ELEVENTH HOUR RESCUE AND THEN
SEE IF THE POLICY UNTIL ACM BUT
IT TEMPORE AT. THE I JUST AS
PROGRAM IS CONSTANTLY AT RISK
BY THE 7% FUNDING CUT BECAUSE
RESTORATION OF THE 7% IS ALWAYS
FOR A SHORT TIME PERIOD A
TEMPORARY- ANNUAL RESTORATION
OF THE 7% CUT AND NOT. IN A
PERMANENT REPORT NOT A POINT
RESTORATION CREATES INSTABILITY
IN THE LIVES OF CARE RECIPIENTS
LIKE MY CLIENT AND THEIR CARE
PROVIDERS LIKE ME. THE REST I
WOULD ASSUME TEMPLE RUN OR ON
THE SEA AT THE POLICY. GET AREA
IN ITS EE THAT. WATER BE THIS
THE PNP COMICALLY ANTI E. L. R.
ESO BROADWAY LONG FORMAL YOU'LL-
I'M SORRY TRANSLATED THAT PIECE
AS WELL YOU CAN MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT FUND GARCIA. HAD TO THAT
ONE ALREADY GO AHEAD. VALERIE
AWESOME. LIGHTLY MEAN ASEAN
THEN SEE AT THE POR CIENTO THEY
LOS FONDOS LAMINA SILOS CUIDADO
THEY ME KLAY ANTI IT THEM BMA
BORN ANDREAS GOAL THE BETTER
THEIR MUKASA NOT BY LAND OR
THAT A LOOK TO SEE THAT AND I
WON YOU'LL TO ASK WHEN DOES IN
THIS SOCIETY. NOT ONLY DOES A
7% CUT THREATEN MY CLIENTS CARE
BUT IT ALSO MEANS I AM
STRUGGLING TO KEEP A ROOF OVER
MY HEAD PAY THE ELECTRIC WATER
AND OTHER BILLS. I CUT. A CUT
TO MY CLIENTS HOURS PUTS US IN
AN UNSTABLE POSITION. LIGHTLY
MEAN ASEAN THEN SEE IF THE POR
CIENTO THE LOS FONDOS.
PHONEMICALLY IN THING NOT TO
DUSTY ON THE IN THE STUDY THAT.
PERMANENTLY RESTORING THE 7%
CUT TO I JUST SAYS THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE WILL BRING BACK
STABILITY OF CARE AND THE
THREAT TO BOTH CONSUMERS LIVES.
IN THE CARE BEING PROVIDED.
LAST I WOULD US JUMP IN MONEY
INTO THE SEA AT THE POR CIENTO
PORTLAND WHAT HATE A LATE.
BRISTOL WEST ALL. ARRIVE WITH
THAT'LL BUT HONESTLY AND THIS
IS PROBABLY EAT THAT I MEAN
THAT I LIE I'M IN NASSAU
BORDER. LEVY THAT. THEY LOST
BILLION THIS IAN AND WITHOUT
OKAY. BUT WOULD BE THE- SO WE
SEEM TO HAVE A GAP IN OUR
TRANSLATION BUT I'VE ALREADY
TRANSLATE TO BOTH OF THOSE
PIECES SO GO AHEAD GLORIA. MEET
ME CLEAR AND THEY THEY MADE THE
APPLICA BY ACCESS ALRIGHT
SOLVENCY LAST ORDER THEM WITH
ADULTS WE DON'T REALLY MEAN
THAT. MY CLIENT SHOULD NEVER
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT WHETHER HE-
OR SHE WILL HAVE ENOUGH HOURS
OF CARE. ALL AROUND LET BE A
LIST BE LAMAR LAMENT THE POOR
SLOB BALL YOU'LL DILEMMAS THAT
WOULD SEM THAT MONEY DAY THEY
SEE IT THE POLICY THE PHONE
THOUGH BUT YET SAYS GLASSES BUT
TODAY I ASK YOU TO SUPPORT A
TROOP PERMANENT RESTORATION OF
THE 7% CUT TO THE I JUST AS
PROGRAM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANY COMMENTS FROM. FOR SOCIAL
SERVICES. OHIO FINANCE. IS. SO
I OBVIOUSLY- YOU KNOW THAT
THERE WOULD BE A SIGNIFICANT IN.
AS FAR AS THE BUDGET FOR THAT
THE FINAL YEAR OF THE MULTI
YOUR UTLOOK WOULD WOULD HAVE
TO BE INCREASED SIGNIFICANTLY
WHICH- YOU KNOW COULD. CREATE
SOME SOME PROBLEMS THIS WAS
PART OF- AN AGREEMENT LAST YEAR
TO PUSH OUT THE DATE- THE
ADMINISTRATION BASED ON YOU
KNOW- REVENUE PROJECTIONS AND
EXPENDITURE PROJECTIONS WE-
HAVE PUSH UPDATE FURTHER
ANOTHER EIGHTEEN MONTHS SO
UNDERSTANDING IT'S STILL. ARE
NOT VERY SATISFYING- BUT IT IS-
YOU KNOW IT WAS IT WAS A WAY
TO- YOU KNOW IT'S A WAY TO KEEP
THE BUDGET. IN LINE AS WE GET
THROUGH THE FINAL YEAR OF THE
MULTI YEAR WE WILL BE LOOKING
AT THIS AGAIN AS PART OF THE
MAY REVISION- IN TERMS OF
UPDATED REVENUES AND
EXPENDITURE INFORMATION. OKAY
QUESTION COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ASSERTIVE. HAVE A QUICK COMMENT
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR WHICH
IS WITH HIS PERRIN NEEDY BASHES
DUSTY MONDIAL OR HE YEAH MY
LITTLE WITCHES SO. LAME
PROMOTION GET YOUR WHICH IS
LESS YES. THE THINKING HER FOR
COMING UP AND COMMENTING TODAY.
RIGHT SO- THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION. SO I'M GONNA
MAKE A TO THE COMMON ABOUT THIS
IN A MAYBE A BROADER COMMENT
AND I A NOW WE'VE BEEN TALKING
WITH ACTUALLY TO SPEND SOME
TIME HERE TODAY TALKING ABOUT
OUT YOUR PROJECTIONS AND HOW WE
GET ACCURATE ONES. AND SO YOU
KNOW I GUESS THE THING I'M THAT
THE MASSES SOME FRUSTRATION
WITH- SO YOU'RE THE ONE WHO'S
ACTUALLY SITTING HERE BUT YOU
CAN SEND THAT TO YOUR BOSS IS
THAT. SO I MEAN I SO I HEAR
WHAT YOU SAID ABOUT OUT YOUR
PROJECT BUT THEN WHAT I'M SAID
THAN WHAT YOU'RE SORT OF SAYING
IS OUR FINANCES SAYING I DON'T
SEE E. L. YOU PERSONALLY. IS
THAT WHILE WE ARE PROJECTING
THAT. IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE
THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE LARGE
CUTS TO HSS TO A WHOLE BUNCH OF
OTHER BY THE WAY I NOTICE THEY
ALL HAPPEN TO BE SOCIAL SERVICE
PROGRAMS. RIGHT I MEAN THEY'RE
NOT ACROSS THE BOARD WE'RE NOT
DOING THIS ACROSS THE BOARD IN
THE BUDGET. THERE ARE SOCIAL
SERVICE PROGRAMS AND I HAPPEN
TO CHAIR THE SUBCOMMITTEE SO I
NOTICED THAT YOU KNOW I GO
CHECK WHERE ELSE IN THE BUDGET
DO WE HAVE THIS AUTOMATIC
CLIFFS. IT'S ONLY IN SOCIAL
SERVICES AND I'M GOING WHAT IS
THAT WHY IS THAT. IS THAT FAIR.
I MEAN FOR REALLY THAT ANXIOUS
ABOUT IT WHY IS IT THAT. YOU
KNOW AND AGAIN WE DON'T KNOW
WE'RE IN THE LONGEST EXPANSION
SOME POINT WEBER SESSION SO
FORTH. AND SO WHAT IS THAT
SUPPOSED TO MEAN IS THERE A
COMMITMENT THEN FOR SOCIAL
SERVICES THAT YOU KNOW WHAT
WE'RE REBUILDING YOUR CUT SO
YOU GET. YOU KNOW IT AT WILL
CUT FROM EVERYWHERE ELSE EXCEPT
YOU BUT I DON'T HEAR THAT
EITHER OR SOMEBODY. WHAT I HEAR
IS A WHAT IT TAKES SOCIAL
SERVICE YOU GET AUTOMATIC CUT
AND THEN WE START TALKING ABOUT
HOW HE CUT EVERYBODY. WHICH
MEANS OF SERVICES TAKES IT ON
THE CHIN AGAIN. AND THAT THAT
I'M- YOU KNOW. RELEASE
STRUGGLING WITH BECAUSE I IT
DOESN'T REFLECT MY VALUES I AM
SURE DOESN'T REFLECT THE
GOVERNOR'S OUTSIDE CERTAINLY
HELP. AND SO WE BUILT IT IN AND
YOU KNOW IT AND THEN DID YOU
SAID YOU WERE DOING OUT YEARS
RIGHT WE BUDGET PER YEAR BUT WE
DO OUT YEARS BECAUSE WE TRY TO
BE RESPONSIBLE. BUT I ALSO AM
THINKING LIKE WELL. IS THAT
BEING RESPONSIBLE TO BUILD IN
AN AUTOMATIC CUT T IT'S EITHER
THAT OR WE HAVE TO OWN IT'S
LIKE WELL WE ARE PLANNING TO WE
DON'T REALLY WANT TO BUT WE ARE
PLAIN TO. IN THE ABSENCE OF.
YEAH SO I AND THAT'S THE FIRST
THAT SIMPLY THE FIRST TO FALL
BECAUSE THE ONLY THIS IS THE
HOW THESE ARE THE ONLY PROGRAMS
THAT HAVE THIS. CUT BILL TEN
RIGHT NO ONE ELSE HAS A BUILT
IN THAT WAY. WE DON'T DO IT A
LOT OF OTHER PLACES BUT WE'RE
GONNA BUILD IT IN. AND OUT YOUR
PROJECTS FOR SOCIAL SERVICES.
SO THAT YOU KNOW SO BASICALLY
THAT TRIGGER WE DON'T HAVE TO
PULL THE TRIGGER IT JUST
AUTOMATICALLY HAPPENS. SO I
DON'T I AM. HI I HOPE WE CAN
HAVE A DISCUSSION ABOUT THAT
THAT'S PROBABLY A LITTLE LARGER
DISCUSSION WITH LIKE THE FULL
NOW WITH BUDGET IN THE GOVERNOR
AND AT THE LEADERSHIP LEVEL BUT
I REALLY HAVE A TREMENDOUS
DISCOMFORT WITH THE IDEA THAT
WE YOU KNOW WE TALKED ABOUT
THIS AND WE CAN SAID WELL
DOESN'T REALLY HAPPEN UNTIL
NEXT YEAR OR SO LITTLE AT ALL
IT'S NOT GONNA REALLY HAPPEN
IT'S GOT MORE ON PAPER AND YES
WE CAN PUSH IT OUT PAPER BUT-
AT SOME POINT WHAT WE ARE
SAYING THAT IS THAT WE SET UP
ALL THESE PROGRAMS INCLUDING
ITEM. S. WHICH WOULD TALK ABOUT
HOW BUT ALSO OTHERS FOR AN
AUTOMATIC FALL. QUOTE IF WE
NEED IT. RIGHT AND SO WE DO OUR
FIVE YEAR PROJECTION WE BUILD
IN AND WE SAY GUESS WHAT. SO
THAT IS SO WE'RE NOT BUT WE
DON'T DO THAT UNIVERSALLY
ACROSS THE BOARD WHICH HAS TO
IT FOR CERTAIN PROGRAMS AND
THEY ALL SEEM TO BE. SOCIAL
SERVICE PROGRAMS SO. YOU KNOW.
THAT I COULD SELL- THIS IS OUR
FIRST HEARING FOR THIS BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE SO. I TAKE A
LITTLE MORE TIME TO I MADE
REFER TO THIS. SAID THE
COMMENTS LATER AGAIN AND AGAIN
BUT INSTEAD OF GOING DURING THE
LONG CUT VERSION EACH TIME. I
MEAN I THINK THAT IS SOMETHING
WE NEED TO TALK ABOUT. NOW IS
THIS THE IN OUR BUDGETING
APPROACH BECAUSE- EITHER WE
REALLY THINK THERE'S GONNA BE A
CLINTON. YOU KNOW I'M I'VE BEEN
SUPPORTING EL RAINY DAY FUNDS
AND OTHER TYPES OF THINGS TO
MITIGATE. BUT WERE. BUT WE'RE
ALSONOT TREATING EVERYONE THE
SAME ARE SIMILARLY RIGHT
SELLERS WHAT WE'VE SAID IS THAT
CERTAIN PROGRAMS. WE'RE GONNA
BUILD IN AN AUTOMATIC CUT AND
OTHERONES WERE NOT AND WAS
THAT SUPPOSED TO SAY WHAT'S
THAT TELLING EVERYBODY. RIGHT
AND I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING WE
NEED TO REALLY THINK ABOUT AND
HAVE A BROADER CONVERSATION
ABOUT- SO. CERTAINLY YOU KNOW I
THINK IN THE PAST AS CERTAINLY
AGREED WITH TRYING TO DO THE
PERMIT RESTORATION AND IF WE
ARE GOING TO MAKE THE CUT AGAIN
BECAUSE OF WHATEVER BUDGETARY
THINGS WE SHOULD DO IT
CONSCIOUSLY. AND NOT
AUTOMATICALLY THAT'S MY VIEW
ABOUT IT SO- I KNOW WE HAVEN'T
QUITE GOTTEN THERE AND ANY
PREVIOUS BUDGET AND FINAL
GRIEVANCES SO FORTH BUT I DON'T
WANT TO DO THINGS AUTOMATICALLY
I WANT TO DO THINGS CONSCIOUSLY
WE ARE BUDGETS REFLECTIVE
PRIORITIS AND WE SHOULD. JUST
LIVING I AM YEAH YES WE HAVE TO
MAKE THAT. ABOUT TWENTY BILLION
DEFICIT ME MAKE. CUTS I DIDN'T
WANT TO MAKE. BUT WE DID THOSE
CONSCIOUSLY. RIGHT AND SO FOUR
DEMOCRATS IN THE FUTURE WE'RE
IN GOOD TIMES NOW WE SHOULD
MAKE THEM CONSCIOUSLY AND NOT
JUST AUTOMATICALLY AND BUILT IN.
AT A TIME AND LET'S SETTLE IN
REALLY INTEND TO DO. AND THEN
WE HAVE ALL DIFFERENT TACK
CONVERSATION BECAUSE IT HAD A-
CUT BUT WE DON'T CáC GREAT
BECAUSE WELL DON'T WORRY ABOUT
IT'S NOT REALLY HAPPENING IS
OUT THERE. BUT WHAT'S BUT YOU
KNOW WHAT'S OUT THERE SUPPOSED
TO MEAN SO. I'M FORTY I KNOWYOU'RE THE ONLY MEMBER FINANCES
pMAYBE SOMEONE IN THE AUDIENCE
BUT I MEAN I THINK THAT'S A
DAY- AND- EAT OKAY WELL IF YOU
WISH TO RESPOND- I I'M NOT
GONNA HOLD YOU PERSONALLY
ACCOUNTABLE BUT I THINK YEAH. I
CAN I CAN YOU KNOW I CAN ASSURE
THAT THE THAT THE GOVERNOR
DOESN'T WANT TO SEE THESE
PROGRAMS GET REDUCED- I THINK
WHAT. WHAT WE'RE KIND OF EIGHT
AND IN IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW WHY
THEY'RE THERE PATTERN ARE YOU
KNOW HE'S FUTURE CUTS ARE
REFLECTED IN THESE AREAS. I
MEAN THERE THERE IT REALLY
DOES- COME DOWN TO LIKE WHERE
WHERE CAN WE- IF WE HAVE TO
MAKE REDUCTIONS WHERE CAN WE
MAKE REDUCTIONS NOW I THINK
DEFINITELY WORKING WITH
LEGISLATURE. TO IF THERE ARE
OTHER AREAS OF THE BUDGET- THAT
YOU KNOW THERE CAN BE AGREEMENT
ON TO MAKE REDUCTIONS AND I
THINK WE'RE HAPPY TO OBVIOUSLY
HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS AND I
THINK THOSE CONVERSATIONS WILL
BE HAPPY- IN THE NEAR FUTURE-
BUT I JUST WANTED TO REITERATE
THAT YOU KNOW. THE GOVERNOR
DOES CARE ABOUT THESE PROGRAMS
THESE ARE NOT- HE DOES NOT TAKE
YOU KNOW LOOK AT THESE AS AS
YOU'RE TAKING THESE REDUCTIONS
LIGHT A- UP I'M- BUT WHAT DO
YOU. TO GET A WE HAVE
STRUCTURAL WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO HAVE A
STRUCTURAL YOU KNOW WE MAY NOT.
A BUDGET THAT IS. YOU KNOW. UP
STRUCTURE IN A SOUND MANNER AND-
AGAIN. I THINK. YOU KNOW WITH
THE ECONOMY CAN AS THE WEIGHT
HOUSE. THAT WE WERE ABLE PUSH
THESE REDUCTIONS OUT IT WOULD
BE WONDERFUL WE COULD PUSH THEM
OUT OF THE WAY THE MULTI YEAR
WINDOW COMPLETELY- BUT WE'LL
HAVE TO SEE HOW THINGS LOOK AT
THE MAYOR VERSION AND THEN I'M
SURE WE'LL BE HAVING MORE
CONVERSATIONS. OKAY WELL I
APPRECIATE A RESPONSE. A HOPE
ALSO MY PREVIOUS QUESTIONS THAT
WERE ABOUT HOW ACTIVE WERE
PROJECTING SHOWS ALSO MY OWN
PERSONAL COMMITMENT TO BE SURE
WE DO ACCURATE LONG TERM
BUDGETING SO I AND YOU KNOW
WE'RE I THINK WE'RE IN THAT
TOGETHER AND TERMS OF SAYING.
YOU KNOW AND I KNOW I'M SURE
LA- WORKS WITH US ON THAT AS
WELL SO WE WANT HAVE. ACCURATE
IS ACTORS POSSIBLE REALIZING
THERE'S ALWAYS YOU KNOW THINGS
THAT WE- BOTH WE DON'T CONTROL
WE DON'T KNOW BUT- LOOKING OUT
TO THE FUTURE. BUT IN THINKING
ABOUT AS WE'RE DOING THE OUT
YEARS. HOW WERE YOU PLANNING
FOR THIS IN A WAY THAT REFLECTS
OUR VALUES. RIGHT SO THAT'S WHY
I SAID YOU KNOW IF WE'RE IF I
WEEKS BACK TO MAINTAIN A
CERTAIN LEVEL OF EFFORT FOR.
LONG TERM SERVICES SUPPORTS AND
WE KNOW OUR DEMOGRAPHICS ARE
GONNA BE CHANGING OVER YOU
KNOW. SO AND THERE'S GOING TO
BE A CERTAIN CASELOAD GROWTH I
MEAN IT'S AN ESTIMATE BUT YOU
KNOW YOU KNOW THAT YOU HAVE.
CERTAIN TRY YOU KNOW CERTAIN
AGE RANGES YOU HAVE A CERTAIN
PERCENTAGE PEOPLE NEED THESE
SERVICES ETCETERA RIGHT I MEAN
IT WE CAN MODEL THAT ARE EXPECT
THAT IN THE SAME WAY WE CAN
MODEL OUR ECONOMY. SOMETHING'S
WRONG BUT WE GET PRETTY CLOSE
AND- SO WE SHOULD. I TO. WAS
ACTUALLY AS POSSIBLE. WHAT
WHERE WE'RE GOING TO GO AND
THEN MAKE THE KIND OF DECISIONS
WE NEED TO MAKE TO BE SURE THAT
YOU KNOW WE DON'T CORPORATE
THAT WE'RE ALMOST SAYING THAT
AND THAT'S FOR THE REASON WE
HAD INFORMATIONAL HEARING
ABOUT. LTE SS COUPLE OF THIS
ONE YET THE CUT PREVIOUS
CONVERSATION THEN I WAS LIKE
WELL WE WEREN'T REALLY LOOKING
TEACHER WELL THEN WE'LL GET OUT
PROJECTIONS IF WE'RE NOT
BUILDING IN THE GROWTH IN THE
POPULAR YOU KNOW THE CHANGE IN
THE POCKET. OR SET UNDER BUDGET
FOR THE AT THE WHAT WE'RE
TELLING PEOPLE THAT ACTUALLY
INTENTION IS TO CUT THOSE ARE
ISN'T FUTURE THIS WEEK KISSED
YOU KNOW THERE'S A CERTAIN
LEVEL NOW WE CAN AND I'M
LOOKING FOR MASTER PLAN JANGAN
WORK WILL RESTRAIN THE SIR IN A
WAY THAT MORE EFFICIENT AT
EIGHT OHMS SO WHAT WE REALLY.
THAT MUCH MONEY THERE KNOW FOR
SURE MAYBE WE'LL REDO THE WAY
WE DO THINGS BUT HELLO UNTIL E
CHANGE THE WAY WE DO THINGS WE
CAN'T GO AHEAD WELL BY THE WAY
BUDGET HAPPENED. RIGHT THANKS.
WE WORK WITH YOU THEN AS- AND I
THE GOV. THERE'S ABOUT THE
SERVICES THAT CERTAINLY NOT
IMPLYING HE DOES NOT- ANYWAY.
BUT I AM ALSO BIT FRUSTRATED
THAT WE HAVE BUILT IN. TO OUR
LONG TERM PROJECTIONS.
ESSENTIALLY AUTOMATIC CUTS THAT
YOU KNOW WE MAY NEED TO MAKE IN
A BAD YEAR OR RECESSION WE DID
PUT IN RAINY DAY FUNDS BY THE
WAY TRY TO SET UP BUT I AM
THINKING YELLED THAT- AT HAVING
BEEN AROUND IN THE BED TIME
IT'S EASY TO ALLOW THINGS TO
HAPPEN AUTOMATICALLY I PREFER
WE DO THIS CONSCIOUSLY INSTEAD
OF LETTING SETTING THINGS UP SO
THAT. CERTAINLY CERTAIN THE
PROGRAMS ON TO TAKE THE HIT AND
THEN WE HAVE THE CONVERSATION
ABOUT WHAT'S NEXT ONCE THEY GET
IT SO JUST MY PERSPECTIVE. AND
I THINK THAT'S THE END OF THE-
I WANT I WANT TO. POINT
ANYMORE- ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
ALL RIGHT OKAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION ALL
RIGHT- SOBRE GUIDES NEXT HERE
AS I SEE OTHER PEOPLE STANDING
IN LINE WE ARE GOING TO HEAR-
WHICH ALSO RELATED TO HSS IS
THE B. C. T. ON D. V. V. FOR.
HSS WHICH HAS HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES OFFICE OF SYSTEM
INTEGRATION AND DS AND SOCIAL
FROM SOCIAL SERVICES. USE OF
YOU CAN JUST COME UP HERE DO
THAT PRESENTATION AND THEN
WE'LL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ALL OF ITS US. THANK YOU SO YOU
CAN PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELVES
FOR THE RECORD PLEASE. IN THE
TECHNIQUE THEIR. DON'T TOUCH
ANYTHING. I THAT'S A IS ON THE
GOOD- CYNTHIA TUCKER WITH THE
OFFICER SYSTEMS INTEGRATION.
DEBBIE THOMPSON DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES IT'LL PROGRAMS.
CAN JOHNSON DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES. JACKIE
BRASILIA FINANCE THEY COMPORT
FINANCE ALL RIGHT SO IT IS THE
PCP ON TV FOR IT I JUST US YES
HI SO WE HAVE A COMBINED BCP
FOR CALIFORNIA FARM SOCIAL
SERVICES IN OFFICE SYSTEMS
INTEGRATION. ELECTION IS A
VERIFICATION WHICH OF COURSE IS
REQUIRED IN THE TWENTY FIRST
pOF SERVICES BEING RENDERED SO
THE TOTAL REQUEST IS FOR TWENTY
POINT SEVEN MILLION SIX POINT
ONE MILLION OF THAT IS GENERAL
FUND. ONE POINT THREE MILLION
IS FOR ONE TIME ET THE
IMPLEMENTATION COMMUNITY
OUTREACH IMPLEMENTATION IS
EXPECTED TO GO THROUGH THAT THE
END OF THIS YEAR THERE'S
NINETEEN POINT FOUR MILLION
ONGOING. FOR ETV HELP DESK
TRAINING INFRASTRUCTURE AND A
SUBSYSTEM REFINEMENTS AND WHEN
WE DISCUSS SYSTEM REFINEMENTS
TALKING BUT NOT ONLY THE
ONGOING DEVELOPMENT ANY
REFINEMENTS. NEEDED BY THE I
JUST AS PROGRAM- AS WELL AS AT
FEEDBACK FROM USERS. THAT'S A
VERY HIGH LEVEL WHAT THE
PROPOSALS FOR IT OR NOT THERE'S
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTION ON THAT.
AND THEN YOUR SECOND QUESTION
WHICH I'VE LOST MY PAPER. I IS
IN REGARDS TO THAT THE LOOK THE
SAME MASS SO- LIKE I JUST SAID
ABOUT SYSTEM REFINEMENT SEEN AS
THE PROGRAM NEEDS- CHANGE HERE
OR THERE OR FROM PASSED A COLOR
FEEDBACK IT IS NOT PLANNED OR
EXPECTED THAT THIS REQUEST FOR
CHANGE BASED ON ASSETS WHEN
CONVERSATIONS WITH CMS-
WHATEVER DISCUSSIONS WOULD
OCCUR IT'S EXPECTED THAT IT
WOULD BE BUILT ON TOP. OF WHAT
WE ARE CURRENTLY BUILDING
ROLLING OUT NOT THAT WE WOULD.
START FROM SCRATCH AGAIN RIGHT
SO ALL OF THE EXTREMELY GOOD
WORK THAT'S HAPPENED- WITH THE
AT THE COMMUNITY WITH REGARDS
TO ROLL OUT IN LA AND- AND
PHASE ONE X. ADDRESS- WOULD
CONTINUE AND IT WOULDN'T BE
SCRAPPED IT WOULD JUST BE.
AUGMENTED OKAY IN JUST A CLEAR
FOR WOULD YOU NEED DO YOU
ANTICIPATE YOU DATE POTENTIAL
FUNDS FOR AUGMENTATION I GUESS
IT'S A LITTLE HARD TOGUESS
BECAUSE YOU DON'T KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT THE CHANGES MIGHT BE FROM
THE FEDS BUT- WE DON'T EXPECT
IT- BUT YES WITH THE WAY THE
DISCUSSIONS ARE CRYING WE- WE
DON'T BELIEVE. WE BELIEVE IT
WOULD BE ENCOMPASSED WITHIN
THESE REFINEMENT COSTS THAT
WE'VE ALREADY AND STATE IT IS
THERE OKAY THANK YOU SOCIAL
SERVICES. NOTHING MORE JUST
AGAIN IT'S TO BE DETERMINED
RIGHT WE ARE CONTINUING TO WORK
THROUGH THE CONVERSATION WITH
CMS RELATE RELATED TO THE
MANDATE WHETHER OR NOT. THE
PROCESS WHICH WE HAD PREVIOUSLY
APPROVED AND MEETS THE
FREQUENTLY ASKED QUESTIONS WITH
THE SINCE BEEN RAISED. TO BE
DETERMINED IN CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS ARE CURRENT.
DEVELOP OKAY WE AGREE WITH THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION TO HOLD
THIS OPEN UNTIL. WE'RE ABLE TO
FINISH THE STATION LET'S SEE I
THINK IT UP UNDERSTAND. THE
ALTERNATE BECAUSE THIS THAT
DESIGNED IN HOW THESE FUNDS
WILL SUPPORT THAT. THANK YOU
FINANCE. OKAY QUESTIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OKAY NOW
THINK SYMMETRY PRESENT. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO
AND TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT IN ALL
OF THE ITEMS RELATED TO I ITS
SS- CAN INTRODUCE YOURSELVES
AND THANK YOU WELCOME. I AM MY
NAME IS JUDY JACKSON I'M HERE
WITH THE ALAMEDA COUNTY FOOD
BANK. I WANT TO ANSWER YOUR
EARLIER QUESTION ABOUT
PROJECTIONS. IN MY CASE I TOOK
OVER CARE FOR MISS CAROL
BECAUSE SHE HAD NO FAMILY. AND
I'M TOOK THE TRAINING FOR AL
TIMERS AND WAS TOLD THAT HER
CONDITION WILL CONTINUE GET
WORSE SO SHE WILL NEED MORE AND
MORE CARE. RIGHT NOW I'M TOLD
SHE GETS NO MORE I HSS HOURS
UNLESS SHE HURTS HERSELF FOR
SOMEONE. AND I DON'T THINK THAT
HAS ANYTHING TO DO WITH WHAT
SHE NEEDS TO BE ABLE TO STAY IN
HER HOME. FIVE SUPPORT ANY
INCREASE IN OUR DATE PROVIDERS
SALARIES BECAUSE WE'D BEEN TWO
MONTHS TRYING TO FIND AN EXTRA
PROVIDER TO TAKE CARE OF HER
WHEN HER REGULAR PROVIDER CAN'T
DO IT. THANK YOU. I CAN. OKAY
WELCOME DOESN'T GET CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES-
IN OPPOSITION TO THE TO
STAKEHOLDER PROPOSALS RELATED
TO INCREASE FOR SIX NINE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING ON THE
FIRST ONE WITH INCREASING THE
PENALTY YOU KNOW WE REALLY VIEW
THIS AS A KIND OF MAKING A
REFERENDUM ON THE NEW PROCESS
THAT WE JUST ESTABLISHED LAST
YEAR WITHOUT EVEN LIKE IN THAT
PROCESS BE TESTED WE'RE ONLY AT
STEP ONE OF FOUR OF TESTED 25%
OF THE PROCESS NEEDS COUNTIES
CERTAINLY WE SHARE THE BILL OF.
IT'S REACHED PAYMENT WE KNOW IT.
IT INTO. COUNTIES CONSENT GOING
TO MORE TO. IN SOME OF THEM.
BUT LET'S TEST THE NEW PROCESS
THAT WE ALL CAME TOGETHER AND
ESTABLISH. A BEFORE MAKING A
JUDGMENT CALL ON WHETHER IT
WORKS OR NOT AND WHETHER THE
PENALTY NEEDS TO BE INCREASED.
ON THE ISSUE OF- KIND OF
CONTRACT CONSULTANTS FOR
BARGAINING. YOU KNOW IN MANY
CASES COUNTIES HAVE A- A
STANDING UP PARTNERSHIP- ACROSS
ALL KIND OF COUNTY CONTACT NOT
JUST RELATED AYE ACCESS. AND SO
THESE ARE KIND OF AGAIN
INDIVIDUAL COUNTY DECISIONS
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBERS
OF- COUNTY IS THAT. PARTNER
WITH A CONTRACT CONSULTANTS-
FOR I'D SAYS FIRST COUNTIES A
DON'T YOU KNOW THE AT THE
AMOUNT OF AGREEMENT IS PRETTY
MUCH AT THE SAME RATE AND SO
AGAIN WE THINK THIS.
RESTRICTION TO BE UNLIKE ANY
OTHER RESTRICTION ON COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING- EMITTED NOR IS A
PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE ON
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AND
AGREEMENTS AND HE'S COUNTIES.
DO YOU DISEASE. AND SO WOULD
OPPOSE. WELL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WELCOME THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FRANK MCCOURT THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN OPPOSITION TO THE U. D.
W. BARGAINING PROPOSALS A
LITTLE BIT OF HISTORICAL
PERSPECTIVE PRIOR TO
BARGAINING- THE LEGISLATURE HAD
OPTIONS- TO IMPOSE BARGAINING
ON COUNTIES OR TO DO THE
BARGAINING YOURSELVES. THE
UNIONS RECOMMENDED LOCAL
BARGAINING WE RECOMMENDED STATE
BARGAINING AND WE LOST. MANY OF
THE REASONS THAT WE ARGUED FOR
BY STATE BARGAINING WOULD BE
SUPERIOR ARE MANIFEST IN THE
DEBATE WE'RE HAVING OVER WHAT
THE BARGAINING RULES ARE. IF AT
SOME POINT THE STATE'S FOR-
ROLE IN LOCAL BARGAINING IS TO
IS TO DICTATE THE TERMS NOT THE
OUTCOME. IF WE WANT TO GET TO
THE POINT WHERE WE BELIEVE AS A
MATTER OF PUBLIC POLICY. THAT
THERE'S A PREDETERMINED OUTCOME
AND THAT IS A GREATER FLOOR OF
WAGES FOR EVERYONE WHO DELIVERS
AYE HSS WAGES. LOCAL BARGAINING
ISN'T THE ONLY WAY FOR YOU TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT YOU CAN
ESTABLISH THAT IN LAW. YOU CAN
ALSO HAVE BARGAINING DONE AT
THE STATE LEVEL RATHER THAN THE
LOCAL LEVEL THOSE TWO
APPROACHES. IN OUR OPINION DO
REQUIRE THE STATE PAY MORE THAN
THEY OTHERWISE WOULD. BUT I
JUSTWANTED TO BE CLEAR ABOUT
THE FACT THAT LOCAL BARGAINING
ISN'T THE ONLY WAY TO CONCEIVE
BARGAINING IT WASN'T OUR IDEA.
I'M AND YOU HAVE OTHER OPTIONS
RATHER THAN TO INAPPROPRIATELY
IN OUR IN OUR OPINION AS THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD TO. DICTATE NOT
JUST THE TERMS OF THE
BARGAINING BUT TO TAKE THE
OUTCOMES WHICH IS AN
APPROPRIATE. THANK YOU WELCOME
MY NAME IS MY NAME IS BRENDA
AND I'M HOME CARE PROVIDER AND
I'M HERE TODAY TO THE ACTS FOR
SUPPORT FOR ADOBE PC A HOME
CARE PROVIDERS AS WELL THEY
NEED- SICK DAYS JUST AS WELL AS
WE DO AT THEIR HOME CARE
PROVIDERS JUST LIKE I AM AND
THEY DESERVE TO HAVE SICK DAYS
RIGHT ALONG WITH SICK PAY THANK
YOU. AND PLEASE SUPPORT US
THANK YOU THANK YOU. WELCOME IS
LORNA AND I AM. PROUD MEMBER OF
IT YEAH YOU LOCAL TWENTY
FIFTEEN. AND I'D JUST LIKE TO
SAY FIRST OF ALL ARE WE
EXPECTING SOME PANDEMIC THAT'S
GOING TO BE KILLING OFF JUST
ARE ELDERLY AND DISABLED FOR
PEOPLE BECAUSE IF YOU HAVE
BUDGET US FOR THAT SHORTFALL.
IN THOSE YEARS OUT IS THAT WHAT
YOU'RE EXPECTING BECAUSE WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THIS BY HAVING TO
PUT TOGETHER A MASTER PLAN OF
AGING BECAUSE WE HAVE A TSUNAMI
OF AGING PEOPLE COMING. AND
HERE IN FACT. WHAT ARE YOU
SAYING THAT SPEAK NOW TO BOTH
SIDES YOU'RE SAYING YOU'RE
EXPECTING MORE ELDERLY PEOPLE
AND EXPECTING MORE DISABLED
PEOPLE TO BE REQUIRING THESE
SERVICES THAT IN HOME SUPPORT
SERVICES PROVIDE. AND YET
YOU'RE GIVEN AN AUTOMATIC CUT
THE BUDGET SO THAT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE TO ME SO DOCTOR PAN I'M
JUST AS- FRUSTRATED YOU ARE
BECAUSE- WE'VE GOT SOME LONG
TERM GOALS. REACHED OUT THERE
THAT YOU'RE A FOCUSING ON BUT
THEY'RE ALL CUTS. OTHER
AUTOMATIC CUTS TO THE SOCIAL
PROGRAMS THAT AFFECT THE POOR
PEOPLE OF THIS COUNTRY AND I
WAS CERTAINLY OF THE STATE
THAT'S NOT HOW WE ROLL HERE.
THAT'S NOT HOW WE SHOULD BE.
AND CERTAINLY ANY CUTS IT
SHOULD BE MADE SHOULD HURT WHEN
THEY ARE MADE THAT SHOULD BE
AUTOMATIC IN THEJUST. LEFT ON
THE TABLE THEY SHOULD HURT AND
THEY SHOULD BE- MADE
CONSCIOUSLY WITH A CONCERT
EFFORT NO THE PEOPLE THAT
YOU'RE LOOKING AT ARE THE ONES
THAT YOU'RE CUTTING. IT SHOULD
HAPPEN THAT WAY ALSO THE 7% I'M
TIRED OF COMING UP HERE AND
ASKING FOR YOU TO FUNDED
PROGRAM HUNDRED PERCENT. THAT
USED TO BE A 100% FUNDED AND
TELL A GOVERNOR CAME IN AND
TOOK THAT AWAY AND SO I'D LIKE
TO SEE THAT- ALMOST HAD IT IN
PLACE LAST YEAR WE THOUGHT FOR
SURE. SO I DON'T KNOW BUT HOW.
MY 7% REDUCTION. IN MY CLIENTS
HOURS OR IN MY PAY. IF THIS IS
MY LAYOFF NOTICE LET ME KNOW
NOW WHEN THE PEAK FORM THANK
YOU THANK YOU. WELCOME THANK
YOU HI MY NAME IS SHERRY IRAQ
AND I'M FROM TO HIM A COUNTY I
WAS A KID MY CLIENT AS AN H. AS
WORKERS PERMEABLE PERMANENTLY
BLIND SO A MY SERVICES IN MY
HOURS GETTING CUT IS NOT RIGHT
AND ALSO I AM ASKING YOU TO
PERMANENTLY REMOVE THE 7% CUT
THAT WE HAVE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. WELCOME HELLO MY NAME IS
THERESA HEISMAN- FROM LOCAL
TWENTY FIFTEEN I'M FROM FROM
NORMAL COUNTY I AM A RETIREE HE
FROM THE MEDICAL FIELD DR PAN
WHERE MY CONCERN IS THIS SEVEN
PERCENT. CUT CUT DAY WE GOT IT
SHOULDN'T HAVE NEVER CAME ABOUT
IN THE FIRST PLACE BECAUSE
WE'VE GOT SOME CLIENTS SOME
PEOPLE THAT WORKING TO A THREE
CLIENTS JUST TO MAKE ENDS MEET.
ALL THAT 7% WE HAVE A SISTER
THAT JUST TOLD US NOT. BUT A
YEAR AGO THAT HER MOM HAD TO
CUT HER DIABETIC MEDICATION FOR
THEM TO BE ABLE TO LIVE IN THAT
HOME WHICH DAY HAD TO MAKE IS
ME SO THIS 7% SURE COME BACK
QUICKLY US 1100% AS THEY TOOK
IT. AWAY FROM US ONE HUNDRED.
THANK YOU. YOU WELCOME. MY NAME
IS BENITA MINNOWS AND I'M FROM
CINEMA COUNTY AND THIS IS MY
CLIENT THAT I TAKE CARE OF ALSO
MY SON BUT IF HE LOSES HIS 7%
THAT'S A BIG CAT FOR US AND HE
WOULD WIND UP WHERE THE ME
HOMELESS ON THE STREET OR HE
WOULD HAVE TO BE
INSTITUTIONALIZED AND THAT IS
NOT SOMETHING THAT HE WANTS HE
DOESN'T WANT TO BE HOMELESS ON
THE STREET HE WANTS IS 7%
TELLING RESTORED BACK. TO HIM
PERMANENTLY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU. HELLO ON THE.
WELCOME HI MY NAME IS CAROL
TAYLOR AND A RETIREE AT A HOME
CARE WORKER FROM CINNAMON AND-
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR ALL THE
THINGS YOU SAID DR PAN ABOUT
STABLE FUNDING NEEDED IN THAT
WE'RE OR FIRST ON THE CHOPPING
BLOCK AND I'D LIKE O SUGGEST
THAT ONE REASON MORE ON THE
CHOPPING BLOCK IS BECAUSE 72%
ACCORDING TO OUR PAPERS HERE
OUR FAMILY MEMBERS AND I THINK
THERE'S THIS CYNICAL ATTITUDE
THAT THE WORK WILL GET DONE
ANYWAY WHETHER WE PAY THEM OR
NOT. AND I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S GOT TO GET
REFORM BECAUSE PEOPLE HAVE TO
WORK THE- AND IF THE IF IT WILL
MAKE CARE WORKERS AND SECOND
FOR THE W. PCS WORKERS THIS IS
SUCH A LOW HANGING FRUIT CAN
MAKE YOU FEEL GOOD I THOUSAND
PEOPLE OR IT IN THE WHOLE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA TO GET SICK
LEAVE. HOW CAN THAT EVEN BE A
QUESTION YOU GET TO HAVE FUN
YOU GET TO YOU KNOW NO DO YOU.
VERY EASILY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. WELCOME I HELLO ONE ON
SATURDAYS ME NUMBER IS ALSO A
RUCKUS THE ANNALS YOU'LL FIND
YOUR NOTING THIS PARK AND GOT
THE WAY TO PUT THE NEW THAT IT
ON THE SQUARE LAW OKAY SINGLE
SEE BECAUSE ONE OF THESE SMALL
E. THE SUFFERED FROM ELEMENT
THE NORTH. WILL OPEN TWENTY
THAT. THE IS LACKEY ALL YOU.
BROUGHT UP IN THE LIST. NO
POINT THANK YOU THOUGHT MUSCLES
THE POR CIENTO PARK AFFORDABLE
THEY LITERACY PAIN THEN THEY
ASSOCIATE SO GET UP OUTSIDE SO
THE DNA YOU'LL- FORGIVE ME A
CALL. A LIST REPRESENT MARKET
DON'T THINK WAS THE COMMANDER
OF. THE NORMAL POINT OF A CAR
EVEN AT THAT ARE HARD I LIKE
ARE YOU GUYS PRETTY GOOD ALSO
BUT I AND IS A SOLID IT
ACCORDING. BONUS A PHONE SAID
ONE THOUGH AND WE SUPPORT THE
SCHOOL MODERATE COMO WHICH IS
MY THAT IS PROBABLY A LOT AS AN
WAS THIS I MEAN THAT IS FATHER
THIS IS PAUL SUNSET IN MY MOST
YOU GET THE NAME WAS K. A SITE
I. TOLD IMPROVING WHAT THAT OR
US. WHICH IS MY LAST YES. HE
DOES THIS MAKE ANY OPINION.
PROCESS I WANT TO RE MY OPINION.
OF THE IS TO SEE TO IT THAT I'M
TO. CARE OF MY SON. WE HAS A
MANY DESERVE. AND OF. THE 7%
CUT IS AFFECTING. AND HE SAID
TAKING OFF TO THE LIVE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. HE
THIS. WELCOME. MY NAME IS LEE
CAN I'M WITH SENIOR THE SEVEN
THE ACT IN FRANCISCO AND EVERY
YEAR WE COME FOR THIS AMY ST I
WANTED TO BRING IN PAGE HOW
ABOUT CUTTING THE POLICE I'M
SORRY BUT YOU KNOW- IN MANY IN
MANY PLACES WE DON'T REALLY
FEEL THAT SAFE WITH THE POLICE
AND THEY IS TALKING GRAYSON
THEIR BUDGET BUT YEAH IT WILL
NOT INCREASE IN THE BUDGET FOR
THE SOCIAL SERVICES THAT ARE SO
NEEDED- I AGES AS IS A VERY
GREAT PROGRAM YOU KNOW THIS IS
A ONE OF THE BEST PROGRAMS.
THAT ALLOWS PEOPLE SENIORS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES TO BE
PARTICIPANTS IN THE COMMUNITIES
YET WE'VE THINKING ABOUT
CUTTING DOES- OVER YOU KNOW THE
CARD IS STANDING I KNOW THAT
IS. THAT EVERY YEAR IS BEING
PUT BACK BUT- IT SHOULD BE
PERMANENT- GRAY STAR IN A FIT
RIGHT. AND ANOTHER THING AS- WE
THINK ABOUT THE FUTURE. LONG
TERM SUPPORT SERVICES LET'S DO
AS I REALLY- SEER USE- YOU KNOW
MASTER PLANNING ON AGING AND
INCLUDE THAT CELL. PLEASE WE
MADE THAT SOCIAL INSURANCE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WELCOME
TO CHOSE MINSTER MEMBER SENIOR
ACTION OF SAN FRANCISCO TO
NATIONAL ACTIVE AND RETIRED
FEDERAL EMPLOYEES AND A
SUPPORTER OF THE SPARTACIST
LEAGUE WOULD ADVOCATES FOR A
WORKERS GOVERNMENT. UNDER
WORKER'S GOVERNMENT IT WILL BE
A LEGAL THEY'RE NOT PROVIDE
COMFORT CARE AND SUPPORT TO THE
AGED AND DISABLED. THESE PEOPLE
WHO TO PROVIDE SERVICES LIKE
THIS THERE THERE ARE SAVIORS.
TAPE PROVIDING A LIFE AND DEATH
CARE. NOT AS COMPARED TO
ANDROID AND ANY OTHER LUCKY IF
THEY GET MINIMUM WAGE. NOW WE
GOT JEFF PARASITE THAT BEZOS
NET WORTH ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY BILLION DOLLARS. THAT
WORKS OUT TO TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTY NINE DOLLARS PER
SECOND. ANY GETS PAY WISE EATEN
SLEEP IN AND SITTING ON THE
CRAPPER. THEIR BOARDS OUT TO
MORE THAN TWO WEEKS PAY FOR THE
AVERAGE WORKER IN THIS SOCIETY.
THERE'S SOMETHING WRONG WITH
THIS HI. BUT OUR WORKERS
GOVERNMENT I KNOW WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN THERE HUNDRED THIRTY
BILLION DOLLARS THAT WOULD BE
DISTRIBUTED TO THE PEOPLE OF
THIS COUNTRY. WE WERE
EXPROPRIATED WEALTHY HE'S
GREEDY **** AND GIVE IT TO THE
PEOPLE WHO NEED IT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WELCOME HI MY NAME
IS MY WOOD I AM. A AS AT THAT
PROVIDER FROM CENTER COUNTY I'M
TAKING HIM OF MY MOM. I'M COME
HERE TODAY TO TALK ABOUT TIA
PUBLICLY I COME HERE. EVERY
YEAR TO TALK ABOUT THE AREA 7%
CUT BOB SO NOW I DON'T YOU THE
TO. A PERMANENTLY RESTORE.
SEVEN THE FAN AND- I TO SUPPORT
ALL OF THE LONG TERM CARE UNION
TO THE ABOUT THE A- ALL THE
AWFUL REQUEST FROM RUN FROM QUE
UNION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WELCOME MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE
WHITE SEA WENT ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA- I
THINK THE COMMENT THAT YOU MADE
MISTER CHAIR EARLIER- THAT AS A
BUDGET REALLY DOES REFLECT OUR
PRIORITIES AS A STATE- IS IT IS
CRUCIAL RATE- WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THE PERMANENT RESTORATION OF
THE 77% CUTS T<c.cyan> HSS UP</c>
PROVIDERS- YOU KNOW FOR MANY OF
THE CLIENTS THAT THE WEATHER TO
EIGHTEEN OR DISABLED POPULATION
PROVIDERS ARE THE LIFELINE AND
I THINK WE HAVE TO ASK
OURSELVES AS A STATE I DO WE
PRIORITIZE YOU KNOW THE CARE
THAT'S BEING PROVIDED DO WE
PRIORITIZE OUR MOST VULNERABLE.
IN THE STATE AND IF THE ANSWER
IS YES THEN WE SHOULD DO THE
RIGHT THING AND RESTORE THESE
CUTS- DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA'S ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THE EXTENSION OF SICKLY FOR
PROVIDERS CURRENTLY EXCLUDED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WELCOME.
HELLO JOHN CAMPBELL MY CARE
PROVIDER IN SACRAMENTO THANKS
RICHARD YOU ALWAYS BEEN A BIG
ADVOCATE FOR SEPARATE SHEET
THAT I TAKE CARE TO ELDERLY
GUYS ONCE MY BROTHER ANOTHER
FELLA HAD A BRAIN INJURY IN
REALLY WORRY ABOUT HIM MY I'VE
BEEN SPENT A LOT MORE TIME OVER
THERE LIKE FOUR HOURS TO GET
PAID BORDERS I GOT TO DO A LOT
OF WELLNESS CHECKS ON IT IS
GIVEN A DIMENSION GOT A GROUP
OF A ONE O'CLOCK IN THE MORNING
HILL WHO KNOWS WHAT HE'S DOING
BUT I GOT TO GET OVER THERE.
AND OUT A LOT OF PEOPLE FORGET.
YOU KNOW GET A WEEK OFF FOR NOW
ON ME I KNOW. PROBABLY FIFTY
HOME CARE PROVIDERS PERSONALLY
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY. IT'S A
DAY OFF FOR SEVEN DAYS A WEEK.
AND I DON'T KNOW THE LAST TIME
I HAD A VACATION BUT YEAH IT'S
KIND OF A KICK IN THE TEETH
EVERY YEAR. GET RID OF THIS
CRAP I MEAN IT'S GETTING OLD.
IT'S JUST A 7% NEEDS TO BE
SHELVED AND- DEALT WITH YOU.
SHE TO HELP THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS NEARLY MARTINEZ AND I'M
FROM SHASTA COUNTY AND I'M HERE
IN SUPPORT OF MY BROTHERS AND
SISTER PHONE MY UNION SEIU
LOCAL TWENTY FIFTEEN AND ALSO
MY BROTHERS AS IF THE PHONE YOU
DID DIAL YOU UP I TO GET A MY
MOTHER SHE'S TWENTY FOUR HOURS
CARE SINCE LAST YEAR'S SHE
BROKER HE PARALLAX AND NOW IT'S
YOU CAN BOOK SHE LOST HER
BALANCE SHE IS COMPLETELY
DISABLED RIGHT NOW IN A
WHEELCHAIR. SHE'S ALSO ON-
HOSPITAL. SO ARE. CUTTING DOWN
7% IT WILL BE COMPLETELY
PUTTING US DOWN BECAUSE I PAY
FIVE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY DOLLARS
EVERY MONTH FOR ELECTRICAL
BILLS BECAUSE OF THE RENTAL
FLIES EVERYTHING HOURS THAT WE
HAVE TO PAY WE CAN AFFORD IT.
SO I'M HERE TO ASK YOU PLEASE
TO SUPPORT ALL THE LAND LONG
TERM CARE WORKERS ARE ASKING
YOU A LIKE THAT ON THERE ALSO
THE UNEMPLOYMENT RIGHTS. OUR
BROTHER SINCE THE THIRD THAT
THEY GET THEIR HUSBANDS OR
WIVES THEIR CHILDREN STATE THE
CEREBRAL LOAN WORKERS I MEAN
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE. AND
ALSO MY BROTHER SINCE HE'S
DIFFERENT. WBCS THEY ALSO BE
CENTER. TO GET THAT CD BAILEY
IF BECAUSE IF WE DON'T GET IT
WE GET SICK HOW WE CAN AFFORD
IT TO WORK. AND THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
I HOPE I YEARS YOUR SUPPORT IN
THIS. THANK YOU. WELCOME
MESSAGE ARE MEMBERS OF ANY
RIGHT WITH THE CA YOU
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THE
MANDATORY I AGE IS A SOCIAL
WORKER TRAINING PROPOSAL- AS
WELL AS WANTED TO MENTION I'M
RELATED TO THE INCREASE ON THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING ON THE
PENALTY. LASSEN COUNTY STRAIGHT
OUT TOLD US THAT THEY WOULD
RATHER PAY THE PENALTY AND THEY
DID- RATHER THAN SETTLE A
CONTRACT SO IT'S NOT OKAY
SOMETHING NEEDS TO BE DONE WE
HAVE ALSO MADE- THROUGH THE
MASTER PLAN ON AGING A PROPOSAL
FOR STATE RIGHT COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING. AND LOOK FORWARD TO
REVISITING THAT CONVERSATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WELCOME
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ADAM
GREEN I'M FROM PLEASURE COUNTY.
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORDS EARLIER PERCENT OF
IT REALLY MEANT A LOT. ALSO
WANT TO SAY. A LITTLE OLD
FASHION ADAGE THAT YOU PROBABLY
KNOW EVERYBODY'S FAMILIAR WITH.
A MAN WORKS FROM SUN TO SUN.
BUT A WOMAN'S WORK IS NEVER
DONE. THE REASON WHY I SAY THAT
IT'S THE SAME THING WITH OUR
LINE OF WORK OUR LINE OF WORK
IS NEVER DONE. AND IF WE LET
CALIFORNIA START TERRAIN AND
NOT KEEP TO SEVEN PERCENT. IT'S
GOING TO RULING RAIN AND POOR
AND TO US. SO PLEASE WHAT'S
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA. SUNNY AND
LET'S GET 27% THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. WELCOME THANK
YOU MY NAME IS CHARLOTTE LEóN
I'M FROM PLASTER COUNTY- OUR
PROGRAM HAS TO BE TRANSPARENT
AND SO THEY SHOULD BE
TRANSPARENT WITH. THE YOU KNOW
WITH. WITH A COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING TRANSPARENCY THANK
YOU Q. THANK YOU. WELCOME. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M DIANE MCCARTY.
AND PHONE WITH YOU D. W. AND
WOULD LOVE TO SEE THIS RESTORED
7% WE ARE SO TIRED OF COMING
DOWN WITH OUR CLIENTS AND MANY
OF THEM THAT CAN'T EVEN MAKE
THIS. AND THE JUST WOULD LOVE
TO HAVE YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WELCOME AFTERNOON BEVERLY ON
BEHALF ETW ASKED ME LOCAL
THIRTY NINE THIRTY THANK YOU
DOCTOR PAN FOR YOUR STUPID
COMMENTS TODAY AND THE
DISCUSSION. BUT WE WANT TO
REITERATE THAT. THERE'S THIS
COLLECTIVE FRUSTRATION OF THESE
OPEN CONTRACTS THAT JUST HAVE
NOT BEEN ENTAL SETTLED IN
RESPONSE TO THE COUNTY
COMMENTS. THE UNIONS ARE PUSHED
FOR MANY YEARS FOR STATE WHAT
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AND WE
CONTINUE TO DO SO AS PART OF
THE STATE MASTER PLAN. AND IT
WE WELCOME COUNTY SUPPORT
BEHIND THIS PROPOSAL AS WELL.
WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE
HAD TO RESORT TO MANY DIFFERENT
WAYS TO THE COUNTY COMMENTS TO
INCREASE THE STATE MINIMUM WAGE
IN ORDER TO GET OUR PROVIDERS
WISH TO GO UP. AND I THINK WE
ARE JUST NEED TO TAKE A LOOK AT
WHAT ELSE CAN WE DO- IN TERMS
OF PUTTING TOOLS IN OUR TOOL
BOX WHICH IS THE PROPOSES WE
DISCUSSED TODAY RIGHT- ALL THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING RELATED
ASKS THAT WE HAVE. A IT
PERMANENTLY RESTORING THE 7%
AND MAKING SURE THAT THERE'S
THIRTY FOUR W. PCS PROVIDERS
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THESE
PROPOSALS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WELCOME HI MY NAME PLEASES GOD
I'M ON A PROVIDER AT OF
ELDORADO COUNTY FOR NINETEEN
YEARS AND I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF
ET W. I AM ARM IN FAVOR THE 7%
CAT THE FISCAL PENALTY- ONE IS
THE COUNTY SEAT CARSHARING.
REINSTATED SO ALREADY CASELOAD
GROWTH ALLOCATIONS IN NINETEEN
NINETY ONE REALIGNMENT AND ALSO
REQUIRE TRANSPARENCY IN
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING BUT MY
HEART IS REALLY FOR THE 7%
BECAUSE WHEN HIS FIRST WHAT ARE
CAME OUT. I ALMOST LOST THE
CLIENT. SHE SHE WAS OUT HOURS I
DECIDED TO GO BY THERE AND SHE
WAS- PRETTY MUCH COMATOSE IN
THE BATHTUB. COULD I HADN'T
CHECKED HONOR FOR TWENTY FOUR
HOURS AND I KNOW MANY HOURS. SO
THAT THAT IS REALLY WHERE MY
HEART IS YOU REALLY NEED TO
RESTORE THE 7% IT'S NOT SO MUCH
HURT US BUT IT'S HER IN THE
CARE AND THE DIGNITY THAT WE
GIVE TO OUR CLIENTS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WELCOME GOOD EVENING
HOW YOU DOING THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORKTO DO MY NAME IS BOX
IN NINETEEN I. ONLY A TWENTY
FIFTEEN AT TAKE CARE OF MY
MOTHER AND MY BROTHER AB MA'AM
BEEN HERE WHEN I'M FIFTEEN
YEARS WHENEVER WENT OUT A- TWO
WEEKS VACATION BECAUSE I HAVE
TO TAKE THEM WITH ME MY MOTHER
IS LEGALLY BLIND. ALL TERM AS
MY BROTHER HE'S MENTALLY ILL
WITH A MINOR THREE YEARS OUT IF
IT IS SEVEN YEARS PAST SIX
YEARS OUT. AND I'VE BEEN DOING
THIS WORK FOR NOW OVER OF.
TWENTY YEARS FIFTEEN YEARS WITH
A MAN LIVING WITH ME AND I'M
WORKING TO BEFORE I WAS TWENTY
I'M ALWAYS AS WHEN WE DID TO
CUT. I HAD BOTH OF THEM BUT
THEY TOOK ME OFF OF HIM THE
ONLY LATIN BUT MY MOTHER
BECAUSE I COULDN'T TAKE HIM MY
BROTHER BUT I'M ALL WHAT THEY
LIVE WITH ME AND WE ALWAYS IN
THE HOUSE TOGETHER WITH THEM.
AND I'M I'M STANFORD OTHER
WORKERS THAT DON'T GET OF A
SICKLY BUT I DON'T HAVE A
SICKLY I CAN'T TAKE SIX ORTEGA.
LESS I TAKE THEM WITH ME SO
THEREFORE PLEASE PLEASE I BEG
OF YOU ALL THANK YOU FOR ALL
YOU DO FOR US I LOVE YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. WHAT AFTER TO
GIVE SOUL. BUT RIGHT NOW YUBA
HAPPEN PEOPLE THAT YOU'RE
CURRENTLY SERVING THROUGH AYE
HSS YOUR POPULATION IS ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION PLUS THAT'S
TODAY IN ALL OF THESE THINGS
ARE GOING TO BE INCREASING AND%
YOU HAVE LESS THAN HALF OF THE
FORCE RIGHT NOW TO PROVIDE THE
NEEDS MOST OF THEM AND PAID.
THANK YOU. WELCOME HELLO MY
NAME IS REBECCA BUT LONG TO DOG
FIGHT WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
GROUP ANYTHING YOU CAN TO HELP
THE PEOPLE ON THE ON WITH
DISABILITY AND PEOPLE I TAKE
CARE PRO WOULD BE GREAT WHY IS
THAT THE SOCIAL SERVICE
PROGRAMS ARE THE FIRST ONE TO
GET CUT NOTHING ELSE GETS CUT
AS- SENATOR PAN SAYS EARLIER. I
DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT. THANK
YOU WELCOME HELLO MY NAME IS
SHERRIN TO JESSE I AM THE
PROVIDER IN BOTH PLASTER IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY DOCTOR PAN I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICES-
EVERYBODY ON THE PANEL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING AND
GIVING US YOUR EDGY EDUCATION
ON THESE DIFFERENT THINGS-
COUPLE THINGS DEFINITELY DOCTOR
PAN AGREE WITH YOU ON THE 7%
CUT IT'S FRUSTRATING THAT THIS
IS A THING THAT WE HAVE TO KEEP
FIGHTING OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
AND YEAH I AGREE WITH YOU KNOW
BUT NO OTHER SOCIAL SERVICES.
ARE NO OTHER. GROUPS HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT THAT ANY I NEVER
MADE SENSE TO ME WHERE THEY SAY
YOU NEED A HUNDRED HOURS BUT
WE'RE ONLY GOING TO PAY FOR
YOU. PAY NINETY THREE HOURS FOR
YOUR AYE THAT'S I'VE NEVER
UNDERSTOOD THAT BEFORE- ALSO
ARM I'M PART OF THE BARGAINING
TEAM IN PLASTER COUNTY. AND I
CAN'T TELL YOU HOW FRUSTRATING
IT IS. GOING INTO BARGAINING.
AND IT NOT. BEING TRANSPARENT.
AS A DESERT F. AS AN OBSERVER-
SO ANYTHING THAT WE CAN TO. TO
DO THE TRANSPARENCY DON'T WANT
TO PUT ANY MORE BURDENS ON THE
COUNTIES FISCALLY. BECAUSE
THAT'S GOING TO BE PART OF THE-
PART OF THE ISSUES THAT WE HAVE
TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU. RIGHT WELL I
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE WHO I
CAME TO TESTIFY WERE HOLDING
ALL THE ITEMS OPEN AT THIS
POINT IN TIME- SO- I DO JUST
WANTED- TO BE CLEAR THAT- AND I
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S NOT
PROPOSING A CUT AT THIS TIME
FOR THIS COMING YEAR- I KNOW
THAT MANY OF YOU KNOW THIS-
THIS IS- THE REQUEST IS TO MAKE
IT PERMANENT THAT WE DON'T HAVE
A CUTS SO IT'S NOT GONNA HAPPEN
AND HOW YEAR AND CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE VERY MUCH- DOES NOT WANT
THAT TO HAPPEN IF POSSIBLE AND
IS LOOKING AT. YEAH THAT WAS
MORE NUMBERS COME IN TO BUILD
PUSH IT OUT BUT I WOULD ALSO
APPEAL THAT. REALLY TO ME
PHILOSOPHICALLY WE SHOULD JUST.
NOT HAVE IT OUT PLAN FOR IT NOW
YEAR BUT THAT'S A WHOLE NOTHER
THAT'S ANOTHER WILL WILL HAVE
THAT DISCUSSION AGAIN LATER- SO
AGAIN AT PRE SHEET EVERYONE'S
PRESENTATIONS- WHAT. WHAT I'M
GONNA DO NOW IS- JUST- WE'LL
TAKE A FIVE MINUTE STRETCH
BREAK- AND THEN WILL RESUME
WITH- OUR NEXT ITEM WILL BE
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES SS I
SS PEACE AGAIN THANKS SO MUCH
FOR EVERYONE AND- WILL. BE BACK
IN FIVE MINUTES SO STRETCH USE
THE RESTROOM GET UP. AREA
SOUNDS GOOD RIGHT THANKS.
A
GIVE ANOTHER MINUTE AND WILL
RESUME. SO. ANOTHER MINUTE.
I
THINK WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD IN-
RESUME AGAIN SO HOPEFULLY
EVERYONE HAD A CHANCE TO
STRETCH A LITTLE- THANK YOU- SO
WE ARE NOW ON SS I SS P. AND
REAR BEGIN WITH THE- OVERVIEW
BY THE PHARMACEUTICAL SERVICES
SO- I KNOW EVANS KIND OF
INTRODUCE THEMSELVES AGAIN
VIEWS WITH EACH YES GOING TO GO
AROUND IT IS FOR THE AXIS OF
PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELF THE
END FOR THE RECORD. IN JOHNSON
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES THANK YOU. JERRY
THOMPSON CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES IT'LL
PROGRAMS THANK YOU HELLO JACKIE
BRASSIERE ELIA A FINANCE CAKE
PORT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OKAY
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT. LET'S GO
HADN'T BEEN OKAY- YOU ALSO HAVE
A POWER POINT HIM DOWN ON THE
SS I SS P. PROGRAM- TO PROVIDE
YOU SOME OF THE INFORMATION OF
AN OVERVIEW- I'M LOOKING AT THE
SECOND PAGE HERE CASELOAD
YOU'LL SEE THAT THERE IS AN
ONGOING SLIGHT DECLINE IN THE
CASE LOAD OF THIS PROGRAM WHICH
HAS BEEN GOING ON THE LAST.
SEVERAL YEARS THE FOLLOWING
PAGES ADDRESS A FEW OF THE
POTENTIAL REASONS FOR THAT
INCLUDING THE FINANCIAL
STABILITY OF BABY BOOMERS. ON
THE ADVANCES IN MEDICAL
TECHNOLOGY HEALTHIER BEHAVIORS-
ASSET LIMITS SO THAT IT KIND OF
OUTLINES THOSE ARE. REASONS
THAT HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED THAT
RELATE TO THAT DECLINE- THAN
THE FOLLOWING PAGE GOES INTO
THE BUDGET FOR NINETEEN TWENTY
THE ESTIMATED BUDGET WAS NINE
POINT SEVEN BILLION IT'S ABOUT
THE SAME FOR FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. THE ADMINISTRATIVE
PORTION OF THAT IS ABOUT AN
EIGHT HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE-
FOUND MILLION. FOR THE S. P.
ADMINISTRATION THAT THE STATE
AT THAT THE STATE- CONTRACTS
WITH SSA TO PROVIDE. ON WE DO
HAVE MOVED INTO THE MAINTENANCE
OF EFFORT AND THE PAYMENT
STANDARDS THAT ARE OUTLINED
THERE FOR YOU AND THEN ALSO.
GIVE THE COMPARISON AS WE MOVE
FORWARD A COUPLE OF PAGES TO
THE FEDERAL POVERTY GUIDELINES.
AND THEN- THAT LASTS SEVERAL
PAGES PROVIDED THE COLA HISTORY.
FOR YOU THERE HAPPY TO RESPOND
TO ANY SPECIFIC QUESTIONS THAT
YOU'RE- WOULD LIKE MORE
INFORMATION ON. OKAY THANK YOU
A COMMENCEMENT ELIO. REVIEWED
THE ESTIMATES A REASON A MAJOR
CONCERNS- BUT SIMILAR TO I IT
JUST SAYS- SPECIFICALLY ON CASE
THAT WE DID JUST NOTE THAT
LOOKING AT THE MOST RECENT
MONTHLY ACTUAL- CASELOAD
ESTIMATES MAY COME IN HIRING ME
BUT STILL WE WOULD SEE THAT
DECLINE OVERALL BUT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT- WILL BE
MONITORING AND LOOK FOR IT PER
THAT MAYBE UPDATE. THANK YOU
FINANCE. AB SIMILAR YOU KNOW TO
THE DISCUSSION ON I JUST AS
COSTS FROM WILL BE UPDATING-
OUR PROJECTIONS- TO IN THE MAY
REVISION. OKAY THANK YOU. SO IN
TERMS OF THE- SO I GUESS WHEN
THE ISSUES THAT AS NINE OF WILL
BE HEARING A LOT OF THINGS
ABOUT HOUSING BUT- THERE IS
ACTUALLY HEARING THAT WAS
CHAIRED BY SARAH TAUGHT IT WAS
CHAIR OF HUMAN SERVICES- ON-
CARE BOARDING AND- SO IN THAT
HEARING. IT WAS. MENTIONED THAT
IT'S PRESENTED THAT WHILE THE
OVERALL NUMBER OF. GUEST BEDS
AND KAREN BOARDING HAS BEEN THE
SAME. THE THAT ACTUALLY BUT
THERE'S BEEN A DECLINE IN KAREN
BOARDING BEDS FOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE ON SSI BECAUSE BASICALLY
THE LIMITS WERE TOO LOW AND
DOES NOT REALLY FINANCIALLY
SUSTAINABLE- HAS THAT IS THAT
SOMETHING AND TURN OVER WHO
PRESENTED ON THAT AT THAT
HEARING BUT- CAN YOU CAN YOU
SPEAK TO THAT I MEAN WE'RE SO
AS WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS AND-
REALLY A CASE LOADS AND- AND WE
WILL BE HEARING A- QUEST FOR
REGARDING- HELP PAY LATER BUT
TO USE CAN YOU SPEAK TO THE
HOUSING ISSUES RELATED FOR.
PEOPLE OR ON SS I SS P. SURE SO
THE WARDEN CARE OR THE ADULT
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE ELDERLY ARE PART OF THE
CONTINUUM THAT PROVIDES A
SUPPORT TO ACCESS THAT
SOCIETIES P. POPULATION OUT WE
ARE AGAIN AS YOU NOTED OVER
ARCHING WE WERE SEEING A-
ACTUALLY INCREASING CAPACITY OF
THOSE FACILITY TIES BUT FOR
THOSE THAT ARE CARING
SPECIFICALLY FOR SSI ASSIST
PEOPLE POPULATION THERE'S A
GREATER DECLINE- AND SO I'M
HAPPY TO PROVIDE SPECIFICS
NUMBERS IF YOU'RE IF YOU'D LIKE
TO THERE ARE SOME AND I THINK
YOUR AGENDA SPEAKS TO IT A
LITTLE BIT LATER AROUND SOME OF
THAT- THE- WAYS IN WHICH WE
HAVE. ESSENTIALLY A PROXY TO
LOOK AT THE DATA MATCHING
BETWEEN WHO'S WHO'S IN A
RESIDENT IN THOSE FACILITY
TYPES IN WHOSE RECEIVING A
SOCIETY PROXY THAT WERE USING-
BUT I CAN CERTAINLY I'M SURE
WITH THE SPECIFIC DATA AT THE
STATE LEVEL FOR A FEW PEOPLE
LIKE THAT OUR OR LATER ON IN
THE AGENDA BUT CERTAINLY WE ARE
SEEING A DECLINE SPECIFIC TO-
WHEEZING THAT PROXY MEASURE OF
THE NUMBER OF THOSE FACILITY
TYPES AND CASSIE THIS FACILITY
TYPES THAT ARE SERVING THE SS I
SS BE POPULATION. OKAY WELL I
MEAN I THINK YOU KNOW WHAT WAS
WERE TRANSCRIPTS HOMELESSNESS
AND HOUSING- I THINK WE NEED TO
LOOK AT HOW YOU KNOW HOW THE
POPULATION IS ON SSI SSD IS
BEING IMPACTED IN ORDER TO
THINKS THAT WE NEED TO DO. TO
THE GATE DOBBS YEAH WE ARE
OTHER A LOT THE WELL. PROGRAMS
PROPOSALS AROUND HOUSING ALSO
JUST STRUCK THAT. YOU KNOW
WE'RE LOSING CARE CARE BOARDING
HOMES FOR PEOPLE ON SSI ASSIST
P. AND- ALLOWING A DUE TO STUDY
I DON'T. THE CASELOAD IS MAYBE
DROPPING BUT I AND I DON'T
THINK THAT- THAT ACCOUNTS FOR
WHY WE HAVE A TEACHER THAT WE
HAVE A DECREASE IN BEDS RIGHT.
RIGHT SO WE BELIEVE IN
CERTAINLY IN THE S. SURVEYS
THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS
CONDUCTED ON WHY SOME OF THOSE
FACILITIES AT CLOSE THEY HAVE
ACTUALLY IDENTIFIED. AT THIS
RATE AS ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT
THEY ASH STRUGGLED WITH AND
WHICH CHALLENGED WITH PART OF
OUR PROPOSAL AT THIS TIME IS
THE HOUSING- THAT'S ASSIST
HOUSING FUND- WHICH- ONE OF
THREE PURPOSES OF THE FUND IS
SPECIFICALLY TO ADDRESS-
STABILIZING. PICKED THE CARE OF
THIS POPULATION IN THOSE
FACILITY TYPES AND SO AGAIN-
BASED ON THE NEEDS THAT IN ANY
GIVEN REGION. THIS WILL BE ONE
OF THOSE THREE ALLOWABLE USES
OF THE FUN AT TO SUPPORT BOTH.
A POTENTIAL- STABILIZING RENTER
HAVING A RENTAL AGREEMENT
EXCHANGE BUT ALSO FOR. A
POTENTIALLY IN THE-
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE FACILITIES
THAT NEED TO BE DONE TO ENSURE
THAT THE TO HIGH QUALITY THE
AND THEN THE OTHER QUESTION.
UNDER THE OVERVIEW IS YEAH WE
WERE- SUCCESSFULLY ABLE TO-
BASICALLY GET. ALLOW PEOPLE
UNNECESSARY S. P. TO GET ON- A
CAL FRESH RIGHT- AND- SO I JUST
WANT TO CHECK IN IN TERMS OF
THE FOLLOW UP ON THAT AND DOES
SO MANY TOPICS TO READ THEIR
OWN ALSO PERSPECTIVE AS WELL
BUT FROM- SO HAS A HOUSE THAT
IMPLEMENTATION IN ROLLING OUT
I'VE BEEN GOING GOING IT'S
BEEN- PHENOMENAL AND WE ARE
GRATEFUL FOR THE PARTNERSHIP OF
OUR COUNTIES MANY BOOKS
ORGANIZATIONS WE HAD A VERY.
ROBUST ENGAGEMENT ENGAGE
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS THROUGHOUT
THE PLANNING AND IMPLEMENTATION
SO FAR INCLUDING ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES THAT WERE INCLUDED IN
THE BUDGET TO MAKE SURE WE WERE
DOING OUTREACH AT A GREATER
RATE HAS AND SO THAT THAT HAS
BEEN SUCCESSFUL WE HAVE- OVER
WELL OVER THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND- INDIVIDUALS IN THIS
POPULATION AND ROLLED AND THAT
NUMBER CONTINUES TO GROW SO-
AGAIN JUST GRATEFUL FOR THE
PARTNERSHIP ACROSS THE BOARD TO
MAKE THAT A SUCCESSFUL IN AND
IT HAS IT HAS BEEN JUST THAT SO
WILL. NOT DONE THE BEST AT
PHENOMENAL SO THAT WORK I ONE
THINK THAT THE AND CERTAINLY
THE PUT YOUR PARTNER FOR MAKING
THIS HAPPEN I KNOW THAT. MEAN
WE HAD IT DECADES WE DIDN'T DO
IT VERY REASONS- AND THAT WE
WERE ABLE TO COME TO AN
AGREEMENT AND ATTACK LIMIT THIS
AND I THINK THIS SOME THAT
GOING TO FIT. ALMOST HOUSEHOLD
IS A- OF PEOPLE. DECIDE YOU
KNOW WE PUT IN MACINNES TO TRY
TO MANY FRAME WHO MIGHT AND
GIVEN THIS NATURE FORMULA TO BE
SURE WE- TO HELP THEM HARMLESS
AND- SO APPRECIATE THE HARD
WORK OF THE APARTMENT- IN IN
MAKING THAT. HAPPENS OF THANK
YOU. AL RIGHT OTHER QUESTIONS-
AT THE MET. OKAY I CAN'T ASK
YOUR QUESTION FOR YOU I THINK.
THE KNOWLEDGE YOU'RE YOU'RE
YOU'RE HEARING THAT YES THAT WE
HAD ON BOARD CARE SO YES THAT'S
HOW I THINK CENTER HER DAUGHTER
FOR LEADERSHIP AND- HOLDING A
HEARING ENSURING HEARING
ITSELF. OKAY ALRIGHT SO LET'S
GO AND MOVE ON- TO ISSUE TO
WHICH IS MORE SPECIFIC TO
HOUSING HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS
IN THE UPDATE ON THE HOUSING
AND BILLY ACS PROGRAM EACH.
SPOKE INTRODUCE YOURSELF FIRST.
GOOD AFTERNOON TIM WALLACE WITH
THE ACCOUNTING DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS BUREAU SO IN TERMS
OF AGE TAP- JUST A BRIEF UPDATE
SINCE YOUR AGENDA DOES A REALLY
GOOD JOB SORT OF- EXPLAINING
THE PROGRAM AND LAYING OUT SOME
OF THE- DATA THAT IS-
SUMMARIZED IN THE RECENT- AGE
GAP LEGISLATIVE REPORT THAT WE
SUBMITTED. I WOULD JUST NOTE
WITH RESPECT TO THAT REPORT-
SOME OF THE SOME OF THE DATA IS
A LITTLE BIT- DATED- BEING FROM
OUR SORT OF THROUGH JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY NINETEEN SO
WANTED TO PROVIDE SOME UPDATED
DATA POINTS TODAY IF I COULD-
WHICH ARE ACTUALLY THROUGH
DECEMBER TWENTY NINETEEN- SO
REALLY PLEASED TO REPORT THAT
WE NOW HAVE. THIRTY TWO HUNDRED
OF FOLKS AND ROLLED IN H. TAP
WITH ELEVEN HUNDRED OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS IN A PERMANENT
HOUSING SOLUTION EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
HAVING A DISK WOULD SUBMITTED
THEIR BEHALF. AND UNDER OF
THOSE WITH DISABILITY
APPLICATION APPROVAL SO SOME OF
THE GREAT WORK HAPPENING AT THE
LOCAL WITH OUR EACH OUT. SONY'S
IN SERVICE OUR AGE THE
LIMITATION FOR I WOULD JUST ADD
THAT WE HAVE NINE COUNTIES- ARE
CURRENTLY PARTICIPATING- WE
REALLY SOME UPDATED PROGRAM
GUIDANCE- IN EARLY- NOVEMBER
TWENTY NINETEEN- BROUGHT ALL OR
COUNTIES TOGETHER- IN PERSON
HERE IN SACRAMENTO IN LATE
NOVEMBER FOR SORT OF A TWO DAY
LEARNING FORUM- WHERE WE TALKED
ABOUT- BEST PRACTICES AND
LESSONS LEARNED- STEP. WHICH IS
REALLY VALUABLE- AND THEN IN
TERMS OF THE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION THAT WAS APPROPRIATED
VIA THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
A BUDGET ACT- I WOULD JUST ADD
THAT WE HAVE- APPLICATIONS DO
THIS COMING MONDAY AND INTEND
TO TURN THOSE AROUND VERY
QUICKLY AND HAVE IT FUNDS
ALLOCATED LATER. THIS MONTH. SO
THAT'S SORT THE BRIEF H. UPDATE
HAPPY TO HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU HELLO
CURRENT. I WOULD JUST ADD SOME
YOUR LINE OF. AND PRIOR ITEMS
JUST ONE OF MANY SOCIAL
PROGRAMS THAT SPECIFICALLY
TARGET ASSIZES P. INDIVIDUALS-
TO ENSURE THAT THEIR HOUSING
NEEDS ARE MET. OKAY THANK YOU
FINANCE. CURRENT QUESTIONS WITH
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OF ALRIGHT
BUT PRE SHEET- THAT YOU KNOW
WE'RE- THIS PROGRAM OR HEALTH
TRY AGAIN LATER- WILL I BE SURE
WELL WE WANT TO WE CAN TO KEEP
PEOPLE HOUSE THEN TYPICALLY
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES AND SO.
EIGHT THE UPDATE ON THE PROGRAM
AND- LOOK FOR TO ITSELF
CONTINUED THEN FURTHER
IMPLEMENTATION. SO WELL AND-
AGAIN WE WANT TO TRY TO TRACK
WHAT'S HAPPENING TO OUR FOLKS
OR ON SS I SS PAEAN. AND SEE
WHAT WE CAN DO TO SEE WHAT WE
NEED TO DO TO. KEEP THEM-
THOUSAND SAFE AND- TAKE CARE OF
SO. THANK YOU FOR. ALL RIGHT-
ISSUE NUMBER THREE THANK YOU WE
HAVE A PROPOSAL FOR INVESTMENT
AND I THINK WE HAVE THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY YOU
KNOW OF. OKAY COME ON UP. ALL
RIGHT. AND CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS
ALRIGHT OKAY OTHER. WITH AM
SHANTI PER SIDE WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS SPUR THREE SIERRA ROMERO
ACOSTA BE LESS OKAY UP SO I AM
HERE. NO THANK YOU SO THREE
MINUTES SUCH THE- EIGHT. I'M
HERE TO ASK FOR THE INVESTMENT
REALLY THE RESTORATION TO THE
LEGACY CUTS THE SS I SS P.
THAT- HAVE RESULTED IN THE
EXTREME POVERTY OF OVER A
MILLION OF OUR SENIORS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES ACROSS
THE STATE IN EVERY COUNTY IN
CALIFORNIA- NOW AT 88% OF
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL. FOR
SENIORS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES ARE SUFFERING-
IT'S THE ONLY MAJOR PROGRAM
THAT HAS NOT BEEN RESTORED THE
COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT HAS
BEEN DECIMATED DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION- AND YOU KNOW ALL
THOSE FACTS SO I'M JUST GONNA
SHARE ONE OF MY STORIES AND
HAPPEN YES SHARE ONE OF HERS-
WAS BORN IN FRANCE NOW MY
MOTHER WAS RAISED THERE- SHE
HAD YOU. AND SHE WAS THIRTY TWO
SHE HAD- THYROID. BEFORE I WAS
BORN- SHE WAS THE FIRST IN HER
FAMILY AND THE ONLY ONE OUT OF
FOUR CHILDREN- OF FARM WORKER
IMMIGRANT PARENTS TO GET A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE FROM FRESNO
STATE- AND SHE DID THAT ONE TO
THIRTY FIVE- WHEN I WAS THREE
WHICH SINCE SHE HAD THE CANCER
SHE ALWAYS STRUGGLED WITH HER
ENERGY LEVEL AND WITH.
MEDICATION TRIAL AND ERROR AND
WE WERE ALL THE SAME NOT
PROGRAMS WHEN I GROWING UP THAT
WE COULD QUALIFY FOR AND SHE
WORKED PART TIME ON AND OFF BUT
AND SHE GOT SSI. IN HER LATE
FIFTIES AND EARLY SIXTIES- BUT
IN TWO THOUSAND AFTER TRAILER
HOME DOWN. SHE BOUNCED FROM
WELL TO REPTILE AS HER HEALTH
DETERIORATED. IN THE SS I CUTS
THAT HAPPENED DURING THAT TIME-
IN IN THIS YEAR'S LATER DURING
THAT TIME MADE IT A LOT WORSE-
THANKS A- BUT THAT IS A
RESOURCE FULL PERSON AND WAS
ABLE TO. GET HER UP IN THE LINE
TO GET SECTION EIGHT- BUT WHEN
WE HELP HER MOVE HER OUT I WAS
LIVING IN NEW YORK AT THE TIME
IN ABOUT TWO THOUSAND EIGHT.
SHE WAS SITTING IN A ROOM WITH
A FAN SHE DIDN'T KNOW WELL HER
ROOM WAS INFESTED WITH MAGGOTS.
FLEET I THINK PROBABLY THE HER
DETERIORATED HEALTH. WAS NOT.
HER FOR. I'M WHICH- LAST NAME
AND SHE WAS SO ROW NICE WHEN
SHE THE DOOR I WILL NEVER THE
LOOK ON FACE. THAT'LL BE
SOMETHING OVER FOREVER. AND IF
WE TALK ABOUT THE GENERATIONAL
TRAUMA OF POVERTY THAT'S IT
RIGHT THERE. SHE DIDN'T WANT TO
LET ME ENTER HER ROOM BUT I
HEARD ABOUT IT FROM MY AUNT TO
HELP CLEAN IT UP AND THANKFULLY
WE GOT HER INTO SENIOR LIVING
WITH COMMUNITY EVENTS AND ALL
THAT KIND OF NICE STUFF FOR THE
LAST FEW YEARS OF HER LIFE. SHE
PASSED AT THE AGE OF SIXTY NINE
IN TWENTY ELEVEN AFTER SHE
BROKE HER HIP AND SHE DIDN'T DO
WELL AFTER THE SURGERY BECAUSE
OF HER HEART CONDITION WITHOUT
A WORD SHE DIDN'T DO WELL- SHE
RECKONED BEAT BADLY TO.
ANASTASIA AND BECAUSE SHE HAD
US AS A FAMILY AT LEAST TO HELP
HER SO MUCH SHE IS ONE OF THE
LUCKY ONES. SHE'S ONE OF THE
LUCKY. HAVE A LOOK AND I HAVE A
FEELING THAT IF SHE HAD BEEN
BETTER TAKEN CARE OF THE STATE
HELPED HER OUT A LITTLE BIT
MORE SHE WOULD HAVE LIVED A LOT
LONGER PASSED THE AGE OF SIXTY
NINE. PLEASE RESTORE THESE
GRANTS FOR THOSE. STILL HERE.
YOU GOT. SIX SECONDS LEFT. FF
AND THAT'S IT NOT. ENOUGH IT'S
THREE MINUTES. OKAY SO- BUT IF
YOU CAN DO IT VERY QUICKLY SHE-
BRIEFLY. AT THAT DON'T WANT
HELLO MY NAME IS BUT THREE
SETTLEMENT AUGUST FEVERS I AM
NOT ON SSI BUT I HAVE A SISTER
THAT LIVES IN MY HOME THAT. IS
ON SSI. SHE'S BEEN N. SHE
MOVED INTO MY HOME BECAUSE SHE
MOVED FROM CHICO. OVER TO THE
BAY AREA- ON. AND ON. IT HAS
BEEN ON LIST FOR SECTION EIGHT
CANNOT GET INTO SECTION EIGHT.
HOUSING AT THIS POINT. R. CHEAP
ONE AT HIS SIDE AS I STATED.
SHE CANNOT AFFORD SHE HAS TO
LIVE. IN MY HOME TO CARE FOR TO
BE HOMELESS. SHE GETS CAL FIRST
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO GET THE
WHOLE SIXTEEN DOLLARS A MONTH.
OKAY SHE CAN'T LIVE OFF OF
THAT. SONG I'M A RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTING THAT YOU. UP THE-
SSI BENEFITS. YOU DO YOU
COMMENTS FROM FROM OUR SOCIAL
SERVICES AVAIL ALL RIGHT
FINANCE OKAY RIGHT QUESTIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS YES SIR TARA.
FIRST AND FOREMOST THANK YOU TO
THE BILL THREE HER COMING HERE
TODAY AND FOR SHARING YOUR
STORIES. FIVE MYSELF I'M FROM
BORN IN FRESNO I RAISED AND
SINGER BOB WHY STILL LIVE
THERE- AND- YOUR FIRST AND
FOREMOST I'M SORRY TO HEAR
ABOUT THE LOSS OF YOUR BEER
YOUR MOTHER TONGUE SHE SOUNDS
LIKEAN AMAZING AND WONDERFUL-
HUMAN BEING. BUT YOUR STORY IT
YOUR STORIES ARE VERY SIMILAR
RIGHT TO A LOT OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT PEOPLE FACE IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND- IT'S
NOT UNIQUE AND SPECIFIC TO THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IT'S SOMETHING
THAT. WE REALLY NEED TO WORK ON
AN ADDRESS AT THE STATEWIDE
LEVEL- YOU KNOW THINGS LIKE HOW
IN AND FOOD ENTRANCE SHE JUST.
NEEDS PORTABILITY ISSUE HERE-
AND I KNOW THAT THE PEOPLE AT
GREATEST RISK FOR BECOMING
HOMELESS ARE THOSE STACKED.
BECAUSE HOUSING COSTS EXCEED
YOUR 50% OF THEIR HOUSEHOLD
INCOME. OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND BEYOND- YOU
KNOW SPEND UP 290% OF. OF THEIR
SSI ASSISTED S. S. P. GRANTS
FOR SMALL STUDIO APARTMENTS.
I'VE SEEN AND COME ACROSS A LOT
OF FAMILIES AND LOVED ONES
THAT. HAVE THE SAME CHALLENGE.
OZ SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
HOMELESSNESS AND HOMELESSNESS
AND CENTRAL VALLEY BEYOND- I
THINK THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
SHOULD I RESPECTFULLY ASK MY
COLLEAGUES TO THINK ABOUT THE
SS I SS P. AS A PART OF
HOMELESS EFFORTS AT THE CAUCUS
TO. ARE REALLY BEST BECAUSE OUR
BUDGET UP IN OUR BUDGET
SURPLUS- IT'S UNACCEPTABLE THAT
NUMBER ONE GROUP OF PEOPLE
BECOMING HOMELESS ARE.
CONSIDERED THE MOST AFFORDABLE
AND OUR COMMUNITY SO THANK YOU
FOR. I ALSO WANT THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR COMING YEAR AND- AND
PRESENTING AND SHARING YOUR
STORIES WITH US- YOU KNOW I DID
THE KNOWLEDGE THAT THE CURRENT
PROPOSAL MEANS THAT- ACTUALLY
INDIVIDUALS ARE STILL BELOW THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LINE COUPLES
ARE KIND OF. AT THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LINE AND WE KNOW THAT
THE FEDERAL POVERTY LINE IS NOT
BASED ON CALIFORNIA ACOSTA
LIVING IT'S BASED ON ACTUAL
COST LIVING SO. WE KNOW THAT
THINGS ARE MORE EXPENSIVE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA FOR A LOT. OF THE
REASONS THE GOOD BAD BUT-
PEOPLE DOWN- BUT- THAT THAT
MAKES A HUGE CHALLENGEAND
THAT'S WHY ALSO I A AM I
APPRECIATE AGAIN CENTER TAUGHT
US HEARING AND- I UP AND SAYING
OKAY WELL FOR LOSING AB BEDS
FOR PEOPLE WHO NEED. TO YOU
NEED TO CARE BOARDING AND FOR.
DOING IN TERMS OF OTHER TYPES
PROGRAMS TO AND HOW WE TRACK
WHAT'S HAPPENING TO PEOPLE
RIGHT IN. AND DAY OUT FROM THE
MINUTE WE OF COURSE WE DO HAVE
A CHALLENGE WITH HOW MUCH MONEY
THEY GET HOUSE FOR SO- I KNOW
THIS IS. SOMETHING WE LOOK EACH
YEAR SHOP. YOU TO GO TRYING TO
PUT GET. ME SOME JA ACOSTA
LIVING WITH FIGURES FROM WE
NEED TO HAVE THAT. BUT YEAH WE
I SAREK. THAT IT'S OUR OFF
BEHIND AND WE'RE NOT REALLY
CATCHY UP OR KIND OF CREEPING A
LITTLE BUT NOT REALLY CATCHING
UP SO. AGAIN MY THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
AWARE HOLDING EACH ITEM OPEN
FOR EIGHT NOW AND WILL STILL
THIS WEEK WE SEE YOU- IN THE
DISCUSSIONS MOVING FORWARD SO.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
SOMEONE NOW THAT PUBLIC COMMENT
ON. THE SS I ISSUES- SO- PLEASE
INTRODUCE YOURSELF WELCOME.
JEFF TURNER GEAR. OUT WE DIDN'T
HAVE IT AB REVIEW TO SENATORS
UP FOR SIGNING ON TO A ONE
HUNDRED FOUR ONE HUNDRED. BUT
ON TO A BUDGET REQUEST FOR ONE
HUNDRED FOUR ONE HUNDRED.
BOTTOM LINE IS YOUR BUREAU A-
BUDGET IN SAID THAT. OVER EIGHT
HUNDRED DOLLARS PLUS IS
BASICALLY WHAT THE SSI
RECIPIENT. AND BOARD AND CARE
SINGLE FAMILY. SHOULD WE SAY
ROOMS ALL OF THEM COST NO MORE
THAN THAT- SO COST. AND THE
OTHER FACTORS THROUGH HERE AND
EVEN CAL FRESH YOU'VE ONLY GOT
LESS THAN A HALF A MILLION OF
THEM AND THERE'S ONE POINT FIVE
OUT THERE. SO EFFORTS TO
CONTINUE. I DO MY BEST TO
PARTICIPATE AND BRING IT BACK
TO YOU GUYS AGAIN. AND AGAIN.
THANK YOU WELCOME. HELLO KEITH
A MOTORBOAT WITH KARA SENATOR-
I WANT TO SPEAK ON YOUR STATUTE
STATUTES SAYS ON THE SS I S. AS
THE RECIPIENT IS TO A LARGE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR INDEPENDENCE
SO WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT A
HUNDRED PERCENT- OF THE POVERTY
LINE AND WHEN YOU'RE NOT
RESTORING THE CUTS YOU'RE
BASICALLY DOING A REVERSE OF
ENLARGING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
INDEPENDENCE SO IT IS CONTRARY
TO WAY OFF ELFARE IN
INSTITUTIONS CO TWELVE THOUSAND
TWO. IN A INTENT THAT THE
PROGRAM ITSELF THE SECOND THING
I WANNA ALLUDE TO IS WHERE THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD. AND BEING SIDES- WE ARE.
EFFECTIVELY INSURING CERTAIN
PEOPLE LIVE BELOW THE POVERTY
LEVEL AND TO ME THAT IS CAUGHT.
THE DISHEARTENING THAT SUCH A
RICH STATE WOULD LOOK ALLOW ITS
CITIZENS OR RESIDENTS TO LIVE
AT THAT LEVEL OF A WAY OF LIFE
SO ANYWAY- MY FINAL ITEM IS
WHEN YOU NEGOTIATE WITH THE
FULL COMMITTEE AND ASSEMBLY ON
THIS SOMETIMES YOU NEGOTIATE IN
BETTER POSITION WHEN YOU
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF MONEY IN
YOUR BUDGET BECAUSE NOW YOU'RE
AT A DIFFERENT NEGOTIATING
POINT THAN IF YOU JUST ADOPT
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AS THIS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
WELCOME HI NANCY ROBERT WITH
JEWISH FAMILY SERVICE LA- THANK
YOU FOR TAKING UP THIS ISSUE
THANK YOU SENATOR DORADO FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP TO RUSSELL ON
CRIED FOR TADO. IS HE SHE ISN'T
SHE'S MIND SORRY. MY APOLOGIES
OF WE OBVIOUSLY FULLY SUPPORT
THE ADVOCATES PROPOSAL THERE
ARE MILLION CALIFORNIANS LIVING
IN POVERTY BECAUSE OF DECISIONS
WE'VE MADE AS A STATE. AND WE
ARE FACING HOMELESSNESS AND
HUNGER AND AGING AND DOES
ADDITIONAL HEALTH CONSEQUENCES
AND WE CAN MAKE THE INVESTMENT
TO START HELPING THOSE PEOPLE
MOVE. TOWARDS NOT THAT THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL IS ENOUGH
BUT IT'S CERTAINLY BETTER THAN
WHERE WE ARE TODAY AND WE'D
LIKE TO START MAKING THAT
INVESTMENT TODAY SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WELCOME REBEKAH
GONZALEZ NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER WE REPRESENT
APPROXIMATELY TEN THOUSAND
SOCIAL WORKERS WITH THERE
DEGREES THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- THERE ARE SO MANY
HEARTBREAKING STORIES OUT THERE
IN ADDITION TO WHAT YOU'VE
HEARD TODAY AND SOCIAL WORKERS
WORK WITH THIS COMMUNITY-
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL
AND HOPE THIS IS THE YEAR WE
CAN FINALLY GET THIS DONE.
THANK YOU. OKAY LEASE A COMMON
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LONG TERM
CARE OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION AT.
THE OUT OF POCKET- THE OUT OF
HOME MEDICAL NON MEDICAL
REIMBURSEMENT OF A THOUSAND
SIXTY NINE DOLLARS FOR THOSE
RESIDENTS ON SS I SS BE. MEANS
THAT AN ASSISTED LIVING. OWNER
OPERATOR IS OPERATING ON THIRTY
FIVE DOLLARS A DAY. IT IT IT'S
JUST NOT WERE NOT ALLOWING A
GOOD OPERATOR TO PROTECT TO
PROVIDE EVEN THE BEARS QUALITY
OF LIFE CITING CURRY JUST
ABSOLUTELY TO DO THIS PROPOSAL
BUT TO CONSIDER DOING AB A
PATCH ON THE SS P. SO THAT WE
COULD GET. MORE OLDER ADULTS
THAT ARE JUST OVER QUALIFYING
FOR SSI INTO THESE FACILITIES
AND GETTING THEM HIGHER QUALITY
OF LIFE. THANK YOU WELCOME. AS
CHAIR MEMBERS MY CAROL WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY- A FIRST FOUR ONE THANK
SENATOR TARA FOR HER LEADERSHIP
ON THIS ISSUE AND REALLY HOPING
THAT THIS IS THE YEAR THAT THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE AT THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE CAN FIND A WAY TO
ACTUALLY START TO FUND THE
INCREASES I'M TWO THINGS I
WOULD JUST PULL OUT OF THE DATA
THAT THE DEPARTMENT PROVIDED ME
ONE IS THAT SINCE THE CUTS WERE
FIRST ENACTED IN TWO THOUSAND
AND TEN WE'VE ONLY INCREASE THE
S. S. P. GRANT ONCE ONCE IN
THAT ENTIRE TIME PERIOD. AND SO
I THINK WE CAN DO BETTER I
THINK EVEN IF THEY'RE GOING TO
BE SMALL STEPS CONTINUING TO
PROVIDE NO INCREASE JUST MAKES
THE WHOLE BIGGER EVERY YEAR
THAT WE TRY TO DO THIS SO WE
NEED TO START DOING SOMETHING.
AND THE OTHER THING I WOULD
NOTE IS THAT THE DROP IN THE
CASELOAD MEANS THAT OR JUST THE
LAST SIX YEARS WE HAVE A
REDUCED FEE INVESTMENT SAN JUAN
VESTMENTS BY OVER TWO HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
GENERAL FUND EACH YEAR BOSER
DOLLARS COULD HAVE BEEN PLOWED
BACK INTO THE GRANT LEVELS BUT
INSTEAD THEY'VE GONE INTO THE
GENERAL FUND FOR OTHER USES WE
NEED TO STOP THAT WE'RE GONNA
HAVE CASE LOAD REDUCTIONS
BECAUSE OF ATTRITION IN THE
PROGRAM THAT MONEY SHOULD GO
BACK INTO THE GRANT THAT WE
TOOK FROM CLIENTS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU WELCOME.
HEY LOOK YOU CAN LOOK WITH
SENIOR IN THIS LEADING ACTION I
HAVE SOME OF OUR MEMBERS HAMMER
NOT TRANSLATE FOR THEM. BUT I
ALSO WANTED TO SAY THAT- AT YOU
KNOW. EFFECTIVE LEADERSHIP.
WILL BE ABLE TO SEE THE NEEDS.
AND ADDRESS THEM SO I HOPE THAT
YOU ARE ALL EFFECTIVELY
THERE'S- IN THIS CALIFORNIA BIG
STATE. AT LESS HERE FROM HIGH.
THANK YOU. WELCOME NUMBER THERE
AMONG. THEM THE- THE RELATIVE
IN AT THE OF CONTENDERS IS THAT
YOU JUST DO OR NORTH IT DIDN'T
PROVIDE TO PASS SO YEP IN OP
IVY. ACOSTA BREATH THIS IS THE
SENATE VOTE. BUT THE MAKE. AND
HIS NAME IS JOSE AND HE SAID HE
WAS. NINE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
DOLLARS AND HE'S PAYING SIX
HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR A ROOM AND
HE CANNOT REALLY REALLY LONG-
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY AFTER
THAT. THANK YOU WELCOME
RECKLESS SAN FRANCISCO A FEW
YEARS AGO ELLIS'S SIMON WAS
INFLICTING SO YOU'LL KNOW I WAS
A SIMPLER ANSWER MIKAELA WE
FOCAL BUT A ELEMENTAL IN A
MINUTE BUT ANONYMOUS. NAY BUT
LET ME SEE IN THE YES YES
CLASSES AND- SHE'S ALSO FROM
SOMETIME. RECIEVE NINE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY ONE DOLLARS PAY SIX
HUNDRED AND THE LAW AFFORDABLE
HOUSING- I IN YOU SHE CAN I
REALLY ARE FOR SOME OF THE
MEDICATION ENOUGH- SHE SHARE
ONE THING THAT SHE WAS
PRESCRIBED A LITTLE CREAM THAT
WAS NOT COVERED BY MEDI CAL AND
ANNIE WAS HUNDRED AND THIRTY SO
SHE STILL HAVEN'T BOUGHT THAT
FOR HERSELF AND SHE NEEDS.
THANK YOU. OKAY. HI THIS IS
TAMMY ALL. MICROPHONE YEAH.
THIS IS KEN MILNES SHE'S MAD
FEELING COMFORTABLE ABOUT BEGIN
A BIGGER PLAYS BAD SHE IS ALSO
ONE OF OUR MEMBERS HE SHE
RECEIVE SSI AND SHE WAS-
SHARING THAT. SHE DOESN'T GET
ENOUGH YOU KNOW FOR DENTAL WORK
THAT OUT MEDI KYLE ONLY CLOVERS
EXTRACTIONS AND LIGHT THE LAST.
STAFF ME IN ON THAT THEY DON'T
REALLY COVER PREVENTION OUR
OTHER STUFF THAT IS- NEEDED YOU
KNOW SAW. JUST CONSIDER THIS
THANK YOU WE DID INCREASE I
KNOW THAT WAS WHAT MEDIC WE
HAVE WORKED ON THAT I TELL TO
EXPAND COVERAGE SO HOPEFULLY
SHE CAN IT SHE'S ON THAT THE
CAL SHE CAN GET IT NOW CELL
THANK YOU ARE WELCOME BUT MAIN
REPRESENTING CAL PACE IN ORDER
TO QUALIFY AS A PARTICIPANT IN
A PACE PROGRAM YOU HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO SAFELY IN THE COMMUNITY
WHICH INCLUDES PAYING RENT- AND
PROVIDING A BASIC FOOD WE THINK
THAT THE SITE S. S. P. GRANT
SHOULD BE INCREASE SO THE
PEOPLE ARE ARE. ABLE TO DO THAT
SAFELY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON I'M A
VOLUNTEER WITH THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY COMMUNITY FOOD BANK AN
ADVOCATE FOR THE HUNGRY LIKE
YOU ALL I HAVE A ROOF OVER MY
HEAD AND I HAVE FOOD ON MY
TABLE BUT UNLIKE YOU I CAN'T DO
MUCH TO HELP THOSE AROUND SO I
ASK YOU TODAY PLEASE LISTEN TO
THE STORIES YOU'RE HEARING
TODAY THEY'RE NOT MADE UP AND-
MAGNIFIED THOUSANDS OF TIMES ON
THE STREET PLEASE GIVE THESE
PEOPLE WHAT'S NEEDED TO LIVE A
SOMEWHAT NORMAL LIFE WITH AN
INCREASE IN A COLA. THAT'LL
GOES ON PERMANENTLY THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WELCOME I AM NOT A
RUBBER COPELAND I BELONG TO A
SHOCK SECOND HOMES ORGANIZED
THE COMMUNITY WE WENT OVER
LOTION ISSUES EVERY TUESDAY A
LOT OF PEOPLE THERE ARE A
HOMELESS. SOMEWHERE ON THE
FIFTH FIVE CANNELLA IF THE
FLIGHT INCREASE GRANT IS NOT
ENOUGH FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE
PEOPLE LIVING THEIR CARS PEOPLE
ARE STRUGGLING P. THE RANT
BILLS UTILITIES BOOT. WHAT THE
CALPERS BEEN A PROFESSOR GOOD
THING BUT WE MUST DO MORE THANK
YOU THANK YOU WELCOME LOW CHAIR
MEMBERS KATHY MUST FOR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FOOD POLICY
ADVOCATES WE WOULD ECHO ALL OF
THE CONCERNS AND THOUGHTS AND
STORIES THAT ARE SHARED HERE
TODAY WE SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL
OBVIOUSLY AS WE LOOK AT THE
STATE IT HOMELESSNESS IN TRYING
TO SOLVE THAT CRISIS HAVING
FOLKS LIVE BELOW THE POVERTY
LINE- BARELY ADDED. IN THESE
CASES CAN ONLY EXACERBATE THAT
PROBLEM SO WE THINK THEY SHOULD
BE LOOKED AT AS PART OF THE
HOMELESSNESS DISCUSSION AND HOW
TO GET THESE FOLKS- ADDITIONAL
DOLLARS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME HI THERE- MY NAME'S
MICHELLE SIMONS AND I GOT UP
EARLY TO COME HERE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO THIS MORNING. TO
SPEAK WITH YOU- I'VE BEEN ON
SSI FOR ABOUT FOUR YEARS NOW-
I'M OUT ALSO DISABLED I MAKE
KIDNEY DIALYSIS PATIENT. I AND
MY DOCTOR IS URGING ME TO TAKE
DIFFERENT NUTRITIONAL
SUPPLEMENTS THAT AREN'T COVERED
BY MY INSURANCE. WHICH I CAN'T
TAKE BECAUSE THAT BE ABOUT
ANOTHER DISH NOTE HER DOLLARS
PER MONTH- THIS IS A STORY
THAT- MANY PEOPLE SHARE. AND
OFTENTIMES I AM. PUT IN A
SITUATION WHERE IT'S EITHER
MEDICATION OR PUTTING FOOD ON
THE TABLE. AND I LIVE IN SAN
FRANCISCO AGAIN IN ITS THE RENT
IS VERY HIGH HELLO I'M LUCKY
ENOUGH TO HAVE A SUBSIDY TO
HELP ME WITH MY RANTS BUT
OTHERWISE I WOULD BE HOMELESS
ON THE ON THE STREET SO THEM
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WELCOME. THANK YOU DOCTOR
PAN- APPRECIATE- THE COMMENTS
THAT WERE MADE ABOUT THE MORAL
IMPERATIVE TO DO THIS BUT I
KNOW THAT YOU'VE OFTENTIMES
SPOKE ABOUT THE VALUE OF THE
INVESTMENT SOMEONE YOU KNOW
WHERE THEY AT WHERE THEY GO.
AND SO I JUST WANT YOU TO KNOW
THAT WE WORKED WITH UC BERKELEY
AND ACCORDING TO THE IMPLANT
ECONOMIC ANALYSIS EVERY TEN
MILLION IN INCREASE IT'S A
COMMON A PAYMENTS. WITH SUPPORT
FIFTEEN MILLION IN TOTAL
ECONOMIC THAT'S A ONE POINT
FIVE MULTIPLIER CREATES NINETY
THREE JOBS AND RETURNS POINT
NINE MILLION IN STATE AND LOCAL
REVENUES TODAY WE NEED TO HAVE
A SERIOUS DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
FACT. THAT THESE MONIES DON'T
JUST HELP PEOPLE WITH THE ENEMY
CRISES OF THEIR LIVES BUT
ACTUALLY GO TO THE YOU KNOW THE
PLACES IN OUR COMMUNITY WHERE
THAT CIRCULATES AND MAKES
CALIFORNIA STRONGER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND IF YOU EVER. GET
A COPY THE STUDY TO THE
COMMITTEE THAT BE WONDERFUL
THANK YOU. WELCOME TO SENATOR
MY NAME IS THE SOLUTION AND I'M
AN SSH ANY BEER ILLEGALLY. I
LIVE IN A CITY WHERE AVERAGE
STUDIO PRICES OVER THIRTY THREE
THIRTY THREE HUNDRED PEOPLE A
DOLLAR SORRY IN A SERVICE CAN
EVEN PUSHED. UPWARDS OF TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS. IN MY UNIT
AND BURY LEGALLY WE ASSIST
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES MANY
OF WHO EVEN WITH SSI MUST OFTEN
CHOOSE BETWEEN PAYING RENT OR
PURCHASE MEDICINE FOOD OR
SHELTER. IT'S RICK IN
UNCONSCIONABLE. JUST SERVE FOR
SOME GLOBAL PERSPECTIVE IN A
FEW YEARS AGO I HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF SERVING PUBLISHED
IN GROUPS WHICH THEN THE
POOREST TWENTY. UNION LIST
REELING FROM IT A LOT MITCHELL
THIS IS ACROSS PATHS THE BAY IN.
THE DIFFERENT. THE WE LONG WAY
FROM. THE ELDERLY AND DISABLED
GOING SHELTERED HAVE TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN PAYING RENT. OR FEEDING
AND CLOTHING THEIR KIDS. IS A
HUGE MORAL FAVORITE FAILURE ON
OUR PART YOU SAID THAT A
BUDGET. NOT ONLY REFLECTS A SET
OF PRIORITIES I WOULD GO EVEN
FURTHER AND SAY THAT IT IS A
MORAL- IT REFLECTS OUR MORAL.
MORALITY SO INCREASING THAT
SAYS HE- GRANT AND IMMEDIATELY
RESTORING THE COAL IS A- PRETTY
SIMPLE START TO KEEPING THIS
CRISIS FROM GETTING ANY WORSE.
AND ALLOWING PEOPLE TO LIVE
WITH A LITTLE BIT MORE DIGNITY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WELCOME
HELLO MY NAME IS MARTHA ROSE CO
I WORK WITH ALAMEDA COUNTY
COMMUNITY FOOD BANK I AM A
RESEARCH COORDINATOR WHO DOES A
LOT OF THE WORK IN THE
COMMUNITY FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
DIABETES AND DIABETES
PREVENTION A- FACE AND HAVE
SEEN AND SPOKEN TO MANY CLIENTS
WHO ARE DIABETIC AND ARE ON SSI
AND HAVE TO STRUGGLE WITH-
PURCHASING FOOD OR PURCHASING
THEIR MEDICATION AS THE SIZE
NOT ENOUGH SOME PEOPLE ARE
STRUGGLING WITH- KEEPING THEIR
HOUSING AND HAVE HAD TO MOVE IN
WITH RELATIVES TO AFFORD A
PLACE OF LIVING AND NOT BE
HOMELESS PLEASE DO SOMETHING TO
HELP THESE CLIENTS THAT WERE
SERVING EVERY DAY. THANK YOU.
WELCOME. MY NAME IS EDWARD
WILLIAMS AND I'M AN ADVOCATE.
ANNA VOLUNTEER TO FOOD BANK OF
CUT COSTS COUNTING. CALIFORNIA
THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD. AND THAT'S ADELINE
HUNDRED AND NINETEEN SOMETHING
COUNTRIES. AND. I'M HERE ASKING
FOR A MODEST INCREASE IN MY SS
THAT. CHECK EACH MONTH. SO YOU
GET THE MONEY. IT'S THE RIGHT
THING THANK. OKAY THANK YOU
WELCOME. HI MY NAME IS CLARISSA
BROUGHTON AND I'M WITH THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY COMMUNITY FOOD
BANK AND I WORK WITH OUR YOUTH
PROGRAMS AND I REALLY WANT TO
STRESS THAT THE INDIVIDUALS IN
THE SENIORS THAT ARE RECEIVING
SSI ARE MORE OFTEN THAN NOT
ALSO CARING FOR MINOR CHILDREN
SO A LARGE MAJORITY OF THE
PEOPLE I SEE ACCESS OUR FOOD
PANTRY- HAVE UNOFFICIAL
GUARDIANSHIP OF MINERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES SO THEY DON'T
EVEN HAVE THE BENEFITS THEY
WOULD HAVE AS LEGAL GUARDIANS
SO THEY'RE TRYING TO STRESS
THIS LARGE AMOUNT OF MONEY. NOT
ONLY TO CARE FOR THEMSELVES BUT
OFTEN MULTIPLE CHILDREN AND
JUST ON BEHALF OF A CCF BE RE
SUPPORT THESE GRANT INCREASES
K. THANK YOU. WELCOME GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE WHITE SEEM ON
BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHT
SCALLOP FOR ANYA AND WE DO
SUPPORT THE INCREASE IN SSI
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. SEE NO ONE ELSE OF THE
MICROPHONE- I THINK WE'RE- THE
OTHER FOR QUESTIONS ON THIS SO
THANK YOU I WILL MOVE ON TO
THE- PARTIAL SERVICES COMMUNITY
CARE LICENSING. THROUGH MUCH.
COME UP TO THE TABLE AND THEN
WE'LL DO OUR INTRODUCTIONS FOR
THE RECORD. OKAY ONE INTRODUCE
YOURSELF FIRST CONCERN WITH THE
AGENCY. GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR
POUND THIS PAM DICK FOSS DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR COMMUNITY CARE
LICENSING. IN JOHNSON
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES YOU. ANGELA SHORT LA
JEANNIE BELL LA YOU AND IT'S
JUST INCREASED FROM TO FINANCE
ALL RIGHT SO- LET'S THAT WILL
BEGIN WITH THE OVERVIEW OF THE
COMMUNICATOR LICENSING PROGRAM.
THANK YOU. AT THE FASHION THE
TOOL. YES WILL AGREE A STATUE
AND IS THE UPDATE ON THE
INSPECTION YES THANK YOU OKAY
SO- THERE'S A LOT OF REALLY
pOVERVIEW OF THE INSPECTION TOOL
BUT I'LL JUST LET YOU KNOW
THAT- OVER THE PAST YEAR IN
TWENTY NINETEEN WE HAVE
DEVELOPED ALL THE TOOLS FOR ALL
OUR DIFFERENT FACILITY TYPES
AND ALL THREE PROGRAMS- WE
PILOTED ALL THREE PROGRAMS
COMMUNITY THE CAN THE-
CHILDREN'S RESIDENTIAL PROGRAM
THAT THE CHILD CARE PROGRAM IN
THE DON'T SENIOR CARE PROGRAM
THEY WERE ALL PILOTED
SEPARATELY. SO WE'VE BEEN
TAKING THAT DATA AND REFINING
THE TOOL- AND IS SO WE HAVE AN
NOVEMBER OF TWENTY NINETEEN WE
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTED THE SENIOR
KERR TOOL FOR THE RC A FEES
AND- WE PLAN TO IMPLEMENT THE
OTHER TOOLS FOR THE OTHER
FACILITY TYPES THROUGHOUT
TWENTY TWENTY BY THE END BY THE
FALL OF TWENTY TWENTY- SO WHAT
I WOULD LIKE TO SAY IS THAT. SO
FAR THE EARLY FEEDBACK HAS BEEN
VERY. POSITIVE FROM THE
LICENSEES THEY'VE THEY REALLY
FELT LIKE THE TOOLS ARE MORE
THOROUGH AND GIVE THEM A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE
REGULATIONS- AND IT PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WHICH THE
PREVIOUS TOOLS DID NOT. SO WELL
AS WE COLLECT DATA WILL BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE YOU WITH INFORMATION
AS TO WHETHER IT REALLY IS
GIVING US A AT A HOLISTIC VIEW
TO BE ABLE TO. FOCUS ON THERE'S
THOSE AREAS OF. NON COMPLIANCE.
RIGHT HELLO. FINANCE WE
APPRECIATE THE UPDATE ON THE
TOOL NOW. AS WE MOVED FROM
KßT TO- TO THE NEW INSPECTION
TOOLS WERE STILL USED IT'S
STILL BASED ON THE MODEL OF
RATE OF HAVING- SERVE I GUESS
TRIGGER BASICALLY YOU HAVE SOME
INITIAL ELEMENTS IF THOSE TURN
OUT NOT TO GO SO WELL THEN IT
DELVES IN MORE DEEPLY CORRECT
YES RIGHT IT'S A DELL MAIN
FOCUS RIGHT TOOL THAT IS
DIFFERENT THAN THE CAT SO IT'S
BEST PACIFIC LEAD DEVELOPED
OVER THE ARTICLES IN THE
REGULATION SO YOU CAN DO A DEEP
DIVE FOR THE- NON. WELL I GUESS
WHEN THE MY QUESTIONS I HAD-
THOUGHTS WAS IS THAT- CERTAINLY
IS CO BOTH WHEN YOU DID KITTEN
AND NOW WITH THIS NEW TOOL- AND
I KNOW YOU COLLECTED DATA TO
LOOK AT WHICH PARTICULAR
QUESTIONS WOULD BEST REFLECT
THAT THE MAIN RATE. SO THAT
YOU'D SAID OF DOING EVERYTHING
YOU COULD DO- BUT- I WOULD
IMAGINE THAT FIRST OF ALL OVER
TIME THERE MAY BE SOME
EVOLUTION OF THE TOOL- AND ALSO
US- I THINK THAT. IN TERMS OF
CONTINUOUS EVALUATION OF THE
HOW AFFECTED THE TOOL IS AND I
APPRECIATE TRYING TO MINIMIZE
THE BURDEN ON HERE INSPECTING-
THAT IT WAS THERE ANY THOUGHT
OR ARE PLANNED TO. MAYBE TAKE A
SAMPLE OF THE PLACES BACK TO DO
MORE COPPER TO THE SECTION TWO
IS A WAY TO EVALUATE THE FACT
THIS IS A TOOL ARE TOP. IS THAT
INITIAL THE MAIN QUESTION IN
BEING SURE THAT IT. ACTUALLY OR
FLEX- A BROADER SAID ISSUES
RIGHT SO. THE PAGEANT. WELL
FULLER INSPECTION A SUB HER
EIGHT A SAMPLE AND YOU GO AS IT
HAS YOU KNOW WHAT WE HAVE
PICKED IT UP GIVEN HEALTH WE-
BUT USING THE TOOL AS IT IS WE
HAVE PICKED UP THE THINGS THAT
NOW WE PICKED UP BECAUSE WE DID
THIS FULLER INSPECTION- NOT
JUST ON THE ONE TWO. OBVIOUSLY
HAD A PROBLEM BUT ALSO IN SOME
THAT. THE INITIAL TOLD OKAY
EVERYTHING'S OKAY BUT TURNS OUT
WE DO FULL INSPECTION IT'S NOT
SO OKAY RIGHT DID SO THAT WE
HAVE A MEASURE OF HOW AFFECT.
HOW ACCURATE THAT DENNIS YOU'LL
I THINK IN TERMS OF JUST US IN
A SERVE AN ONGOING ASSESSMENT
TOOL OR YOU TAKE A SAMPLE AND
YOU SAY OKAY YOU KNOW WHAT
WE'RE COMING AND WE HAD TO
FULLER INSPECTION. SO THAT WE
CAN ACTUALLY SEE HOW HOW
ACCURATE ARE TOOL ACTUALLY IS
IN TERMS OF THE IN TERMS OF
INVESTIGATING THAT THE MAIDS IS
THAT SOMETHING THAT- THAT-
DEPARTMENT SAID. IT IS LOOKING
INTO A CONSIDERING. THAT AND
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
CONSIDERING BUT I WILL TELL YOU
THAT ALL OF THE PILOTS WERE A
COMPREHENSIVE TOOL THAT WE
DEVELOP THE STANDARD TOOL OUT
OF SO IF. IF WE HAD CERTAIN
VIOLATIONS AND IN SPECIFIC
AREAS IT TYPICALLY. WOULD HAVE
VIOLATIONS IN ANOTHER DOMAIN
AND SO WE WERE ABLE TO. PAIR
THAT UP AS THEY'RE DOING THEIR
INSPECTIONS IF THEY HAD A
VIOLATION THIS DOMAIN THAT WE
WOULD ALSO GO TO THE OTHER
DOMAIN SO BUT THERE IS-
CONSIDERATION FOR US TO
CONTINUALLY. EVALUATE THE DATA
TO SEE IF. THOSE FACILITIES
THAT WE'VE DONE TO SPOT CHECK
INTO COMPREHENSIVE. OKAY I MEAN
BECAUSE THERE IS CERTAINLY NO
YOU'VE COLLECTED THAT DATA FOR
ESTABLISHING THE TOOL ITSELF
SIGNED AND DATED DOES EXIST I'M
JUST SIR THANK YOUNG ONGOING
BASIS. AND TERMS OF. COULD USE
A VALUATION KNOWING THAT THE
TOOL ITSELF ALSO PERHAPS OF ALL
RIGHT AS WE LEARN MORE. AS
WELL. THAT IS THE PLAN OKAY ALL
RIGHT. OKAY SO. AND I THINK
THAT'S ABOUT IT OKAY WELL AND
IT SAYS THAT- ALWAYS
INTERESTING HEARING FROM PEOPLE
ABOUT THEIR FEEDBACK BUT GLAD
TO HEAR THAT- FROM WHAT YOU'VE
HEARD FROM THE CLIENTS IS THAT
THIS THE SOULS WORKING OUT
PRETTY WELL RIGHT WELL SO FAR I
MEAN THERE ARE SOME ISSUES WITH
THE LENGTH OF HOW LONG IT TAKES
BECAUSE IT'S EXTENDED THE TIME
FOR THE TOOL BUT FOR THE MOST
PART THERE PLEASE BECAUSE
THERE'S OPPORTUNITIES TO GO
OVER THE REGULATIONS AND
PROVIDE MORE ASSISTANCE. SO WE
SURVEYED ALL OF THE LICENSEES
AND DURING THE PILOT SO WE
COULD GET THEIR FEEDBACK AS
WELL AS WELL AS OUR L. P. A.'S
AND UTILIZE THAT TO MODIFY THE
TOOL OKAY. ALL RIGHT EXCELLENT.
OKAY SO LET'S MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT ISSUE WHICH IS- ON THE
ADULT RECREATIONAL RESIDENTIAL
FACILITIES AND RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES FOR THE ELDERLY.
OKAY IN THE FIRST QUESTION HOW
WITH THE DEPARTMENT GO ABOUT
FIGURING OUT HOW MANY SSI SS
HE RESIDENTS RESIDE IN THESE
FACILITIES- WE'VE BEEN WE'VE
BEEN STRUGGLING WITHOUT WE ARE
NOW WE NOW COLLECT INFORMATION
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES WHICH WE MATCH
WITH OUR ADDRESSES OF OUR
LICENSE FACILITIES. BUT IT
DOESN'T REALLY GIVE YOU A
COMPLETE PICTURE BECAUSE A LOT
OF THE TAX ARE DELIVERED TO
FAMILIES OR- SOME PEOPLE DON'T
EVEN CHANGE THEIR THEIR ADDRESS
AND WHEN THEY THEY MOVE SO. WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY MORE IN THE
CURRENT PROCESS OF DEVELOPING
A- OUTWARD FACING PORTAL IN OUR
CRIMINAL BACKGROUND CHECK
PROGRAM. AND IT'S ALLOWING THE
PROVIDERS TO ACTUALLY- BE ABLE
TO. A POINT THAT THEY HAVE TO
IDENTIFY WHERE THEIR STAFF ARE
GOING AND SO THEY CAN
ASSOCIATION DISASSOCIATE
THROUGH THIS PORTAL SO WORK IN
A FOR CONSIDERING USING THAT
UTILIZING THAT PORTAL TO
ACTUALLY ALLOW THEM TO
ACTUALLY- ENTER INFORMATION AND
WHETHER THEY HAVE SSI CLIENTS
WILL HAVE A TRUE COUNT
ACCOUNTING OF THAT AND ALSO
OTHER ISSUES SUCH AS HOW MANY
DEMENTIA RESIDENTS ARE CARING
FOR MENTAL HEALTH OR-
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SO THERE AND
THERE'S A GOOD OPPORTUNITY FOR
US TO- EXPLORE THAT OPTION WE
EXPECT THAT PORTAL TO BE
COMPLETED BY- THIS FALL. WE
WOULD WE WOULD NEED LEGISLATION
THOUGH TO. MANDATE THIS FOR THE
REPORTING OF ALL FACILITIES.
AND WE LOOK AT IT IT'S A
PROPOSAL FOR TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE IN THAT REGARDS- MORE
FOR FIRST LOOKING AT WERE
TALKING WITH THE CONTRACTOR TO
SEE IF THIS IS EVEN A
POSSIBILITY WE THINK AND IT'S
LOOKING PROMISING BUT YOU KNOW
ONCE WE HAVE THAT INFORMATION
THEN WE'RE GONNA. WILL LOOK AT
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE. GEN THE
ADMINISTRATION TIMES ARE JUST
RESPOND FINDS THAT WE DON'T
HAVE A PROPOSAL OR TRAILER
BECAUSE OF RIGHT NOW RELATED TO
THAT CASE. AT THIS TIME OKAY
ALL RIGHT BUT I GUESS THAT
SOMEWHERE POTENTIALLY
INVESTIGATING THIS OKAY. AND
THEN THE SECOND QUESTION HOW
MANY OF THESE FACILITIES OF
CLOSED IN RECENT YEARS WHAT
AFFECTS HAVE THOSE CLOSEST HAD
ON CAPACITY OVER THE LAST THREE
YEARS APPROXIMATELY TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED FACILITIES HAVE CLOSED-
AND WE'VE LICENSE APPROXIMATELY
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED. IT'S SO THE
CAPACITY INCREASED BY FOUR
POINT 8% AND FROM THE DATA THAT
WE HAVE ON SSI IT LOOKS LIKE
THE SSI CAPACITY DECREASED BY
TWO POINT 6% OKAY. IN THE ANY
IDEAS TO THE REASON FOR THE DAY
WELL THE WAIT WE HAVE- MINIMAL
INFORMATION WE SURVEYED THE
FACILITIES THAT CLOSED IN THE
LAST YEAR AND ASKING THEM
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS ON ON
REASONS FOR AND IT WAS. MORE
LOW REIMBURSEMENT RATE SOME.
AND THE GENERAL YOU KNOW THE
JUST THE GENERALLY HIGH
OPERATING COSTS WERE WERE
FACTORS TO WEAR THE SAME. THEY
CLOSED BUT IT'S ABOUT WASN'T
ALL OF THEM THERE WERE SOME FOR
NON COMPLIANCE. BUT DEFINITELY
THE LOW REIMBURSEMENT RATES
WERE- WERE MENTIONED OKAY.
JOINT JUST WANTED AGAIN
EMPHASIZE THAT WE ARE
ABSOLUTELY- COMMITTED TO
LOOKING AT THESE FACILITY TYPES
AS PART OF A CONTINUUM ICE WHEN
IT RE RE EMPHASIZE THAT AGAIN
AND THAT'S AGAIN WHY- ONE OF
THE USES OF THE PROPOSED SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT IS SPECIFIC TO
STABILIZING THESE FACILITIES
TYPE SO WE ABSOLUTELY RECOGNIZE
THAT CHALLENGE IN THAT IS PART
OF THE SOLUTION THAT WE'RE
PROPOSING AT THIS TIME. OKAY
AND I KNOW WILL BE DELVING INTO
THE SEVEN FIFTY MILLION AND IN
THE FUTURE HEARING. BUT IN
TERMS OF. SERVICES WITH A SEVEN
FIFTY MILLION BUT- HOW YOU KNOW
HOW MUCH OF THE SEVEN FIFTY
MILLION DO YOU THINK YOU'LL
NEED TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE WE
ARE CURRENTLY PROPOSING TO
EARMARK AT THE DOLLARS- WITHIN
THAT SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
FOR ANY OF THE SPECIFIC AT
THREE PURPOSES THAT THE FUNDS
WE WILL LEAVE THAT TO REGIONAL
ADMINISTRATORS TO PROPOSE TO
ASK BASED ON THEIR NEEDS
ASSESSMENTS SO IT WILL VARY
ACROSS. REGIONS IN THE STATE-
LATELY FURTHER THIS WAY WAY UP
THOSE INTO SPECIFICALLY
ALLOCATE AND THAT MAY BE
DECIDED AT A MORE LOCAL LEVEL
BY THE REGIONAL MINISTERS
WHATEVER MECHANISM IN OF
DEVELOPING. THEN I GUESS THE
QUESTIONS AND THEN AS THE
BUSINESS AND THEY'RE A COME
ENTIRELY OTHER CENTER FIFTY
MILLION BUT HOW MUCH MONEY
WOULD WE NEED THAT AND TO.
ADDRESS THIS VERY ISSUE ABOUT.
TRYING TO STABILIZE SO I MEAN I
WOULD DOUBT SO THEY MAY NOT ALL
COME OUT THAT'S A HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION BUT I'M JUST TRYING TO
GET A SENSE OF SCALE OF AND
WHETHER DEBT THAT'S THE
DECISIONS CAN BE MADE BY HER
MACES DECISIONS ON THE SEVEN
FIFTY MILLION. IS STILL UP I
GUESS IS STILL UP IN THE AIR
TO. BUT I'D TO STOP DISTRACTING
LIKE SKILL WISE HOW MUCH MONEY
IF WE IF IT WAS SO DECIDED WITH
ARE WE TALKING ABOUT TO ADDRESS
THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE. THE
FINANCE I DON'T SEE THEM. WITH
THE WITH DEMONSTRATION DOESN'T
REALLY HAVE A PROPOSAL ON ANY
OF THAT RIGHT NOW TO THE EXTENT
THAT THAT'S GOING TO BE THAT
WOULD BE A CONSIDERATION THAT
WOULD SOMETHING THAT WE WOULD-
PROBABLY PROPOSAL CONSIDER AND
THE MASTER ENTERS A
CONVERSATIONS GOING ON BUT
RIGHT NOW UNFORTUNATELY WE
DON'T HAVE AN ESTIMATE ON THAT
DATE ALL RIGHT SO I MEAN I'M
SO. I HEARD YOU SAID YOU HAVE A
PROPOSAL NOT ACTUALLY ASKING
FOR PROPOSAL BUT I THINK AND
NUMBER FOR US TO FIGURE OUT.
YOU KNOW THE SCALE RATE. HAVING
SOME IDEA OF OKAY YOU KNOW WHAT
THE DECISIONS MADE OR NOT BUT
HOW MUCH MONEY ARE WE TALKING
ABOUT TO JUST ADDRESS THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE BECAUSE WE CAN
THERE'S A WHOLE BUNCH OF THINGS
WE CAN THROW INTO THE COURT
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION BUT
IT TURNS OUT WE HAVE. BY THE
WAY WE DO THIS ALL TIME BUDGET
RIGHT WE HAVE LET'S SAY TWO
BILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF DEMAND
FOR THINGS THAT ALSO IS THE
FALL THAT SAME POCKET THEN WE
HAVE TO HAVE A WHOLE NOTHER
CONVERSATION ABOUT THAT SO I'M
JUST TRYING TO GET SINCE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THIS ISSUE
GETTING A SENSE OF. WHAT THE
SCALE OF YEAH I WAS A WOULD
ADDRESS IN THE SENATE FIFTY
MILLION WHILE NOT THAT YOU'VE
SUPPOSEDLY ALLOCATING IT I
HEARD YOU SAY THAT BUT- SO
ROUGHLY HOW MUCH MONEY HE- IS
THIS. GOING TO. IT WILL WE NEED
IF WE WERE REALLY ADDRESS THAT
AT EARLIER DID YOU HAVE SOME.
COMMENTS ON THAT GINNY FELLOW
AT THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. I THINK IT'S A GOOD
QUESTION I THINK IT REALLY
COMES DOWN TO HOW YOU WANT TO
APPROACH IT TOO AND I THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL NOW
IS OPEN TO SORT OF A
COMBINATION OF BOTH- HELPING TO
STABILIZE THE FACILITY'S. FROM
LIKE AN INFRASTRUCTURE
PERSPECTIVE- VERSES KIND OF
THIS WITH THIS PIECE ABOUT KIND
OF THE RATE AND HOW TO
STABILIZE IT VIA SORT OF SOME
SORT OF SUBSIDY. SUBSIDIZATION
OF THE RATE. SETTING THOSE ARE.
THE STRIKING A BALANCE THERE
SORT OF IS THAT. PART OF THE
QUESTION IF IT'S MORE A AND
THOSE ALSO- INVOLVE MAKING
DECISIONS ABOUT ONE TIME VERSES
ONGOING COSTS AS WELL SO. WE'D
BE HAPPY TO PROVIDE ANY KIND OF
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. ON TO YOU
OR TO STAFF AS YOU START TO
THINK ABOUT HOW TO HOW YOU'D
WANT TO FRAME THAT QUESTION
BUT- THOSE ARE IMPORTANT. KEY
QUESTIONS I THINK TO ADDRESS
FIRST. BUT I THINK IT WOULD
ESPECIALLY AS WE'RE GETTING
CLOSER TO ACTUALLY TALKING
ABOUT THE- QUOTE SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION ADDING WE HAVE TO
START. GETTING A SENSE OF HOW
MUCH. EACH PIECE. THAT WE NOW
SAY OH IT'S GOING TO BE
ADDRESSED BY THAT. PART OF
MONEY IT'S UNDER FIFTY MILLION
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AND-
SOMETIMES IT MAY NOT BE AN
EXACT NUMBER MAY BE YOU KNOW A
BIT OF A SENSITIVITY ANALYSIS
AND- AND- YOU KNOW HOW THE
ACTUAL DECISIONS BE MADE JUST
GIVE ME ANOTHER DISCUSSION
WE'RE HAVING RIGHT BECAUSE HE
SAID WELL WE'LL GET THE ABOUT
THE REGIONAL MINISTERS DECIDING
ON THE LOCAL LEVEL WHETHER TO
GO TO SPEND THE MONEY ON THAT.
GOT EIGHT HEARD THAT WE WILL
HAVE A WHOLE NOTHER DISCUSSION
WHEN I GOT LIVE. TO DISCUSS THE
PRESENT BECAUSE OF VARIOUS WAYS
OF MAKING DECISIONS HERE RIGHT
NOW THAT'S FOR THE FUTURE
HEARING BUT- I THINK IS WORTH.
AS WE ROLL THROUGH HEARINGS WE
HAVE HERE AND YOU KNOW WE'RE
HEARING ITEMS LIKE THIS ONE AND
THE ANSWERS WELL WE'RE GOING TO
TRY TO ADDRESS THE
STABILIZATION. THROUGH THAT
OTHER PART OF MONEY. I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO GETA SENSE
OF SCALE OF OKAY. FINE THEN. IF
WE WERE ACTUALLY GOING TO
ADDRESS IT IN THAT POT HOW
MUCH. ROUGHLY HOW MUCH MONEY
ARE WE TALKING AND EAT AND I
SAY HI. ROUGHLY HOW MUCH MONEY.
THANK YOU FOR TALKING. TENS OF
MILLIONS OF A HUNDRED BILLION
TEN MILLION A MILLION YOU KNOW
WHAT. WHAT WHAT IS THE SCALE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT RIGHT SO
WITH THE SWORD THE BOUNDARIES
OF THAT AND I WAS. IN THE
DECISIONS MAY BE MADE EXACTLY.
WHERE WE ARE IN THAT RANGE THE
WHAT IS SORT OF THE- RANGE OF
MONIES THAT WOULD BE TALKING
ABOUT TO. TO ADDRESS THE GAPS
YOU KNOW THE STABILIZE OVER HOW
MUCH RENTAL ASSISTANCE ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT THAT WOULD KEEP
PEOPLE FROM BEING THROWN OUT OF
THEIR HOUSES ETCETERA FOR THIS.
PARTICULAR POPULATION IN THIS
GROUP SO THAT'S WHY I'M TRYING
TO. GET MY ARMS AROUND
UNDERSTOOD IN TE IN IN JUST TO
THE- TO THE QUESTIONS THAT
WE'VE HEARD EARLIER RELATED TO
PROJECTIONS I THINK THAT. THE
COMPLICATING FACTOR IN COMING
UP WITH THOSE PROJECTIONS IS
THAT THIS SECOND. I'M AND WE
CAN'T QUITE PREDICT. WHO'S
GOING TO SELECT IDENTIFY WHICH
CARE SAID. AND WHAT'S MORE. THE
MOST APPROPRIATE. IT'S BEING
ABLE TO STAY WITHIN THEIR AND
THEIR- MATCH. PROVIDER CAN.
WHETHER IT THIS AT. THE IS PART
OF THIS SINCE I THINK THAT'S
BEEN. THE MOST CALM. FACTOR
WHEN WE THINKING A- WHICH- IS.
WHAT BE THE- AT PLACE. IN
SETTING FOR ANY GIVEN AND-
JEWEL. OKAY I MEAN I GET THAT.
DOWN THERE THERE MAY BE
ALTERNATIVE SO THEY WON'T MISS
A STAY IN THIS BUT AT LEAST.
FOR THIS. ANY AND- THIS IS. IN
TERMS OF THE OF THIS SUMMER SO
IS THAT OKAY GIVEN THE CAR
POPULATION THAT THERE IN THE
SITUATION ASSUMING THEY MAY
MOVE TO SOMETHING ELSE AND THEY
WORK OUT BETTER OR SOMETHING
BUT JUST EVEN THE CURRENT
POPULATION ASSUMING THE STATE'S
BUT HOW MUCH MONEY WOULD WE
NEED FOR THEM TO QUOTE STATE
BUT NOW WE MAY PROVIDE A BETTER
ALTERNATIVE AND THEY WON'T SAY
BUT WE DON'T NEED THAT MUCH
MONEY IT'S AT- BUT I DID GET
AND IT'S JUST. JUST THE WAY TO
GET A HANDLE OF. ON THE END WE
HAVE TO DECIDE IS YEAH WE- IS
THE SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
THE RIGHT NUMBER RIGHT IN THE
END ALSO RIGHT AS WE GO BACK
AND FORTH I APPRECIATE. YOU
KNOW. BE KIND OF LIKE THINK
THAT NUMBER BASED ON VARIOUS
FACTORS IT CETERA. BUT I THINK
THIS IS A SORT OF A CHECK ON.
IS A HUNDRED TO BE IT. WE NEED
FOR MORE OR LESS USUALLY IT'S
MORE THAN LAST BUT YOU KNOW
THAT SO JUST AS WELL AS EVERY
EVERY TIME WE HAVE A
CONVERSATION WE SAY OH YEAH WE
ADDRESS IT THROUGH THAT PART OF
MY THE- STATE OKAY- HOW MUCH
MORE MONEY TO. WE NEED FOR THAT
POT. OF REALLY ADDRESS IT THAT
WAY. SO IF THERE'S A WAY TO GET
BACK WITH SOME SORT OF.
ESTIMATE RANGE OR SOMETHING ON
THAT SCALE THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL- JUST SO THAT WE GET A
SENSE OF HOW THIS IS ALL
STARTING TO ADD UP. IN THE END
SO. YES I KNOW YOU HAVE TO MAKE
A FEW ASSUMPTIONS THERE BUT
IT'S SERVICE. ESTIMATE OKAY.
RIGHT. YES THEY DO OKAY SO THE
THIRD QUESTION JUST DESCRIBE
THE PROCESS THAT OCCURS WHEN
THE FACILITY IS CLOSING ON THE
ROLE OF C. C. L. IN THE PROCESS
OF THE ADULT RESIDENTIAL
FACILITIES THAT- HOUSE CLIENTS
UP TO THE AGE OF FIFTY NINE
THEIR REQUIRED TO NOTIFY THE
DEPARTMENT WITHIN SIXTY DAYS OF
A SALE OF THE PROPERTY OR
CHANGE OF OWNERSHIP. THE RC A
FEES GREATER THAN SEVEN BEDS
ARE REQUIRED TO SUBMIT A
CLOSURE PLAN TO THE DEPARTMENT
WHICH WE NEED TO APPROVED ONCE
THAT CLOSURE PLAN IS APPROVED
THEY HAVE. SIX THEY CAN HAVE TO
GIVE A SIXTY DAY NOTICE TO ALL
THE RESIDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES- THERE ALSO REQUIRED
TO. PROVIDE FACILITIES WITHIN A
FIFTY MILE RADIUS TO THE
RESIDENT AND THEIR FAMILIES-
AND THE LATE WE THEY ARE
REQUIRED TO GIVE THE NUMBER THE
NAME AND PHONE NUMBER OF THE
OMBUDSMAN. AND THAT THE ROLE OF
CCL WE ASSIST WE PULL AND ALL
SORTS OF PEOPLE PET PUBLIC
GUARDIANS- APS- WHOEVER WE NEED
TO UP TO BE ABLE TO ASSIST IN
RELOCATING THE RESIDENTS WE
PLAYED HI AN ACTIVE ROLE WE
CHECK ON THEM AFTER THEIR
RELOCATED AFTER A- WEEK OR TWO
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEIR
ACCLIMATED. IN THE FACILITY.
MANY COME SELL EL CANCEL SHORT
LA OF- AS HAS BEEN MENTIONED IN
LIGHT OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S
HOMELESSNESS PROPOSALS THERE'S
BEEN INCREASED FOCUS ON
BOARDING CARE FACILITIES OR
MORE SPECIFICALLY THE SICEL
LICENSE NOT RESIDENTIAL
FACILITIES AND RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES FOR THE ELDERLY. WE
WERE JUST HIGHLIGHT THAT THERE
ARE SOME DATA LIMITATIONS WHICH
REALLY MAKE IT DIFFICULT TO
FULLY UNDERSTAND WHO THESE
FACILITIES SERVE AND THE
SEVERITY OF THE CLOSURE
PROBLEM- SOME QUESTIONS THAT WE
HAVE OUR- AS AS WAS MENTIONED
IT'S DIFFICULT TO DETERMINE HOW
MANY AS A SIZE AS P. RESIDENTS
ARE IN THESE FACILITIES BUT
ALSO RESIDENTS YOU MAY RECEIVE
OTHER TYPES PUBLIC ASSISTANCE
AND- HOW HAVE CLOSURES IMPACTED
THESE LOWER INCOME MORE
VULNERABLE RESIDENTS IN
PARTICULAR. AND THEN FINALLY
WHO MAY NOT BE ABLE TO ACCESS
THESE FACILITIES AT ALL- EITHER
TO COST OR TO LACK OF SUPPLY A
MORE FOR SOME OTHER REASON SO-
WE'RE CONTINUING TO WORK WITH
THE DEPARTMENT AND WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THESE QUESTIONS. SHE
THE- IN THE COMMENTS OKAY ALL
RIGHT WELL- YOU KNOW EXCEPT THE
IT'S- FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET THE
DATA TOGETHER AND KNOW THAT- TO
CERTAIN DEGREE IT'S CHALLENGING
RIGHT YOU KNOW ITS- THEN WE
ALSO PEOPLE DON'T LOS NOW WE
WILL HAVE A LOT OF QUESTIONS
AND NOW YES RESIDENTIAL
FACILITIES WHO ARE NOW ASK
QUESTIONS OF PEOPLE MAY NOT
NECESSARILY WANT TO ANSWER ALL
OF THEM BECAUSE IT CETERA BUT I
MEAN I THINK WE NEED TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET A BETTER
HANDLE ON. ON THIS AND- NOW
WITH WITH THE GUILT DOLE. BUT
CHALLENGED BY- NESSA'S IRATE
THAT DOESN'T ALLOW PEOPLE TO
PAY IT NOW THAT THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY THEY HAVE TO PAY FOR
FACILITIES IS- AND THAT'S WHAT
THAT'S WHAT I HEARD ABOUT THE
DECREASING NUMBER AT THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE THAT'S THE
PAYMENT RATES PEOPLE CAN'T DATE
THEY HAVE A CEILING WHAT THEY
COULD AFFORD TO PAY AND THAT'S
NOT ENOUGH FRIGHTENED SO
THAT'S- GREEN CHALLENGES FOR
OPERATORS BECAUSE THEY CAN'T.
THAT'S NOT ENOUGH FOR THEM TO
OPERATE EIGHT AND THEN- AND
THEN SO WHAT CAN WE TRY TO DO
TO DO THAT HOW DO YOU DO THAT
YOU KNOW MORE TARGETED TYPE
THING WORDS I THINK WE'LL TALK
ABOUT SOME FIFTY MILLION WITH
ONLY GET TO THAT. AND ALSO JUST
THE YOU KNOW LIKE WHAT THE WHAT
WAS THE SCOPE- TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO DEFINE THE SCOPE OF
THE- OF THE OF THE PROBLEM. IN
ADDITION. TO DOING NAY. TO AT
LEAST GET ENOUGH THAT. PICTURE
SO WE KNOW WHAT. KIND OF SCALE
OF INTERVENTION WE NEED TO. TO
ENGAGE IN. SO APPRECIATE THAT
SO I LOOK FOR TO OUR ONGOING
CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS I'M
SURE THIS WILL COME BACK UP
AGAIN WHEN WE TALK ABOUT. THE
LARGER POT LATER ON SO. THANK
YOU. I DO WANT TO ADD THAT WE
HAVE EMPHASIZED THE PREVENTION
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE BECAUSE OF
ALL THE MEDICAL CARE ISSUES
THAT ARE HAPPENING IN THESE
FACILITIES THAT THEY'RE JUST
THEY'RE NOT EQUIPPED TO
UNDERSTAND THEY'RE NOT
CLINICIANS AND SO WE'VE REALLY
FOCUSED ON THAT AND HOPE TO
ATTEMPTED. TO REDUCE THESE
CLOSURES. ARMS SO YOU KNOW
WE'LL BE TRACKING THAT MORE WE
JUST STARTED CHANGING OUR
MISSION YOU KNOW TWO YEARS AGO
SO. APPRECIATE THAT YOU HAVE A
SOCIAL SIDE OF SOCIAL SERVICES
AS TREMENDOUS RESPONSIBILITIES
FOR PEOPLE TO. I KNOW YOU'RE
WORKING HARD ON THAT OKAY- SO
WE MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
THREE THE BCP A CARE GIVER
BACKGROUND CHECKS SO THIS
PROPOSAL PURPLE PROPOSES ARE IS
REQUESTING SIX ANALYST
POSITIONS STAFF SERVICES SALES
AND ONE MANAGER. WE HAD A
TREMENDOUS BACKLOG IT WAS
IDENTIFIED IN AN AUDIT A FEW
YEARS AGO SO WE LOOKED
INTERNALLY TO SEE HOW WE COULD
PROVIDE EFFICIENCY SO WE
ACTUALLY- JUST PUT WE HIRED
TEMP POSITIONS IN THE BLANKET
AND CREATED A UNIT THAT WE
FOUND TREMENDOUS- EFFICIENCIES
AND THAT WE PRIOR IT USED ARTS
SIMPLIFIED INVENTION AND-
EXEMPTIONS YOU TO TAKE TWO
HUNDRED DAYS WE GOT IT DOWN TO
SEVEN. SO THE SIMPLIFIED AND
INSPECT SOME SINS WERE
INTERSPERSED WITH THE X. INTO
THE- THE JERK. CRIMINAL
EXEMPTIONS AND SO THEY WOULD
JUST IN WE PULLED ALL THEM OUT
AND THEY WE HAVE A STE CREATORS
SEPARATE UNITS WERE ASKING FOR
THOSE POSITIONS NOW TO BE
PERMANENTLY ESTABLISHED. ALL
RIGHT. HELLO AFTER REVIEWING
THE PROPOSAL WE DON'T HAVE ANY
CONCERNS FINANCE. OKAY ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU SO. APPRECIATE
THE SUCCESS IN FRONT SAID TWO
HUNDRED SEVEN DAYS THE GOOD JOB.
FULL EMPLOYED FASTER AND YES IN
A WIN WIN THAT'S EXCELLENT
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT HOUSE WITH
ON ISSUE NUMBER FOR THE
RECIPIENT QUALITY OVERSIGHT
STAFFING RESOURCES. SO THIS
PROPOSAL IS REQUESTING THREE
POSITIONS TO EIGHTY P. A.'S
THAT TRAVEL OUT OF STATE TO DO
THE OUT OF STATE GROUP HOME
INSPECTIONS AND CERTIFY THE
GROUP HOMES HONEST AS WELL AS
ONE AS A SAM ONE- WE CURRENTLY
HAVE TWO A. G. P. A.'S THAT
TRAVEL OUT OF STATE WE WEREN'T
ABLE TO DO ALL OF THE CODE AND
THE COMPLAINT INVESTIGATIONS ON
SITE- AND SO WE BELIEVE TO AND
TWO EXTRA POSITIONS WILL GIVE
US THE ABILITY TO. CREATE ALL
THE CERTIFICATIONS COMING UP AS
WELL AS AS THE COMPLAINT
INVESTIGATIONS. AND THEN I'M-
OKAY. JOINT GO AHEAD INTO THE
REMAINING QUESTION YEAH- SORRY
THAT YOU HAD A QUESTION I DON'T
KNOW THAT'S OKAY WHAT YOU TO GO
ANSWER ALL FOUR OF THEM AND
THEN ON HOW MANY OUT OF STATE
FACILITIES HAVE ONGOING
CERTIFICATION THEY DON'T
THERE'S NO TEMPORARY
CERTIFICATION THEY APPLY FOR
CERTIFICATION WE GO OUT THERE
AND THEY EITHER GET IT OR THEY
DON'T SO WE HAVE CURRENTLY WE
HAVE TWENTY SIX CERTIFIED
FACILITIES- IN ELEVEN STATES.
AND WHAT IS THE CURRENT RATIO
OF FACILITIES. HER INSPECTOR
WITH THE TWO WE HAVE NOW IT'S
THIRTEEN IT FLUCTUATES A GOES
UP AND IT GOES DOWN BUT BUT
MINIMALLY- IT'S TYPICALLY TAKES
THEM FIVE DAYS TO COMPLETE. AN
INSPECTION WHAT WITH THE TRAVEL
IN THE RIGHT UP- SO IT'S- WE
BELIEVE THE TWO POSITIONS WILL
REALLY ALLOW US TO. DO ALL OF
THE COMPLAINING BASS OCCASIONS
ON SITE. NUMBER FOR THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE INCLUDED IN
TWENTY NINETEEN BETTER THAT
REQUIRED ALL OF THE STATE
FACILITIES TO BE CERTIFIED AS
AS T. R. TWO PIECE BY TWENTY
TWENTY WILL THE DEPARTMENT BE
ABLE TO MEET THIS GOAL WITH
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES. AND DID
THAT THE DEPARTMENT FOR SEE THE
NEED FOR ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
LAST YEAR WHEN THE TRAILER BILL
WAS. DISCUSSED. WELL AT THE
TIME WE THOUGHT IT WAS
PREMATURE TO ASK FOR MORE
POSITIONS AND THOUGHT WE COULD
WE COULD SOAR BUT- THE MORE
CLOTHES- BUT AS TIME HAS GONE
ON AS AS I SPOKE EARLIER WHEN
WE THINK THAT TWO ADDITIONAL
POSITIONS WILL. ALLOW US TO
MEET THIS GOAL. HELLO COMMENTS
REVIEW THE PROPOSAL TO HAVE ANY
MAJOR CONCERNS AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU FINANCE. RIGHT AND
TAKE A GUEST WHEN THE WELL. SO
I DID HAVE A QUESTION IN TERMS
OF. SO WELL I GUESS THE MORE
FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION AND TRY IT
SAYS THAT SO. WHY WHY DO WE
HAVE OUT OF STATE. THE HOMES
THE FIRST IS. THEY'RE TYPICALLY
BECAUSE THEY HAVE- BEHAVIORAL
ISSUES THAT WE CANNOT WE DON'T
HAVE FACILITIES TO SUPPORT IN
SOME INSTANCES- THIRTIES THEY
HAVE GANG RELATED HE WANT TO
GET HIM OUT OF THE AREA THE SEA
SICK KIDS YOU WANT TO GET THEM
AWAY FROM. THERE THE TRAFFIC
TRAFFICKERS THE- CHILDREN THE-
THEY HAVE AGGRESSIVE BEHAVIOR-
CRIMINAL HISTORY THERE THERE
USED DAY AND THEY ARE ALL-
COURT APPOINTED TO GO OUT OF
STATE IT'S NOT LIKE A
DETERMINATION OKAY SO JUST TO
CLARIFY. CALIFORNIA BIG STATE
BUT NIGHT SO THESE HIGH SO IT
SOUNDS LIKE THERE'S MAYBE TWO
TYPES OF POPULATION ONE IS
SOMEONE WHO NEEDS A HIGHLY
SPECIALIZED SITE IS THAT THERE
ARE YOU SAYING IN TERMS OF THE
ANNUAL BEHAVIOR VIOLENCE IN AND
YOU HAVE ANOTHER GROUP WELL I
DID NOT SAY THAT INVITE THE
OVERLAP THERE. THE OTHER GROUP
TO JUST BECAUSE GEOGRAPHICALLY
NEED TO. KEEP THEM OUT OF THE
STATE BECAUSE OF. RELATIONSHIPS
OR OTHER TYPES OF ENGAGEMENT
THAT. TO KEEP THEM SAFE STATE
PROBABLY THERE'LL BE DANGEROUS
FOR THEM ARE ARE CHALLENGING
FOR THEM TO BE ANYWHERE WITHIN
THE STATE IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING THAT'S RIGHT YES OKAY.
ALL RIGHT AND WHAT TO WHAT
DEGREE WHERE WHAT PERCENTAGE OF
THEM ARE BY RICHARD ARE ONES
THAT NEEDS LIKE HIGHLY
SPECIALIZED SERVICES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE IN THE STATE WILL
HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU ON THE
WE HAVE. ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND-
I'M NOT SURE THE EXACT NUMBER
BUT OVER ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY CHILDREN OUT OF STATE
RIGHT NOW I'LL HAVE TO GET BACK
TO YOU ON HOW MANY. IN THAT.
OKAY ALL RIGHT OKAY ALL RIGHT
SO WE'LL I THINK THAT AND I
THINK WE MIGHT STILL HAVE AN
UPDATE DEL IN THE SALON WINE
SEARCHERS AS TO WHY DEL
CALIFORNIA PRETTY BIG STATES SO
IS LIKE BARRY WHITE WHITE WITH
A NEED TO BE OUT OF STATE
THAT'S ONLY THAT THAT'S A VERY
HELPFUL ANSWER NOW OKAY. ALL
RIGHT. OKAY ALL RIGHT SO LET'S
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER FIVE
WHICH THE B. C. P. ON CONTINUED
OVERSIGHT PSYCHOTROPIC
MEDICATION IN FOSTER CARE OKAY
SO THIS- THIS PROPOSAL IS
ASKING TO MAKE EIGHT LIMITED
TERM POSITIONS PERMANENT THAT
WE CURRENTLY HAVE ON STAFF-
SENATE BILL FORTY FOUR.
MANDATED THAT WE HAD TO DO AN
INCREASE REVIEW AND OVERSIGHT
OF THOSE FACILITIES THAT HAD A
HIGH USE OF PSYCHOTROPIC DOT
DRUGS FOR CHILDREN AND SO- WE
COME BACK EVERY TWO YEARS AND
ASK FOR- CONTINUED FUNDING AND
SO WE KNOW IT'S AN ONGOING
WORKLOAD SO WE'RE JUST ASKING
TO MAKE THESE POSITIONS
PERMANENT. OKAY THANK YOU HELLO
ON. ONE OF ANY CONCERNS WITH
THIS PROPOSAL OKAY FINANCE.
OKAY ALL RIGHT THAT SEEMS TO
MAKE SENSE OKAY THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT- SO- THAT WOULD SAID TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENTS ON THE ISSUES
RELATED TO THIS. CERVANTES
SERVICES- INCREASE YOUR
LICENSING SO WELCOME THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON LISA COLEMAN
WITH CALIFORNIA LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION WE- WERE
ABSOLUTELY IN SUPPORT OF THE
INCREASE FUNDING FOR THE
QUALITY OVERSIGHT FOR THE
BACKGROUND CHECKS GETTING-
THOSE STAFF BACK OUT INTO THE
FACILITIES APPROVED. IS A GREAT
PRIME PRIMARY IMPORTANCE TO US
I WANTED TO POINT OUT JUST A
CLARIFICATION I THINK WE KIND
OF DO SOME LANGUAGE ING ISSUE
UNDER THE SS I SS P. WE TALK
ABOUT THE FACILITIES THAT
ACCEPT THE SS I SS P. THAT'S
NOT AN OPTION IF A PERSON IS
LIVING IN A FACILITY AND
BECOMES ELIGIBLE. THEY GET TO
STAY IT'S NOT ABOUT THE
FACILITY ACCEPTING THEM SO I
JUST CAUTION IS ABOUT THAT
TERMINOLOGY. AND WHEN YOU'RE
LOOKING AT YOUR BACK OF THE
NAPKIN KIND OF HOW DO WE LOOK
AT THIS ALL OF 70% OF OR SS I
SS P. RECIPIENTS ARE ADULTS
THAT ARE DISABLED AS OPPOSED TO
THE 30% WE CAN DO THE MATH AND
SAID 70% OF GONNA GET ALL
BURKE. AND THEN THAT'S GONNA BE
THIS BIG PROBLEM IS BECAUSE WE
DO HAVE FEWER- FACILITIES THAT
WE CAN MOVE A PERSON IN WHOSE
ALREADY QUALIFIED FOR THE SS I
SS P. SO I WOULD REMIND THE
COMMENT I MADE BEFORE WE NEED
TO BE LOOKING AT PATCHES. WE'RE
NOT GOING TO CHANGE THE FABRIC
FEDERAL POVERTY LAMENT BUT WE
CAN PATCH OVER TO ALLOW THE
ADMINISTRATORS OF THESE
FACILITIES TO GET A REASONABLE.
DAILY RATE. OKAY THANK YOU.
WELCOME MISTER CHAIRMAN
RECTANGLE REPRESENTING SIX BEDS
IS AN ASSOCIATION OF SMALL SIX
BEDS ARE FEWER FAMILY TYPE
SETTINGS RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES FOR THE ELDERLY AND
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED WE
HAVE WE SHOULD HAVE A SHARED
MUTUAL SET OF GOALS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT YOU'D CONSIDER THEM
TRUSTED PARTNERS AND YOU KNOW
WE REALLY WANT TO FIND YOU
AFFORDABLE SAFE APPROPRIATE
HOUSING AND THEY HAVE BEEN
CHAMPIONS IN THAT AREA WE FULLY
SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL. THANK
YOU. WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON
TIRE IN THE WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION WANTED TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
CONVERSATION AROUND BOARDING
CARES- SO WE WILL BE BRINGING A
PROPOSAL BEFORE THE COMMITTEE-
DURING WHEN YOU HAVE THE
HEARING ON THE SEVEN AND FIFTY
MILLION. WE BELIEVE THAT THE
NEED IS HIGHER IT'S BAD NOW I'M
AND WE'RE BRINGING A PROPOSAL
FOR FIVE HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLARS TO SHORE UP BOARDING
CARE FACILITIES- WE BELIEVE
THAT THE SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS TODAY DOESN'T
PROVIDE AN ASSURANCE THAT. WE
WILL SEE THE BOARDING CARE
FACILITIES THAT WE ARE LOSING
WE DO UNDERSTAND THERE'S DATA
LIMITATIONS BUT WHAT THE DATA
THAT WE DO HAVE TO DAYS SAYS
THAT. IN THE LAST THREE YEARS
FORTY FIVE FACILITIES AND OVER
TWELVE HUNDRED BEDS HAVE CLOSED
IN LA COUNTY THAT PROVIDE-
SERVICES YOU INDIVIDUALS ON
SSI. BUT HAVE THIS YEAR IS NOT
ALONE IN THAT IS CREATING AN
ADVERSE CONSEQUENCES IN OUR
ABILITY TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS. SOME OF THESE
FACILITIES ARE HOMELESSNESS
PREVENTION IT'S ALSO IMPACT IN
ON OUR CONTINUUM OF CARE
BECAUSE THEY ALSO SERVE AS A
STEP DOWN FACILITY. AND THAT IS
A LEADING TO WE HAVE MORE
INDIVIDUALS AND HOSPITALS THAT
WE CANNOT DOWN LEADING TO MORE
INDIVIDUALS AND EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS. GET IN. CREATING A
SYSTEMIC ONE. AND THAT'S THE
DATA FROM LA COUNTY BUT IT IS A
MORE OF A STATEWIDE ISSUE SO
WHILE THERE ARE DATA
LIMITATIONS WE DO KNOW THAT.
THE NEED AS MUCH HIGHER THAN-
YOU KNOW THE SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION SIZED AT THREE
DIFFERENT WAYS SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME REBEKAH
GONZALEZ NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER I WANNA SUPPORT ON THE
REQUEST FOR FUNDS FOR THE
CRIMINAL BACKGROUND CHECKS
CRIMINAL BACKGROUNDS EXEMPTION
PROCESS- THAT THE REASON WE'RE
INTERESTED IN IS SOME SOCIAL
WORKERS THAT COME FROM
COMMUNITIES OF POVERTY AND THEY
TO HAVE- AT BACKGROUND BUT
THEY'RE READY AND WILLING TO
WORK AT THIS MOST OFTEN COMES
UP IN OUR INTERNSHIP PROGRAM
WHEN THEY'RE TRYING TO GET AN
INTERNSHIP AND THEY WANT TO
WORK IN ONE OF THESE FIX THESE
IT IS JUST TAKING TOO LOOK. FOR
THEM TO BE ABLE TO START AND
CAP BECAUSE PASTAS TAKES A LONG
TIME. CAN WE- SAY TURN. FOR
HOLDEN. WAIT TO SIMPLIFY THE
AND GET MORE AND WELL HOPEFULLY
EVENTUALLY. OUR MAIN GOAL WITH
THAT BILL WAS TO GET MORE
PEOPLE INTO THE SIMPLIFIED
EXEMPTION PROCESS BUT IT IS A
PROBLEM AND I AM GLAD THAT-
YOU'RE PAYING ATTENTION TO IT
THANK YOU. THANK ALL RIGHT SEE
ALSO THE MICROPHONE WITH SOME
MOVE ON TO ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES. RIGHT. DO THE
INTRODUCTIONS AROUND THE TABLE
HERE FOR MENTAL. AFTERA THREE
YEP AGAIN TRIED. REMOVE THE.
CAN I GET THEIR. CAN JOHNSON
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES HE DEBBIE JOHNSON
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES PROGRAMS IF. KIM
RUTLEDGE A DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES LIAISON THANK YOU EL
ACCURACY- ELIA FINANCE GAMELY
WITH FINANCE EXCELLENT ALL
RIGHT SO WE'LL GO HEAD START
WITH THE- REVIEW THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELL WE'VE PROVIDED
YOU WITH- SOME BASIC DATA ON
THE PROGRAM I DON'T KNOW HOW IN
DEPTH YOU WANT US TO GO ON THE
OVERVIEW- SO I LIKE IT'S JUST
THE HIGHLIGHT- THEIR
PROJECTIONS FOR THE COMING YEAR
RIGHT THAT'S- WHAT I FIGURED SO
WILL HOLD GO RIGHT TO THAT- SO
WE ARE SEEING A STUDY-
INCREASE. IN CASELOAD- WHICH IS
CONSISTENT WITH- ARE STEADY
GROWTH AND THE AGING AND
DISABILITY POPULATION- THIS
PAST YEAR WE HAD OVER TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND APS REPORTS
STATE WHY- AND THAT CONTINUES
TO GROW AT A STEADY CLIP- ALSO
EXPANDED. IS CAN YOU GROW AS
YOU KNOW THIS IS A COUNTY
REALIGNED PROGRAM- AND OUR
EXPENDITURES GREW UP TO CLOSE
TO TWO MILLION IN THE PAST- I.
WHAT THE CHURCH PRIDE. AND THE
TWO OF K. THAT WERE IN A ALL
CAN TO GROW THE TYPES OF CASES
THAT ARE GROWING THE MOST
QUICKLY AT THIS POINT OUR
FINANCIAL ABUSE- WE'RE SEEING
FINANCIAL ABUSE INCREASING-
JUST FROM LAST FISCAL YEAR TO
THIS FISCAL YEAR BY A LITTLE
OVER 10% OR ALL WHO- SEEING THE
LARGEST NUMBER OF CASES THAT WE
STILL HAVE IN THE PROGRAM-
OURSELF NEGLECT CASES AS WELL.
AT THIS POINT TO- WE HAVE
SEVERAL INITIATIVES GOING ON AT
THE STATE LEVEL THAT WE ARE
WORKING WITH THE COUNTIES TO
ADDRESS- THIS ONGOING GROWTH-
WE RECEIVED A- GRANT FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND TWENTY
SIXTEEN. TO INCREASE OUR DATA
COLLECTION EFFORTS- THIRD NOT
BEEN ANY CONSISTENT DATA
COLLECTION FROM COUNTY TO
COUNTY ON THE PROGRAM UP UNTIL
WE RECEIVE- THE FUNDING TO WORK
ON THAT CONSISTENCY- SO IN THE
PAST FISCAL YEAR WE OF
INTRODUCED A TOOL. THAT ALL
COUNTIES ARE NOW USING- AS OF
SEPTEMBER TWENTY NINETEEN WE
DID HAVE. A CASELOAD DATA
INCLUDING DEMOGRAPHIC DATA AT
AGE RACE ETHNICITY L. G. B. T.
STATUS- FOR ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES- WE'RE CONTINUING TO
WORK OUT I'M A FEW LITTLE BUGS
WITH OUR DATA COLLECTION SYSTEM
THAT- WE'RE MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND WERE STILL
WORKING WE'RE ALSO DOING OUR-
DUE DILIGENCE NOW TO REPORT
THAT DATA TO ON THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- THAT NATIONAL APS.
DATA COLLECTION- DATABASE- WE
ALSO HAVE ANOTHER GRANT FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT RIGHT
NOW WE'RE WORKING ON- THE APS
SOCIAL WORKER TRAINING- WE ARE
HAVING DOING TWO DIFFERENT
PIECES OF THAT THE FIRST ONE IS
WE HAVE A PILOT PROGRAM. FOR
NOT WORKLOAD STUDENTS WHO ARE I
AM INTERESTED IN WORKING IN
ADULT SERVICES THIS IS SIMILAR
TO THE PROGRAM THAT IS AND
AROUND FOR AWHILE FOR MANY
YEARS NOW SEWER CURRENTLY
FUNDING MS. EDUCATION FOR AND
SO IT WORKS ALL IN THE BAY AREA
THEIR COMPLETING THEIR FIRST
YEAR RIGHT NOW AND- ONCE THEIR
EDUCATION IS FUNDED THEY WILL
SPEND TWO YEARS WORKING AS A PS
SOCIAL WORKERS. IN EXCHANGE FOR
A FOR THEIR TUITION COVERAGE-
THE OTHER PIECE OF THE THAT
ENHANCE GRANT IS A SPECIAL
LEADERS INSTITUTE THE WE HAVE
ENACTED FOR- MANAGERS AT APS
SOCIAL WORK PROGRAMS- WE ARE
DOING MONTHLY DEEP DIVES ON A
VARIETY OF. KIND OF HOT TOPICS
AROUND APS- AND THAT'S GOING ON
FOR ANOTHER TWO YEARS AS WELL.
WE ALSO ARE WORKING I'M PRETTY
CLOSELY WITH- DEPARTMENT OF
AGING ON THE MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING- JUST YESTERDAY WE
PRESENTED- WITH OUR PARTNERS
FROM- CDA ALL AND- NEW ABUSE
NEGLECT AND EXPLOITATION. AND
WE'RE CONTINUING TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM AND
LOOKING CLOSELY AT THE
STAKEHOLDER PROPOSALS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THIS
PARTICULAR TOPIC. THANK YOU
COMMENTS MILIEU FINANCE. A HOW
HOW THE F. THE FEDERAL
MINISTRATION COMMUNITY LIVING
GRANTS IS THAT FOR THE DAY THIS
ONE IS THE DATE WHEN IS THE
DATA AND THE OTHER IS THE RIGHT
IT ENCOMPASSES BOTH THAT OF W.
AND THE LEADERS AND SO THE
DATABASE GRANT IS THAT A ONE
TIMERS AND I WHAT'S WHAT'S THE
TIME PERIOD FOR THAT GRANT. DO
YOU KNOW. SO THAT THAT GRANT
FUNDING HAS COMPLETED OKAY SO
THAT THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
ENHANCE OKAY DATA THAT WE HAD
BEEN COLLECTING FOR A PS AND
NOW WE ARE GETTING STARTING TO
GET MORE DEMOGRAPHIC
INFORMATION THAT WE OKAY YOU
SLEEP IN A DOES A ONE TIME
GRANT TO ENHANCE AND THEN SO
BASICALLY DO WHATEVER UPGRADES
OR- NEW COMPLETELY RE LOOK AT
THE TO ALL THAT RIGHT THE
COUNTY IS USED FOR THE DATA
COLLECTION OKAY OUR REPORTING
ALL OF THAT BACK TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT OKAY AS WELL AS
USING IT FOR OUR OWN PURPOSES
OF THE GRANT ITSELF IS
ESSENTIALLY CONCLUDED RIGHT TO
DO THAT OKAY I JUST. CLARIFY
AND THEN THE TRAINING GRANT IS
THAT I'M GOING THREE YEAR BUT A
THREE YEAR GRANT OKAY SO WE'RE
TRADING LAWYER AND THE STUDIES
WERE DOING A TRAINING ACADEMY
YOU SEE THESE THINGS-
CONTINUING BEYOND THE TIME OF
THE GRANTS OR- WE HAVE. AN ON.
A ACADEMY I. THE PARTICULAR.
AROUND THIS GRANT TO OUR-
MANAGER SPECIFIC SPECIAL
TRAININGS- WERE ALWAYS LOOKING
FOR ADDITIONAL GRANT
OPPORTUNITIES AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL THERE'S TWO MORE YEARS OF
THIS PARTICULAR GRANT THAT AND-
WERE ALWAYS LOOKING FOR.
ADDITIONAL FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES. YEAH I'M JUST
SENATE THINK ABOUT HOW WE
USUALLY USE GRAY ALIENS. I GET
THE GRANT WORLD- YOU KNOW
WHETHER SEVEN GOVERNMENT ARE
FROM NOT NOT FOR PROFITS OFF
TENDER TIME LIMITED. AND YOU
THINK ABOUT HOW EL OBVIOUSLY
BECAUSE YOU DO USE YES AND THE
MONEY ON THE THINGS THE GRANT.
ASK YOU TO WRITE THAT'S WHAT
YOU DO BUT ALSO HOW TO USE THE
LEVERAGE A GRANT TO BUILD
CAPACITY RIGHT OUT OF THE
BILL'S PASSAGE AND AS FAR AS
THE MSW STIPEND. THERE IS A LOT
OF INTEREST IN THAT RIGHT NOW
AND ESPECIALLY AROUND MAYBE A
PART TIME MSW PROGRAM BECAUSE
THERE'S A LOT OF. AGENTS THAT
SOCIAL WORKERS ESPECIALLY OR
INTERESTED IN GOING ON TO THAT
MASTERS LEVEL AND HAVING AND- A
MORE ROBUST CAREER PATH SO.
WE'RE HAVING A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR COUNTY
PARTNERS AND AS WELL AS WITH
THEM. THE ADMINISTRATION FOR
pOPPORTUNITY IS THAT WE CAN.
EXPAND THAT IN PARTICULAR. INTO
ROLE WORK. PER BECAUSE WE'RE
INVEST IN TRAINING PEOPLE YACHT
SAIL INCREASING CASELOAD. IS
ARE WE ABLE TO RECRUIT THE KIND
OF A. WE HAVE OKAY. MORE OKAY
SLOW MORE WORK TO DO WE ABLE
RETAIN PEOPLE IN THE FEEL. I
MEAN I WE'RE DOING TRAINING OR
TRYING TO SEVERAS AS AS AS-
SOMETHING WE- NEED TO ADDRESS
OR IS THAT SOMETHING THAT SEEMS
TO BEING GOING OKAY AT THE
MOMENT I'M JUST TRYING TO GET A
SENSE OF. YOU KNOW. DO YOU HAVE
YOU HAVE THE PEOPLE WE NEED TO
TAKE CARE OF THE RISING
CASELOAD THAT THAT THAT
CERTAINLY. YOU KNOW WITH WERE
YOU DESCRIBED. I THINK WORK
FORCES OP IS ALWAYS A
CHALLENGE- WITH THE- STATE THAN
PROGRAM THAT WE BEGAN WITH THE
GRANT WAS INTENDED TO BE A POP
UP PILOT. DO USE SEE. WHAT
EFFECT IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO PURSUE.
ON THE ADULT RIGHT FIELD
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THERE IS
GOING TO BE THIS NEED- AND- SO-
WE'LL WE'LL SEE HOW IT WHAT THE
OUTCOME OF THAT PILOT IS AND-
IF IT'S SUCCESSFUL IN DOING
WHAT WE'RE INTENDING IT TO DO.
I THINK THAT. WE CAN'T WE CAN
RECRUIT BUT IT'S GONNA BE A
CHALLENGE. THE POPULATION
CONTINUES TO GROW SO WE WANT TO
REALLY. BE PREPARED FOR THAT.
OKAY SO DID YOU INSTANCE AND
I'LL JUST ADD THAT AS AS AT MR
LETZ MENTIONED THE WORKING
MASTER PLAN AGING WORKFORCE IS
COMING UP A LOT SO I THINK THAT
WE ANTICIPATE SEEING A NUMBER
OF RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE SPACE
FOCUSED ON WORK FORCE OKAY SO I
GUESS I'LL PUT IT IN- AND- YOU
HAVE THE GRANT. IT'S A THREE
YEAR GRANT. DESTROY AN
EVALUATION THE GET THE RESULTS
AND THEN EITHER WE LOBBY THE
FEDS FOR MORE TO GO I'M GOING
MONEY OR WE SAY IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR THE STATE TO PUT IN SOME
MONEY ETCETERA BUT- THE ODDS BE
SUREWE DON'T LET THIS
OPPORTUNITY GO TO WASTE IN
TERMS OF THE OTHER VALUE EIGHT.
NOW THIS ANYTHING IT'S A PILOT
LIKE OKAY TELL ME WHETHER
WORKED OR NOT RIGHT SO WE
SHOULD WE SHOULD HAVE THERE'S
AN EVALUATION PROCESS WRITTEN-INTO THE GRANT OKAY. WE'LL BE
GETTING I'M WORKING WITH THE UC
BERKELEY IS THE LEAD ON THIS
GRANT AND I'M WORKING WITH THEM
RIGHT NOW TO. GET A PRELIMINARY
REPORT ABOUT HOW THE FIRST YEAR
WENT TO BECAUSE- OF THE TEN
STUDENTS ALL OF THEM ARE IN
FIELD PLACEMENTS RIGHT NOW THAT
ARE IN- THE AGING APS FIELD
AND- WILL BE GETTING A REPORT
ON HOW. HOW IT'S GOING UP TO
THIS POINT EXCELLENT AND IT
DOESN'T KNOW THAT FOR EXAMPLE
YOU KNOW WE ONE NO WITH A STAY
IN THE FIELD BUT WE WON'T FIND
OUT UNTIL WE WE'D ENOUGH YEARS
TO SEE WHAT A STATE SO I MEAN
THAT'S- THAT HOPEFULLY
HOPEFULLY IF. THAT'S SOME PAUSE
RESULTS THAT WAY IN TERMS OF
RETENTION THEN WE SHOULD THAT
AND WE'RE SHORT A WORKFORCE
THAT WE MIGHT NEED TO THINK
ABOUT AS WE CONTINUE TO.
SUSTAIN THIS IS A- AS A WAY.
STRATEGY I DON'T HAVE FIGURES
ON. BUT ENACTED. I KNOW THAT
ARE SO WORKERS. TO RETAIN AT A
HIGHER LEVEL THAN CHILD WELFARE
SOCIAL OKAY. ALL RIGHT. THE
BURN OUT LEVELS A LITTLE BIT
LOWER OKAY. LINE OF THE BURN A
LEVELS PRETTY HIGH ON THE
CHILD'S HEAD IS A TEACHER SHINS
SO. ALL RIGHT. WELL THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT LET'S GO AHEAD AND
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO
HOUSING HOMELESS. THIS PROGRAM
UPDATE AND HOME SAFE PROGRAM.
WELCOME BACK AGAIN PLEASE
INTRODUCE YOURSELF FOR THE
RECORD I KNOW SO THAT IT FEELS
LIKE YOU'RE INJURED YOU SELF
OVER OVER AGAIN BUT- AS WE DO
THE EACH ITEM THIS IS. USEFUL
TO HAVE FOR THE RECORD BEFORE
WE START. TEN LOS WITH SOCIAL
SERVICES THANK YOU. SO IN TERMS
OF- HOME SAFE AGAIN YOUR AGENDA
NICELY- SUMMARIZES THE PROGRAM.
I WOULD JUST ADD THAT WE
ACTUALLY HAVE TWENTY FIVE
COUNTIES ARE CURRENTLY
PARTICIPATING RATHER THAN
TWENTY FOUR- BUTTE COUNTY WAS
ACTUALLY A LATE ADDITION TO THE
PROGRAM THEY WERE GIVEN AN
EXTENSION- TO APPLY GIVEN SOME
OF THE- WILD FIRES OCCURRING-
DURING. DURING THAT PARTICULAR
TIME. AND THEN IN TERMS OF
IMPLEMENTATION- JUST TO GIVE AN
UPDATE THEIR THROUGH DECEMBER
OF TWENTY NINETEEN- HAPPY TO
REPORT WE HAVE A SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FIFTY HOME SAY
PARTICIPANTS- ENROLLED IN THE
PROGRAM- WHO WERE PROVIDED SORT
OF A BROAD RANGE OF SERVICES.
SOME OF THE MORE COMMON- BEING-
RENTAL AND UTILITY A REAR AGES-
DEEP CLEANINGS LANDLORD TENANT
MEDIATION- MOBILITY RELATED-
MODIFICATIONS- TWO UNITS- I EAT
GRAB BARS AND RAMPS AND THINGS
OF THAT NATURE TO HELP PROMOTE
SORT OF SAFETY AND STABILITY-
FOR PROGRAM PARTICIPANTS- JUST
SORT OF THE UPDATE ON THE ON
THE PROGRAM. I KNOW THERE WAS A
SECOND QUESTION AS WELL ABOUT-
OUTCOMES WELCOME TO RE
MEASURING TO DETERMINE PROGRAM
SUCCESS- I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT
WERE CONTRACTING WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AT SAN
FRANCISCO TO. FORMALLY EVALUATE
THE PROGRAM SO LOOKING FORWARD
TO THAT HAPPENING. A AS NOTED
IN THE AGENDA THE PURPOSE OF
THE PROGRAM IS TO SORT OF
PROMOTE THE SAFETY IN THE
HOUSING STABILITY OF PROGRAM
PARTICIPANTS- AS SUCH- YOU CSS
GOING TO BE LOOKING WORKING
CLOSELY EXCUSE ME- WITH-
GRANTEE COUNTIES IN WITH- THE
DEPARTMENT- TO ASSESS THE
IMPACT OF THE INTERVENTIONS
PROVIDED THROUGH THE PROGRAM IN
TERMS OF. FUTURE APS REFERRALS
AND FUTURE INCIDENTS. HOMELESS
SUPPORT THE SIX AND THE TWELVE
MONTH PARKS. THE BE CONDUCTING
SO OF COST BEEN ANALYSIS. OF
THE OF THE PROGRAM AS WELL SO
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE WAYS
WE'RE GONNA BE LOOKING AT A
COMES TO DETERMINE PROGRAM'S
SUCCESS IN TERMS OF YOUR YOUR
THIRD QUESTION AND SORT OF ANY
INITIAL SUCCESS IS. STILL
FAIRLY EARLY WE ARE- WE DO HEAR
FROM OUR COUNTIES ON A REGULAR
BASIS IN TERMS OF- CASE STUDIES
ANECDOTES SORT OF SAYING HOW
BENEFICIAL THE PROGRAM CLIENTS
OR HELP. IN PARTICULAR DAYS
BUT- IN TERMS OF THE MORE
FORMAL PROGRAM EVALUATION BEING
CONNECTED BY UCSF WERE STILL
SORT OF IN THE IN THE EARLY
STAGES SO NOTHING NOTHING
OFFICIAL REPORT AT THIS POINT.
THANK YOU. RIGHT HELLO ONCE
FINANCE. IN JUST A BECAUSE THIS
WAS ALLOCATED TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT WOULDN'T
WINDED AT WHAT POINT IN TIME
SERVICE DECEMBER TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WHEN USED FOR STARTED
TO FUND. RIGHT YEAH I WAS. THE
CITY NINETEEN. YEAH SO. YES I
SAID WHY SEARS SO IN DECEMBER
TWENTY EIGHTEEN I START
ALLOCATE FUNDS USED SORRY RIGHT
SO IT TONY BECAUSE RIGHT
BECAUSE WE DID IN THE BUDGET AX
TWENTY EIGHTEENS THAT BE JULY
FIRST YOU GOT MONEY START
GETTING MONEY OUT DECEMBER
RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT AND A WHAT
BUT WE ACTUALLY HAD SORT OF A
SIX MONTH- PROGRAM. LIMITED IS
CHAIRED. IN WORK WE WORK WITH
COUNTY CLOSELY TO MAKE SURE
THERE ARE SORT PROGRAM
IMPLEMENT MILES SALUTE
PARTNERSHIPS EXECUTING
CONTRACTS THAT SORT OF THING
SO- COUNTIES REALLY STARTED IN
EARNEST MORE IN IN THE SPRING
TO EARLY SUMMER TWENTY NINETEEN
SORT OF A REALLY OUT OF OUT
OVER TO WERE REALLY AT THE
FIGHT ABOUT A YEAR A LITTLE
LESS THAN A YEAR LESS THAN A
YEAR YEAH I THINK ALL RIGHT SO
SOFTLY WILL GET BETTER NO I.
ORDERED BRING DOWN WE
ABSOLUTELY OKAY ALL RIGHT. NAME
CONSCIOUS OF IT TAKES SOME TIME
TO GET RIGHT OKAY. ALL RIGHT-
ALL RIGHT WELL WE LOOK FORWARD
TO HEARING MORE MORE ABOUT THIS
AT SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY PEOPLE
ON ALL THE TIME RIGHT RIGHT
RIGHT SO THAT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR FOR THREE
YEARS THAT'S WHAT IT'S ABOUT
SIX THOUSAND AND I REALIZED
CALIBRATION COPS AND STUFF
BUILT INTO THAT CELL. ALL RIGHT.
OKAY AND- ESERVER OF SPORT I
MEAN UCSF LOOKING AT THIS AND
OTHER DEVELOPING ABOUT A DAYS
LOOKING AT WHAT PERSON. SAGE OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN THE PROGRAM
IF THEY WEREN'T IN THE PROGRAM
I KNOW IT'S A LITTLE BIT
CONJECTURE WITH. ENDED UP WELL
I'VE SEE THIS ABOUT SAFETY AS
APS PROGRAM BUT- WOULD PERHAPS
FIND SELVES EITHER. HOMELESS
ARE IN A- AND AT A SITUATION
WHERE THEY MAY BE HARMED- IF
THE PROGRAM WASN'T SO I'M JUST
I GUESS SENSE OF HOW. THE WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT FOR EVALUATION
I MEAN AGAIN AT THE TRUCKING
AND MORE- OR FUTURE INCIDENTS
OF HOMELESSNESS AND FUTURE
INCIDENTS OF APS REFERRALS- GO
TO THOSE THAT ARE ACTUALLY
PARTICIPATING IN THE PROGRAM
YEAH I MEAN I GUESTS AND MAKE A
YES NO TRYING TO. IN ORDER TO
MEASURE THE OUTCOME OF THE
PROGRAM PEOPLE WERE IN THE
PROGRAM THE AND REALIZING YEAH
I HAVE TO JUST FOR DIFFERENT
THINGS IS THAT SO WHAT DEGREE
PEOPLE WHO. BECAUSE THEY HAD
AVAILABILITY PROGRAM WHAT IS OF.
WELL HAVE HOUSING- OF THE OF
THE MORE STABLE SITUATIONS AND
IF THEY IF THEY HAD. THEY DID
NUYS SOON THE PROGRAM'S NOT SO
LARGE THAT UNFORTUNATELY YET
YOU CAN'T COVER EVERYBODY SO
YOU TRY HAPPENED A FORTUNE AND
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO A LITTLE
BIT OF COMPARISON YEAH I'M SURE
THEY'LL DO THAT NOW. OKAY ALL
RIGHT. SO IS A TO SAY THAT
BECAUSE WE WANT TO TRY TO GET
EVERYONE BUT THE REALITY IS
THAT YEAH OKAY EVEN THOUGH
MAKES FOR BETTER EVALUATION-
ALRIGHT. PRETTY GOOD OKAY
SELECT ALL RIGHT- AND THEN I
THINK WE HAVE A PROPOSAL FOR
INVESTMENT SO THANKS SO MUCH
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION. SEE THIS
IS FROM CWD A RIGHTS AND HANSON
EXPAND AND ENHANCE ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES ALL RIGHT
WELCOME. SO EASY ASKS YOU CAN
KEEP THREE MINUTE PRESENTATION
OF THE BUDGET REQUESTS WE MAY
HAVE WITH QUESTIONS MORE
OPPORTUNITIES EXPLORE. THE
THINGS. SHE'S GOOD AFTERNOON TO
EIGHT A CIRCUMVENT. RED LIGHTS
ON CAN YOU HEAR ME YES GOT IT
OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY NAME ASSURING MIX
BATON AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF SAN FRANCISCO
DEPARTMENT OF DISABILITY AND
AGING SERVICES. I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION AND A
BROAD COALITION OF STAKEHOLDERS
TO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT TO
REDUCE SENIOR HOMELESSNESS BY
EXPANDING AND ENHANCING THE
ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES
PROGRAM. WE'RE REQUESTING A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONGOING STATE FUNDS. THEAPS
PROGRAM WAS ESTABLISHED
ESTABLISHES A STATEWIDE TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN RESPONSE PROGRAM
OVER TWENTY YEARS AGO. SINCE
THAT TIME WE'VE SEEN
SIGNIFICANT RAPID GROWTH OF THE
SENIOR POPULATION IN CALIFORNIA
PARTICULARLY OVER THE LAST TEN
YEARS. THE INDIVIDUALS WE'RE
SEEING HAVE MORE COMPLEX NEEDS
AND NEED MORE HELP THAN WE CAN
GIVE THEM RIGHT NOW. THIS IS
COMPOUNDED BY THE HOUSING
CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA WHICH IS
PARTICULARLY THREATENING FOR
LOW INCOME PEOPLE WHO ARE
MARGINALLY HOUSE. WHEN A PS WAS
FIRST CREATED WE DID NOT
ANTICIPATE THESE TRENDS AND
GROWING NEEDS. APS CLIENTS ARE
AT UNIQUE RISK OF BECOMING
HOMELESS DUE TO THE TO ABUSE
AND SELF NEGLECT. DEEP
DESTABILIZING LIFE EVENTS SUCH
AS FINAL UP SORRY FINANCIAL
EXPLOITATION OR LOSS OF A
PARTNER CAN QUICKLY ESCALATE TO
AN ONGOING STATE OF HOUSING
CRISIS. THE CURRENT FUNDING
WHICH IS MOSTLY COUNTY
REALIGNMENT DOESN'T COVER THIS
NEW GROWING COHORT THAT NEEDS
MORE INTENSIVE SERVICES. SAID
LIKE TO SPEAK BRIEFLY ABOUT
RECENT A RECENT SUCCESS WE'VE
HAD IN SAN FRANCISCO AT THE
HOME SAFE PROGRAM. THE PROGRAM
IS HELP BRING OUR APS TEAM IN
CLOSER COLLABORATION WITH OUR
HOMELESSNESS DEPARTMENT AND
CONTINUUM OF CARE. AND IT'S
PROVIDE A CRITICAL NEW
RESOURCES TO HELP KEEP PEOPLE
HOUSE. WE SEEN REALLY GREAT
SUCCESS WITH THESE EFFORTS- I
JUST WANT TO SHARE ONE EXAMPLE.
HOBBY YEAR NOT HIS REAL NAME IS
A SEVENTY THREE YEAR OLD MAN
LIVING ALONE AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROPERTY FOR FORMALLY
HOMELESS SENIORS. HE WAS
REFERRED TO HOME SAVE SUPPORT
DUE TO SELF NEGLECT. DID WAS
ONGOING HOARDING IN CLUTTERING
BEHAVIORS IS HEALTH AND SAFETY
OR COMPROMISE AND HE HAD
RECEIVED AN EVICTION NOTICE. HE
COULDN'T OPEN THE DOOR WAS UNIT
THE WINDOWS IN HIS UNIT WERE
BLOCKED BY CLOTHING PILED UP TO
THE CEILING. HE'D BEEN SLEEPING
ON A PALLET IN THE HALLWAY OF
THE BUILDING. HE HAD FAILED HIS
LAST THREE UNIT INSPECTIONS AND
RECEIVED AN EVICTION NOTICE. OF
YOUR WAS WORKING WITH A LEGAL
CLINIC FOR ASSISTANCE WITH THE
EVICTION NOTICE BUT NEEDED MORE
INTENSIVE SUPPORT IN CONNECTION
TO SUPPORT OF SERVICES. HE HAD
TO UNDERGO A DEEP CLEANING AND
IS HOME BUT WAS HESITANT TO DO
SO HE DIDN'T WANT TO GIVE AWAY
ALICE THINGS. IT TOOK SEVERAL
VISITS FOR HOME SAFE SOCIAL
WORKER TO BUILD REPORT AND GAIN
HAVE YEARS TRUST BUT SHE WAS
ABLE TO COLLABORATIVELY DEVELOP
A PLAN WITH HIM. USING HOME
SAFE FUNDS WE SCHEDULE INCLUDED
A DEEP CLEANING OF HIS UNIT. WE
WORK TO THE CLIENT TO IDENTIFY
NEEDED REPAIRS AND COORDINATED
WITH PROPERTY MANAGEMENT TO
SCHEDULE THE FIXES. WE HELP
THEM GET CONNECTED TO NECESSARY
RESOURCES INCLUDING IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES AND MONEY
MANAGEMENT. AND DEVELOPED HIS
OWN PERSONAL SAFETY NET. WITH A
DEEP CLEANING COMPLETE. AND
HAVE YOUR CONNECTED TO OTHER
ONGOING SUPPORTS WE CLOSE THE
HOME SAFE CASES A SUCCESS.
WE'RE ALSO FINDING THROUGH HOME
SAFE THAT THESE CASES REQUIRE
EVEN MORE TIME AND DEDICATED
ATTENTION THAN WE HAD
ANTICIPATED. SO WHAT THE PROS
PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU WILL GET
THE STATE. THE PROPOSAL BEFORE
YOU TODAY WILL STRENGTHEN A
CRITICAL SAFETY NET SERVICE.
WITH A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT THE APS PROGRAM CAN
ADDRESS THE COMPLEX NEEDS OF
THE GROWING OLDER ADULT
POPULATION. AND WORK TO COMBAT
SENIOR HOMELESSNESS. INCREASE-STAFFING WILL ALLOW FOR LONGER
TERM CASE MANAGEMENT AND FOR
CASE WORKERS TO INTERVENE WITH
OUR MOST VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS
AT AN EARLIER POINT. HOPING TO
AVERT SOME OF THE MORE
DIFFICULT CRISIS SITUATIONS AND
CONNECT PEOPLE TO ONGOING
STABILIZING RESOURCES. THANK
YOU- ANY COMMENTS FROM. SOCIAL
SERVICES ALL RIGHT HELLO.
FINANCE ALL RIGHT- SO FIRST
WHAT THE HUNDRED MILLION IS
THIS A ONE TIME IS THIS AND I
AND I MEAN. THAT THIS IS THE ON
GOING. IT'S AN ON IT'S AN ON
GOING SO IT'S BUT I DID MILLION
IS FOR THE FIRST YEAR OUR
SYSTEM MULTI YEAR SO I'M JUST
RANDY STAND WHAT YOUR REQUEST
FUND AT. MONEY WEISS'S SAYS
THAT'S UNDER MILLIONS THOSE
UNDER MILLION OVER X. YEARS
VALUES FIRST YEAR WITH ON GOING.
THANK YOU DOCTOR PAN IT'S A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR REQUEST
THAT WOULD START IN THE BUDGET
YEAR. OBVIOUSLY START DATES.
CAN HAPPEN RIGHT WELL THE AS
WELL IF WE ACTUALLY GET TO BUY
ME YOU'RE ALL YOU'RE PROPOSING
REQUESTING IS HUNDRED MILLION
EVERY YEAR A YEAR AND IT WOULD
DO IT WOULD BE FOR THINGS THAT
WOULD IT WOULD LOWER THE AGE-
OF ELIGIBILITY FOR ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES FROM SIXTY
FIVE TO SIXTY. WHICH ALIGNS
ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES WITH
OTHER OLDER AMERICANS ACT
PROGRAMS AND IS ALSO RESPONSIVE
TO THE RESEARCH. THAT THE
FASTEST GROWING GROUP OF
HOMELESS ADULTS ARE PEOPLE OVER
THE AGE OF FIFTY SO WE
OBVIOUSLY ARE NOT TAKING IT TO
FIFTY BUT WE'RE BUT WE'RE
BRINGING IT DOWN. THAT WOULD
ALLOW FOR MORE INTENSIVE CASE
MANAGEMENT FOR THOSE PEOPLE WHO
ARE EITHER HOMELESS OR AT.
HIGHEST RISK OF BECOMING
HOMELESS. IT WOULD EXPAND THE
HOME SAFE PROGRAM. SO THAT MORE
COUNTIES COULD PARTICIPATE IN
FOR THAT THE COUNTIES THAT ARE
PARTICIPATING CAN GO DEEPER
INTO THEIR NEED- AND IT WOULD
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR COUNTIES TO
PARTICIPATE AND- MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAMS LIKE
FINANCIAL BE SPECIALIST TEAMS.
WHERE APS AGING SERVICE SAYS
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY LAW
ENFORCEMENT OTHER NONPROFIT-
FOR EXAMPLE PROVIDERS WERE
COLLABORATIVELY TO INTERVENE ON
FEET FINANCIAL ABUSE CASES. AND
THAT THE GOAL OF THIS EXPANSION
IN THE INSPIRATION OF THIS
EXPANSION WAS THE RESEARCH BY
DR TO SHELVE THAT HALF OF THE
OLDER ADULTS ON THE STREET
RIGHT NOW ARE OVER THE AGE OF
FIFTY. AND HALF OF THEM GOT
AFTER THE AGE OF FIFTY THEY
DIDN'T GET THERE BECAUSE OF A
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS THEY GOT
THERE BECAUSE OF A LIFE EVENT-
OR POVERTY OR RENT INCREASE AT
THAT PREVENTED THEM FROM BEING
ABLE. TO CONTINUE TO REMAIN
HOUSE SAFELY LIKE LIKE THE
PERCENT ON THE EXTREME
DESCRIBED. SO AND PRIVATE SHE
GOT TOUCH ON THIS BECAUSE YOU
KNOW WE GET TO THAT CENTER
FIFTY MILLION THING- SO. YOU
AYE CHANNEL THIS THROUGH A PS
AND THE REASON FOR BECAUSE WHAT
YOU DESCRIBE THIS OKAY YES
SOMEONE IS AT RISK FOR
HOMELESSNESS AND- WITH A NEED
HELP AND YOU KNOW THEY NEED
SOME HELP FOR THE REST SO. AB
AND SECURE IS TO. WHY THROUGH A
TS VERSUS SOME OTHER MECHANISM
RIGHT NOW ALL THIS MONEY RIGHT
NOW YOU CREATED A P. S. TO BE
THE TWENTY FOUR HOUR STATE WIDE
RESPONSE TO ABUSE AND NEGLECT-
AND YOU CREATED HOME SAFE
WITHIN THE APS PROGRAM. TO
SUPPORT. OUR EFFORTS ON BEHALF
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE ABUSED AND
NEGLECTED WE BELIEVE THAT. BY
BEING ABLE TO FURTHER ASSIST
PEOPLE WHO COME WITHIN THE
DEFINITION OF THE PROGRAM THE
YOU ALREADY CREATED WE CAN
SUPPORT THE ACTIVITIES THAT ARE
FUNDED. OUT OF THE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR FUND WE DEFINITELY SEE
THIS IS COMPLEMENTARY. BUT
THOSE ARE COMPETITIVELY
PROCURED THERE BASED ON
WEEKENDS SOME ENTITIES WILL
PARTICIPATE AND SOME WON'T.
WHERE'S THE PS PROGRAM IS THE
STATEWIDE MANDATED RESPONSE TO
USE GLASS. AND IT'S BASED ON
THE RESEARCH THAT IDENTIFIES
THOSE PEOPLE OPPORTUNE. HIGH
RISK THAT WE THINK THAT. WITH
WITH WHAT IS IN THE GRAND
SCHEME OF THINGS A PRETTY
MODEST ANNUAL INVESTMENT WE CAN
START TO CHIP AWAY AT THAT
GROUP THOSE PEOPLE OVER FIFTY.
FOR THE FASTEST GROWING GROUP
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE ON THE
STREET- AND WE BELIEVE THAT WE
CAP AND START TO BEND THE CURVE
ON THAT. WHILE OTHER
HOMELESSNESS SERVICES PROVIDERS
WERE FUNDED THROUGH KEEP IT
HAPPENED THE NEW FIND THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS PROPOSED CONTINUE
TO DO THINGS- LIKE DO BOOT TO
STAND UP NAVIGATION CENTERS ARE
TOO LONG TERM RENTAL SUBSIDY
PROGRAMS- AND THE OTHER VARIOUS
GREAT THINGS THAT COULD BE
FUNDED. OUT OF THAT FOR. SO
IT'S AS IF THIRTY AND HERE YOU
SEE EIGHT. ADULT EIGHT SIXTY
SIXTY FIVE WHO. ARE WHO
IDENTIFIED WITHIN THE APS DUDE.
HOW DO YOU HAVE AN ESTIMATE HOW
MANY PEOPLE WERE TALKING ABOUT
ROUGHLY. THE STATE. ELIZA
REALLY WE DON'T HAVE AN S. TO
OF THE OF PEOPLE THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY COME TO OUR
ATTENTION. BUT I THINK THAT THE
ESTIMATE THAT WE HAVE IN THE WE
CAN BE SURE BACK UP WITH YOU
AND YOUR STAFF. IS A TO BE
ABOUT THIRTY THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL VICTIMS OF ELDER
ABUSE AND NEGLECT. THAT COULD
BE ASSISTED WITH THE
AUGMENTATION WERE HAPPY TO
SHARE THAT YOU GOT YOUR YOUR
YOUR OLD PROJECTING YEAH YEAH I
THIS FUND WOULD ESSENTIALLY
ASSIST ABOUT THREE HUNDRED.
THIRTY THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
PEOPLE WITH THE CASE MANAGEMENT
AND SAFE AND HOME SAFE AND THEN
THE OTHER PART IS THIS. BEST
PRACTICES CENTER THAT'S
DIFFERENT OKAY. ALL RIGHT OKAY
SAYING ALL RIGHT NOW THANK YOU
ANY OTHER COMMENTS THAN NATIONS
ALL RIGHT. NOW HOME SAFE IS
JUST STARTING RATE SO WE WORST
SO WE'RE STILL WAITING TO GET
SOME REST IT'S FOR THAT BY ARE
YOU TALK ABOUT ADDITIONAL
EXPERIENCE READY THAT SAN
FRANCISCO SAID AND WE'RE IS
EAGER TO WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT AND YOU SEE A FAST
SAYS ANYONE TO GET THAT
EVALUATION INFORMATION OKAY
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW WE HAVE FIVE
MILLION PER YEAR FOR THREE
YEARS RIGHT ON I'M SELF HOME
SAFE SO WE ARE LOOKING AT 25%
FROM FIVE TO TWENTY FIVE IT
ALSO I MEAN THE GOVERNOR'S ALSO
PROPOSED A BIT HARD TO ACTUALLY
TO TWENTY FIVE TO THIRTY ASSUME
YOU'RE NOT SAYING THAT. TO TAKE
AWAY THE FIVE SO WRECKED. THE
GONNA SAY THAT THAT. THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED A- A ROOT
CAUSES STUDY- THAT WE THINK
THIS COMPLEMENTS AS WELL AND WE
REALLY DO NEED TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT'S HAPPENING IMMEDIATELY
BEFORE. SOMEONE GOES FROM ONE
HOUSE STE- YEAH. FROM HOUSE TO
ON HOUSED IN AND WHAT COULD ANY
OF US TO. TO HAVE PREVENTED
THAT AND FOR THOSE PEOPLE WHO
FALL INTO HOMELESSNESS HOW COME
WE QUICKLY- BEFORE THE D.
COMPENSATING THAT OCCURS. GET
PEOPLE RE HOUSE AND SO WE
BELIEVE THAT THE EXPERIENCE OF
HOME SAFE ALSO ELUCIDATE. AND
COMPLEMENT THAT RESEARCH. OKAY
I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THAT
APPROACH BECAUSE I THINK IN. MY
VIEW AYE THIS IS THAT. WHEN
SOMEONE BECOMES HOMELESS I MEAN
THAT'S THAT'S A- CRITICAL
EVENTS RATE I MEAN- TERMITE
PEOPLE I DON'T THINK PEOPLE.
END UP HOMELESS BECAUSE THEY
HAVE MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEMS
RIGHT WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT. NOT
SAY THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
DON'T HAVE MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
IS THAT WHEN THEY BECOME
HOMELESS THOSE GET COMMENDED
EXACERBATED AND THEN YOU GO LOW
AT ALL THE- HOLD THIS. TO SEE A
THE AS WELL. ACTUALLY IT'S- TO
HELP US. BECAUSE I KNOW HOW SHE
FOR AND SAME WITH A ISSUE AND
TYPES THINGS. KEEP FOR HOW. THE
IS THAN TRYING TO REACH SOME
WHAT THEY'RE READY ON STATE AND-
BASIC. THE SPECIAL THAT AND
EVERYTHING ELSE THE UNSTATED.
BECAUSE THERE WAS SO. I DO
APPRECIATE. AND TRUST PART YES
WANT. IT JUST AT THE ONE OF THE
THINGS WE SEE A LOT OF IS THE
MAIN. AND SO WORSE A CAR AND IN
IN THE FORM OF DEMENTIA WERE
SEEN. CERTAINLY THE NEED FOR
LAW TERM CASE. AND UP. SO WILL.
VERY SPECIAL SIR. SO SING HOME
PEOPLE IMMERSING ON PEOPLE WHO
HAVE THAT CONTENT HAVE
IMPAIRMENT WE KNOW THAT WE NEED
TO SPEND MORE TIME SO THEM.
MUCH OF THIS PROPOSAL IS AROUND
LIKE- LENGTHENING THE TIME THAT
WE HAVE AS WITH APS WORKERS TO
SPEND. WITH PEOPLE WHO REALLY
NEED HELP TO TRANSITION. EITHER
INTO HOUSING OR AT LEAST IN. OF
STABLE. SUCH XIN. ALL RIGHT.
OKAY ALL RIGHT THANKS SO MUCH
FOR YOUR THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SO
IT'S MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT ON
A PROTECTIVE SERVICES WELCOME
GOOD AFTERNOON LISA COLEMAN
WITH CALCUTTA WHILE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS SOUNDS LIKE AN
ASTRONOMICAL AMOUNT I WOULD
POINT OUT THAT WITH THE NUMBER
OF CASES OF SELF NEGLECT IF WE
DON'T ACT MORE PRO ACTIVELY
THOSE OLDER ADULTS ARE GOING TO
ULTIMATELY GOING TO SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES WHICH WILL
BE A SIGNIFICANTLY GREATER COST
YOU SAID IT BEFORE SENATOR PAN
WE PAY FOR THESE THINGS ONE WAY
OR ANOTHER. YOU PAID FOR THE
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM BECAUSE
BETTER TO DO AN OUNCE OF
PREVENTION AND A POUND OF CURE
YES. I QUICKLY. ANOTHER A- OF
YOUR PREVENTION THE FAST TEAMS
ARE AMAZING OMBUDSMAN SPEAK
VERY HIGHLY OF THEM BUT THEY
ARE NOT CONSISTENT ACROSS THE
STATE BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
ALWAYS SUPPORTED WITH PAID
STAFF AND THEIR COMPLEX TO GET.
ALL THE PARTIES TO THE TABLE
BUT WHEN WE GET ALL THE
DIFFERENT PARTIES TO THE TABLE
THE FAST PROGRAMS ARE
FANTASTIC. AT PREVENTING THE
HEMORRHAGE OF FINANCIAL LOSS
LOU IF WE COULD STOP SOME OF
THE FINANCIAL ABUSE WE COULD
HAVE OLDER ADULTS PAYING FOR
THEIR OWN LONG TERM CARE
INSTEAD OF THE STATE HAVING TO
PICK UP THE DIED BECAUSE- THAT
THE PREVENTION IT'S JUST TOO
LATE WHEN THE MONEY IS ALREADY
GONE TO. BIG SUPPORTER APS
PROGRAM. THANK YOU WELCOME. THE
WHITE SEA YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF EXPANDING AND
ENHANCING THE APS SERVICES
PROGRAM- WE DO THINK IT'S A
COMMON SENSE MEASURE PROPOSAL-
TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS AND TO
PROVIDE HOUSING STABILITY FOR
THE APS CLIENTS THANK YOU THANK
YOU. WELCOME JUST TO GET
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES WE ARE A CO SPONSOR IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL
TO EXPAND AND ENHANCE THE APS
PROGRAM WITH WHAT WE'RE SEEING
WITH THE GROWING. NUMBER OF
HOMELESSNESS POPULATION AS WELL
AS A GROWING NUMBER OF ABUSE
AND NEGLECT. AND WHAT WE KNOW
OF THE GROWING AGING POPULATION
THAT'S COMING NOW COMBINE THAT
WITH THE GREAT WORK OF OUR
COUNTY APS PROGRAMS ON THIS IS
A REALLY CRITICAL TIME TO MAKE
THIS IMPORTANT INVESTMENT AND
WE ARE JUST SUPPORT THINKING.
THANK YOU. WELCOME REBEKAH
GONZALEZ NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER ANOTHER CO SPONSOR OF
THIS REQUEST WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT APS- IT WITH OUR
GROWING SENIOR POPULATION HAS
BECOME MORE IMPORTANT- AD AND
IT WILL BECOME MORE IMPORTANT
AS TIME GOES ON AND WITH THE
MASTER PLAN ON AGING IT ALL
MAKES SENSE TO HAVE ALL THESE
PROGRAMS WORK TOGETHER. THANK
YOU. WELCOME A KELLY BROOKS ON
BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS OF ENTER AND
RIVERSIDE COUNTIES I'M ALSO
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN
COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA WE ARE
ONE OF THE CO SPONSORS OF THIS
PROPOSAL- THE URBAN COUNTIES
ASSOCIATION IS REALLY TRYING TO
LOOK BROADLY AT THE
HOMELESSNESS ISSUE AND TRY TO
PRIORITIZE PREVENTION AND NOT
JUST SORT OF IF TRYING TO
TRYING TO STEM THE TIDE AS AS
WELL JOB ACTIVE THINGS TO SAYS
FOR EXPERIENCING SAYS AND THIS
IS ONE OF THE- EIGHTIES FOR US
AS WE- LOOK AT THE LANDSCAPE.
OUT HOMELESSNESS AND THINK-
ADULTS- AND THAT THE LINK WITH
HOMELESS ADULTS AND THOSE OVER
THE AGE OF FIFTY IS SO CRITICAL
THAT THIS IS AN IMPORTANT THING.
WELCOME TO CHAIRMAN. ANYWAY
WITH CA A CALIFORNIA A CO
SPONSOR OF THE- APS PROPOSAL
WHICH IS ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WELCOME
DEVON ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF THE
CEMETERY COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THE PROPOSAL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. WELCOME CAROL SOURCE
LEADERSHIP CALIFORNICATION ON
AGING THE COMMISSION IS ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL.
EXCELLENT THANK YOU. RIGHT OKAY
SO ALRIGHT SO WE'LL HOLD ALL
THE ITEMS OPEN AND- THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATIONS
AND- I THINK WE A LOT A WE HAVE
A LOT OF WORK TO DO AND WE'RE
DESTROYING THE WITH THIS FIRST
HEARING I THINK WE'RE JUST YOU
CAN SEE WHAT STRAIN IT THE
EDGES AND LOOKING FORWARD TO-
TO THE- FURTHER. DEVELOPMENTS
AND- OF THE VARIOUS PROPOSALS-
AND APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
PHARMACEUTICAL SERVICES- AND-
HELPING SUPPORT. PEOPLE SO
THANKS VERY MUCH. OKAY WELL
WITH THAT- I THINK THAT
CONCLUDES. SORT OF FUNNY
STRANGE OKAY WITH THAT WERE YOU
HAVE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA FOR
THIS HEARING OF THE SENATE
BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER THREE ON
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES. I
THANK EVERYONE FOR BEING HERE
WE ARE NOW ADJOURNED THANK YOU.